Schießt da jemand? Schießen wir? Das war keine AK. Ich glaub nicht.
Ihr hört CRE Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und ich begrüße alle bei diesem so selten erscheinenden Format. Aber jetzt ist wieder Herbst und da wird man immer ganz kreativ. Und ich hab mal wieder ein paar Themen auf meine Liste gesetzt, die da schon etwas länger rumdümpeln. Und heute blicken wir mal ein wenig in die Geschichte und so wie die Welt sich eigentlich an manchen Stellen zusammenfügt. Konkret soll der Blick gehen nach Kurdistan und dazu begrüße ich meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich den Enno Lenze. Hallo. Ja, Enno, wir haben es keine Ahnung, wie lange wir da schon drüber reden, aber stimmt schon zwei Jahre oder so. So ist das manchmal. Andererseits finde ich den Zeitpunkt jetzt ganz gut gewählt. Kann man ja mal kurz vorweggreifen. Du kommst mehr oder weniger gerade aus Kurdistan.
Ja, am Freitag mit dem letzten Flugzeug vor der Luftraumsperrung noch rausgekommen.
Heute ist ein Dienstag, um das gleich in Kontext zu setzen. Genau, da kommen wir dann auch noch drauf zu. Aber wie es hier so usus ist, würde ich ganz gerne erst mal ein wenig darüber reden, wie du eigentlich so bist. Wir beide, das kann man auch gleich dazu sagen, wir kennen uns irgendwie auch schon gefühlt ewig mittlerweile.
20 Jahre müssten es sein.
Mindestens, ja. Noch so aus alten CCC-Tagen, wo wir beide irgendwie rumgewuselt haben. Jeder so auf seine Art, was ja auch mal sehr, wie soll ich sagen, veranstaltungsaffin. Das heißt, du hast auch schon mal so eine Ader gehabt, auch einfach mal Dinge loszutreten, wo andere jetzt vielleicht erst mal so nicht draufkommen. Ich erinnere mich da an so eine Zuggeschichte.
Ja, ein Museumszug, Schartan, um, nee, das erste Mal ging ja wirklich zum Kongress, zum ich glaube 18C3, 19C3, ich weiß es nicht, 2002. Genau, von Bingen am Rhein, mit der rhein-hessischen Eisenbahn, mit zwei Schienenbussen, in nur 18 Stunden bis zum Alexanderplatz. Das war auch das einzige Mal, dass es geklappt hat, weil das wie immer so ein Problem war mit, die Leute müssen vorher zahlen und dann weiß man erst, ob es stattfindet, also so das Kickstarter-Prinzip. Aber heute sind das Leute gewohnt und, hier muss ich ja nicht erzählen, wie planungsaffin Nerds sind. Es ist ein Wunder, dass das das eine Mal geklappt hat.
Ja, aber da kommt man so ein bisschen auch auf den Geschmack. Ich finde, solche Aktionen zeigen einem dann auch manchmal so, ja man muss manchmal auch einfach das Unmögliche denken und dann ist es eigentlich auch am Ende gar nicht so das große Problem.
Nö, das war, wie so oft es ging los mit einem Newsgroup-Post, so hallo, ich will einen Zug schartern, wie mache ich denn das? Wir wollen zu einer Veranstaltung nach Berlin und in dem Fall einfach die richtige Person getroffen, dann hat sich Scamp, also aus der Demoszene, der macht so Demoszenepartys große, gemeldet und sagte, ich kann mir vorstellen, wo du hin willst und ich habe einen Zug, lass machen.
Ich dachte, das war einfacher als gedacht. Und dann lief es.
Also manchmal hat man Glück.
Und dann hast du dir den selben Spaß quasi nochmal dafür, das holländische Camp, was war das, what the heck war das?
Genau. Wir haben es versucht, es hat aber nicht geklappt, weil da hätten wir einen richtig geilen Sonderzug gehabt. Aber es war wieder die Sache zwischen, wir brauchen vorher einen signifikanten Teil des Geldes, können dann erst richtig die Streckenplanung machen, den Zug mieten und so weiter. Und daran ist es letzten Endes gescheitert, dass am Anfang alle gesagt haben, wollen wir, dann aber die wenigsten gesagt haben, jo, ich zahle, um dann zwei Wochen später zu sagen, bis wann sollte ich noch mal zahlen? Also das war leider so, liegt halt in der Natur der Sache, dass das einfach schwierig ist, was irgendwie schade war, aber zumindest einmal gemacht.
Später bist du dann etwas ausgeschert und hast dich irgendwie ganz anderen Dingen zugewendet. Mal grob gesagt, du hast dich Berlin zugewendet.
Ja, wie alle. Irgendwann landet man hier.
Ja, aber sehr, also ja nicht nur, dass du hierhergezogen bist, sondern du hast ja dann hier auch jetzt, weiß ich gar nicht, ob ich so begriffsfest bin, Berlin Story ist hier der richtige Begriff, so eine Art Museum.
Also sind mehrere Teile, es besteht halt aus dem Verlag, der historische Berlin-Bücher macht. Das ist so mein Alltagsjob, dass ich da Verleger bin. Und dann gibt es das Museum zur Geschichte Berlins, also Berlin Story Museum. Und jetzt eben seit diesem Jahr die Dokumentation Hitler, wie konnte es geschehen? Das ist die größte NS-Dokumentation der Welt. Und das ist sozusagen der Hobby-Teil, oder wie man sagen will, den ich mache, wo ich so bei den letzten zehn Jahren irgendwie in Berlin-Geschichte gekommen bin. Und es blittet sich halt wie immer auf in so den einen Teil, den man braucht, um seine Miete zu zahlen, und den anderen Teil, den man macht, weil es einfach ein gutes Projekt ist.
Und wie bist du an dieses Thema überhaupt rangekommen?
Ich meine, Geschichte hat mich immer irgendwie interessiert, aber so wie ein Thema interessiert. Nicht, dass man sagt, da mache ich jetzt was, sondern gerade Berlin-Geschichte ist total wirr und interessant.
Du hast auch nie Geschichte studiert oder so?
Ich habe Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik studiert. Da wurde mir gesagt, damit kann man alles machen. Recht behalten. Habe ich dann auch nur vier Semester gemacht, dann wusste ich alles. Und nee, aber nie was in dem Bereich studiert. Und eigentlich kam mein Interesse so aus diesen ganzen wirren kalten Kriegsgeschichten, also so James Bond-artige Stories, wo ja genug in der Art wirklich passiert ist. Und ich fand diese ganze Technik einfach irre. Also was leider durch Kriege immer ein Technik-Fortschritt kommt und gerade im Kalten Krieg an Nachrichtentechnik, was die an Jets gebaut haben, an Weltraumtechnik, also immer mit der Intention, so das Wettrennen gegen die anderen. Aber was es da für wilden Kram gab. Und dann kommt man natürlich zwangsläufig auf die politische Schiene, weil es waren ja jetzt nicht Technik-Nerds, die gesagt haben, lass mal irgendwie ein größeres Kampfjet bauen, sondern es ging ja darum, wie knall ich den anderen halt besser ab. Und dann ist es wie immer, man fängt mit dem Thema an und bleibt behängen und sagt, ja, aber warum war das so und warum war das so und warum war das so? Und irgendwann hängt man dann bei irgendwelchen Kriegen zwischen Preußen und Dänemark und denkt, Moment mal, ich war gerade aber noch bei Satellitentechnik, irgendwie ist es abgedriftet. Und dann war es so, dass ich zu der Zeit, als ich wieder nach Berlin kam, einfach Geld aus der Dotcom-Zeit noch über hatte. Also nicht in den Mengen, wie Leute, die arbeitsamer waren. Ich war immer ein bisschen faul, aber genug, um irgendwas Sinnvolles zu tun. Und dann hatte ich die Möglichkeit, hier einen Verlag zu kaufen, der halt Berlins Geschichte macht. Und eigentlich war der Punkt, ich habe immer gesagt, ihr macht das falsch, ihr müsst E-Books machen, ihr müsst die Homepage anders machen. Also irgendwie, naja, da hat man immer gesagt, kein Wunder, dass die Verlage sterben. Ihr seid halt salopp gesagt, alle zu blöd. Dann haben sie gesagt, echt, dann mach's selber. Und dann habe ich aber, als wir ernsthaft drüber nachgedacht haben, dann hat sie gesagt, ja, warum nicht?
Also, wie kam es denn überhaupt zu diesem Kontakt? Es kam jetzt nicht aus der Familie oder so?
Doch, in dem Fall wirklich aus der Familie. Also, das ist auch immer so eine Schwierigkeit, wenn man innerhalb der Familie Unternehmen kauft, dann heißt es ja immer, ah, hat man ein Geschenk bekommen. Ja, sicher, weil man Unternehmen einfach verschenken kann in Deutschland. Weil Unternehmer ja auch meist großherzig sind und sagen, wer möchte mein Unternehmen haben?
Ich glaube, man will es irgendjemandem machen.
Nee, habe ich im Prinzip einen größeren Teil meiner Ersparnisse reingehauen. Und dann aber, also, der Vorteil war, ich konnte mir die Sache vorher in Ruhe angucken. Ich habe gedacht, irgendwie, also, ich kam mir echt vor wie in so einem Steinzeitmuseum bisschen so. Also, dass die nicht mit Stein Feuer gemacht haben, um den Kaffee zu kochen, war so alles aus meiner Technik-Nerdsicht irgendwie. Also, es ging los so mit Fileserver näher. Also, der Klaus hat da ein paar Sachen. Ich habe hier welche. Ja, da drüben, der macht schon ganz komische Geräusche, der Computer. Also, irgendwie so, wo man halt aus IT-Sicht sagt, alter. Also, ich habe, aber gut, ich konnte mir vorstellen, worum es geht. Und dann hatte ich mir das so einen Monat angeguckt, so wie Praktikant oder so kann man sagen, und habe gesagt, ja, ich sehe ein bisschen Verbesserungspotenzial und ich sehe natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, Kohle mit zu verdienen, weil also da ging, also wenn ich nur mein Geschichtswissen befriedigen wollte, könnte ich auch Wikipedia leer lesen, sondern es war halt klar, es geht ja auch um Business. Und deswegen musste also beides passen. Und dann habe ich das Ding halt übernommen, aber ich habe halt nie was mit Verlagswesen zu tun gehabt. Aber mein Ansatz war auch anderer. Ich habe gesagt, das ist ja Geld verdienen ist im Kern eine kaufmännische Frage. Also du kannst im Prinzip Scheiße am Stiel verkaufen. Solange du gute Kundschaft hast, kannst du auch damit Geld verdienen. Also und habe dann aber fast ein halbes Jahr so IT-Hausmeister erst mal gemacht, im Prinzip mit dem ganzen Kram und Homepage bauen und E-Books anfangen überhaupt. Also es ist auch so ein Punkt E-Books, denkt man immer ganz simpel.
Also jetzt, wir reden jetzt ab der Zeit, als du es übernommen hast.
Genau so 2010 dann und da ich auch gemerkt, wie schwierig es in der Praxis war, vor allem 2010 aus so einer Adobe-Datei ein lesbares E-Book zu machen, was ein durchschnittlicher Kunde haben will. Also weil die Technik-Nerds sagen, na haus durch latex und dann kannst du es doch mit einem Datenkabel und dann musst du irgendwie dein Kindle jailbreaken. Also genau, das ist kein Business-Modell. Ja, aber da gibt es das kann man konvertieren, ja, kann man. Wie? Jetzt kommen wir wieder, das ist, also schien mir immer so wie die typische Unix zu Mac-Diskussion, ja, also ich kann das auf meinem Unix irgendwie machen und du sagst auf dein Mac, ja, ich kann es mit der Maus von rechts nach links ziehen und dafür benutze ich eine closed-source-Software, aber es funktioniert. Also so dieses alte, schwierige Thema, Ende vom Lied war. 2010 waren E-Books aber auch noch überhaupt nicht relevant, also für uns. Es ging in dem Unternehmen nur darum, den Anschluss nicht verpassen, also vorbereitet sein. Deswegen kommt man das in aller Ruhe machen auch. Ich habe nie einen E-Book-Reader benutzt, weil ich insgesamt verhältnismäßig wenig Bücher lese. Also, oder es kommt immer drauf an, ich denke im Bundesdurchschnitt lese ich sehr viel Bücher, aber im Verhältnis zu Buchaffinen Leuten wenig.
Oder im Verhältnis zu Verlagsinhabern.
Genau, die alles auf Papier wollen und ich lese Kram wirklich meist auf dem Handy, auch damals schon. Also da gab es ja schon sinnvolle Smartphones und ich habe halt auf dem Android, auf dem G1 schon E-Books gelesen oder halt auf dem iPhone 3, glaube ich, war damals noch so ungefähr das, was ich da hatte. Und dann habe ich mir erstmal einen Stapel E-Book-Reader gekauft und geguckt, was können die an Formaten, wie kriege ich die Daten drauf? Also weil ich habe gesagt, ein Datenkabel benutzt doch keiner. Also niemand will das irgendwie im Browser runterladen mit einem Datenkabel rüber. Also die Geräte kann ich ausschließen. Das ist ungefähr wie mit einem Palm-Pilot oder Palmtrio. Da konnte ich auch Apps runterladen und mit dem Datenkabel rüber spielen. Aber IPhone mit App Store hat dann jeder benutzt. Also es muss simpel sein. Und ganz viel so Sachen. Also war total spannend. Also so wie immer sich ein neues Thema angucken und halt was mitmachen. Und dann, also direkt noch in dieser Kuddel-Model-Phase hieß es dann, hey, hier ist noch ein Souvenir-Shop abzugeben unter den Linden. Weil da jemand raus will, würde das nicht passen. Satz Souvenirs unter den Linden, also am Brandenburger Tor quasi, also ein paar Minuten von da. Da kann man nichts falsch machen. Also was soll da bitte schief gehen? Und ich dachte so, Touristen gibt's, die geben Geld für Blödsinn aus. Und im Prinzip war es auch so, also lange Zeit, sodass ich dann also so eine Kombination hatte aus dem Verlag mit, sagen wir mal, tiefsinnigen Berlin-historischen Themen und so das andere Ende der Touristenskala, so blinkende, glitzernde Souvenirs für überteuerte Preise einfach. Und das war ganz interessant, weil da kamen halt dauernd Leute in den Shop und haben irgendwas gefragt. Die haben Sachen zu Berlin wissen wollen. Also meistens, wo ist die Mauer? Wo kann ich den Führerbunker sehen? Und wo gibt es irgendwie billig Essen und Trinken? Also billig und gut. Und da ist dann halt die Sache, wenn man auch selber da mal hinter dem Tresen steht eine Weile, dann kriegt man halt auch mit, was wollen so Touristen wissen? Also Touristen aus dem Rest der Welt, Touristen aus Deutschland oder Leute aus Berlin, die mit ihren Verwandten aus Deutschland hier sind, die aber selber auch gar nichts richtig von Berlin wissen, weil sie sich das nur marginal angeguckt haben. Daraus entstanden immer neue Ideen, was man so machen kann. Und also unter anderem dieses Museum, also die Berlin Story Museum mit 800 Jahre Berlin Geschichte in einer Stunde, war eine Sache, die die Ideen schon vorher entstanden. Aber halt dieses ein, also für diese Leute, die reinkommen und so die die drei, vier Fragen haben, warum, wo ist die Mauer, wo, also immer DDR und Hitler, das sind so die zwei Themen, sagt okay, wenn das wirklich 20 mal am Tag die Leute fragen und die wollen kein Buch lesen, da sagt man hier, ist mit vielen Fotos, nee, es muss einfach sein, wenn man dann sagt, wir machen Ausstellungstafeln, nee, da muss ich auch lesen, da tun die Augen so von weh, also Leute sind faul bis zum Umfallen. Das heißt, es muss etwas sein, ein Film, den man guckt oder ein Museum mit einem Audioguide. Und so entstehen dann zum Beispiel solche Ideen einfach durch den Dauerkontakt. Und im Prinzip zieht sich das bis heute durch. Einen Souvenirshop habe ich nicht mehr, weil sich da einfach der Markt geändert hat. Die Leute kaufen weniger und billigere Souvenirs nur noch und es gibt mehr Konkurrenz einfach, sodass das einfach ein härteres Business geworden ist. Also früher war es im Prinzip ein Selbstläufer und inzwischen ist es wirklich so, scheint mir wie im großen Elektromarktbereich, dass es um kleine Margen geht, hohen Durchsatz, Filialisierung und sagt, das ist nicht meine Welt und das fasse ich nicht an und mache es halt zu, mache was anderes. Aber dieses Berlin-Geschichte vermitteln, das fand ich spannend, also weil ich auch oft selber so kleine Touren durchs Museum gemacht habe oder Freunde durchgeführt habe oder mal Schulklassen oder so. Und gemerkt habe, die Leute haben Interesse, sie sind aber echt zu faul, sich mal zehn Minuten Text durchzulesen, also was so eine der wichtigsten Erkenntnisse war bei der Vermittlung. Und der nächste Punkt war, damit kann man kein Geld verdienen. Also es gibt ganz wenige private Museen in Berlin, die Geld verdienen, das ist aber echt maximal eine Handvoll, der Rest macht kein Geld und ist gefördert. Ich denke, sei es wie es ist, damit muss man dann halt leben und da muss man nur überlegen, kann ich es machen oder nicht. Und speziell, also das, was ich ewig im Kopf hatte, war schon vor vielen Jahren so dieses Latente nach rechts driften in der Gesellschaft. Also nicht, dass wir jetzt eine große gesellschaftliche Bewegung haben, dass alle nach rechts gehen, aber dass die Leute aus ihren Löchern kommen und halt nicht mehr so ein paar Rechte irgendwie mal am Rand, als so eine übliche Erscheinung von Demokratie, dass es Idioten gibt, sondern dass es mehr werden und dass die offener werden. Da sagt irgendwie, so wie immer, man sollte mal was tun, man müsste mal was tun, aber wie und was, und kompliziert. Und irgendwann verdichtete sich dann aber die Idee, also wo eigentlich zwei offensichtliche Sachen zusammen kamen. Ein Touri interessiert sich für Hitler und wirklich, wie oft wir gefragt wurden, wo es die Touren durch den Führerbunker gibt. Das kann man sich so als halbwegs gebildeter Mensch nicht vorstellen. Es kommt nicht nur von, sagen wir, Leuten, denen man wenig Bildung zuspricht, sondern wir haben auch heute ungefähr einmal die Woche Anfragen von deutschen Schulklassen, die Touren durch einen Führerbunker oder sowas haben wollen. Ja, oder auch, wir haben so ein Best-of von, also wo ich denke, Schüler sollen alle scheiße fragen, dafür sind wir da. Das ist super, dann wissen sie es besser, aber...
Die Lehrer sollten doch vielleicht schon mal davon gehört haben, dass der Bunker eingestampft wurde.
Ja, und auch wenn mich ein deutscher Geschichtslehrer fragt, ob der Bunker, in dem wir gerade sind, aus dem ersten oder zweiten Weltkrieg ist, dann ist das immer so schwierig, sagen wir mal. Oder auch, was wir hatten, dass jemand gesagt hat, naja, sie waren halt in einem Atomschutzbunker, da müssen sie sich jetzt ja nicht noch zweite Weltkrieg-Geschichten angucken. Die Storys von den Opfern sind ja im Prinzip immer die gleichen. Ich dachte ja, wir erinnern uns alle, wie in den 70er-Jahren die britischen Bomber über Berlin flogen oder so. Da verzweifelt man, aber auf der anderen Seite weiß man, warum man es macht und sagt, ja, dann geht es weiter. Und so kam es im Prinzip zudem. Es war immer so, sagen wir, die letzten sechs, sieben Jahre war es immer so, man hat so eine Idee und es geht weiter und es ist nicht fertig. Und jetzt seit diesem Jahr bin ich im Prinzip auf dem Punkt, dass ich sage, jetzt ist sozusagen stabil und fertig. Was mal ein schönes Gefühl ist, nachdem wir halt diese Dokumentation Hitler, wie konnte es geschehen, fertig gebaut und aufgebaut hatten. Und dies halt auch in einem zweiten Weltkriegsbunker, also am Anhalter Bahnhof, also dass man einen authentischen Ort hat.
Also ihr hattet jetzt nicht in diesem Laden, oder in Linden gibt es keine Ausstellungen.
Da gab es auch eine Ausstellung zur Berlin-Geschichte. Da war auch dann das Berlin Story Museum in einem Laden lokal eine Weile. Was super war, weil man da Laufkundschaft hat. Und die Idee war da immer günstig, also die Leute ranziehen, dass sie schnell was mitnehmen und dass es billig ist, dass sie es auch machen. Also da war es immer so, dass man 5 Euro inklusive Audioguide gezahlt hat. Und es stand halt dick dran, du bist in einer Stunde durch. Also wenn irgendwie ein Regenschauer kam, sind 100 Leute reingegangen und haben gesagt, naja, dann nutze ich die Stunde mal eben sinnvoll. Und das war eigentlich super, weil wir gesagt haben, wir erreichen Leute, die nicht zwingend deswegen gekommen sind. Das ist ja so der Marketing-Traum im Prinzip. So Hitler to go. Nee, das war ja noch nur Berlin-Geschichte. Bei der Hitler-Dokumentation war es halt schwieriger, weil wir gesagt haben, da ist es das Gegenteil. Da soll man nicht mal schnell durch, weil dann ist es eben so Sensationslust befriedigen, aber nichts vermitteln.
So ein bisschen wie so N24.
Genau, so die Hitler-Droge, das Hitler-Auto, das Hitler-Haus irgendwie. War schwierig. Und wir haben dann...
Was ist denn diesen Bunker hier?
Den gab es abzugeben, Glück gehabt. Ein Freund hat mich angerufen und gesagt, ey, willst du einen Bunker? Ich habe da irgendwie gelesen, da... Ja, das war ganz lustig. Der war schon seit den 90ern von einer privaten Firma genutzt. Und die Inhaber von der Firma wollten im Prinzip in Rente gehen und das abgeben, waren aber nicht in der Lage, sagen wir mal, ordentlich Marketing zu machen, dass das abzugeben ist, was mein Vorteil war, weil ich es dann quasi durch Zufall mitgekriegt habe. Und also ein Glücksgriff einfach. Der Vorteil an der Location ist, also zum einen authentischer Ort ist immer gut, zum anderen hat man darin fast keinen Handyempfang und durch die Wegführung ist man ein bisschen verwirrt und man muss quasi unseren vorgegebenen Weg gehen, weil sonst haben die Leute Sorge, dass sie nicht mehr rausfinden, auch wenn es Blödsinn ist, aber die Leute verirren sich. Sie haben kaum Handyempfang und es ist ruhig. Das heißt, sie sind fokussiert auf das Thema. Also ich denke, im Normalfall denke ich immer, lasst den Kunden ein Produkt nutzen, wie er mag. Aber das ist so der eine Fall, wo ich denke, dass es gut, ihn so ein bisschen dahin zu pushen, dass er sich dem Thema annehmen muss. Und wir hatten erst im letzten Jahr sozusagen als Vorläufer von der ganzen Sache die Dokumentation Führerbunker eröffnet. Und das ist eine 250-Quadratmeter-Dokumentation gewesen, die im Prinzip die gesamte Lebenszeit des Führerbunkers erklärt, also die paar Monate, die es denen gab. Aber weil wir gesagt haben, wenn man das so macht, lockt es auch so diese, also jetzt keine Rechten, aber so Hitler-Eventuries, an die sagen, Göl, ich will mal Hitler gucken, und die halt keine Distanz zu dem Thema oder so haben, was ja nicht unbedingt bösartig sein muss, aber nicht das, was wir vermitteln wollen. Also haben wir gesagt, das gibt es nur eingebunden in eine 90-minutige Tour, wo wir vorher halt den Schrecken des Krieges erklären und dann wie er endet. Und so eingefasst geht das. Und haben aus denen, also im Parallel wurde die große Dokumentation auf zweieinhalbtausend Quadratmetern aufgebaut, aber wir haben halt noch ganz viel einfließen lassen von dem, was wir bei den Touren gelernt haben. Also ich habe selber bis zu zehn Touren am Tag gemacht, um wirklich mitzukriegen. Genau, was machen die Leute da? Was fragen die, worauf wir nicht kommen? Und wirklich selbst, wenn man es bis zum Ende erklärt hat und alles, und wie ist Hitler gestorben und was, dann kam fast jedes Mal am Ende, und gibt es den Führerbunker noch? Sagt man, nee, ich habe dir vor fünf Minuten ein Detail erklärt, wie er gesprengt wurde. Ach, darum ging es. Und dann sagt man, du hast eine Tour gebucht dazu. Ich habe es dir erklärt, du hast es nicht verstanden. Okay, dann muss man es noch anders erklären. Das ist halt der Punkt. Also so, hey, wenn ich es vermitteln will, also das ist der Punkt. Wenn ich Kohle verdienen will, kann es mir scheißegal sein. Wenn ich was vermitteln will, dann muss ich mein Konzept ändern. Und dadurch habe ich aber gemerkt, gut, das wirklich so intensiv am Anfang selber zu machen, weil man gemerkt hat, 95 Prozent verstehen es, 5 nicht. Wir sind bis heute bei der gleichen Quote, egal was wir tun, und haben gesagt, okay, dann ist es einfach so, dass 5 Prozent zu doof sind. Dann kann man auch mitleben, aber dann weiß man, da bringt es nichts. Ist halt so. Und auch jetzt...
95 Prozent ist aber auch eine ganz ordentliche Quote, muss ich sagen.
Und?
Kann man mitarbeiten.
Was bei dem Projekt jetzt so extrem befriedigend ist, wenn man da selber halt an der Kasse steht, wo die Leute beim Reihen und Rauskommen vorbeigehen, das ist wirklich das allererste Mal bei allen Projekten, glaube ich, die ich gemacht habe, dass den ganzen Tag Leute rausgehen und sagen, hey, danke, das war super, da habe ich was gelernt. Also und die Kombination aus, toll, ich habe was gelernt, ist ja schon selten genug. Also oft ist das ja ein Gegensatz. Und da habe ich gesagt, das irgendwie, dann hat man das Gefühl, das war echt das Richtige, wenn man das wirklich nicht mal hört und nicht von Kumpels, die man eingeladen hat, sondern wirklich von wildfremden Menschen, die auch nicht mal wissen, was ich mit dem Projekt zu tun habe, sondern ich stehe halt an der Kasse und die halten mich für eine Kassenkraft oder so und die sagen trotzdem, war wirklich gut. Und dann ist es ordentlich, war aber ein Bergarbeit. Und gerade dieses, also das Aufbauen und also die Dokumentation zeigt halt auch nicht nur den Zweiten Weltkrieg, das ist eigentlich ein ganz kleiner Teil davon. Zwei Drittel sind halt wirklich davor. Also wie kam es zu den Nazis? Warum, also wie ist Hitler überhaupt zum Nazi geworden? Weil 25 Jahre lang war er ein Loser, den keiner mochte, der keine Führungsrolle hatte, der keine Kohle hatte. Und auf einmal wurde eine ganz andere Person draus. Und dann auch, warum sind die so im Idioten nachgelaufen? Also diesen ganzen Kram versuchen wir im Detail zu erklären, weil wir sagen, dass es dann zum Krieg kam. Das ist der Teil, den kennen alle im Großen und Ganzen und einigermaßen wie der Krieg lief auch. Aber dieses, wie es dazu kam, das ist doch der Punkt. Und das Erschreckende ist halt, wie viel einem bei heutigen Populisten in allen Ländern genau gleich vorkommt. Und eben auch der Slogan von Hitler, ich werde Deutschland wieder groß machen. Wo man denkt, das war der Werbeslogan, der kommt einem irgendwie bekannt vor. Aber auch ganz viele andere Mechanismen, wo man sieht, das ist in 70 Jahren bei allen Populisten gleich geblieben, das ganze Vorgehen. Heißt halt nicht, dass es zum gleichen Ende immer führt. Aber man sagt so, ja, also das Volk in die Guten und die Bösen teilen gegen die aktuelle Regierung wettern, gegen Minderheiten wettern und denen die Schuld an allem geben und so. Das ist irgendwie, das ist so der Klassiker. Und das erklären wir halt genau. Ein weiterer Bereich, den wir sehr ausführlich haben, ist dann der Holocaust sozusagen in drei verschiedenen Teilen. Zum einen so diese Massenvernichtung halt, die Industrielle. Da merken wir, das ist, was die Leute am ehesten kennen und wo gerade Deutsche sehr abgestumpft sind. Also nicht, dass sie das nicht für wichtig halten, aber so Bilder aus Vernichtungslagern, das hat so ein durchschnittlich gebildeter Deutscher lange und oft gesehen. Da sagt er, weiß ich, macht sozusagen Haken drunter das Thema weiter, aber es betrifft ihn jetzt nicht in dem Moment emotional. Der bricht da nicht in Tränen aus oder so. Und deswegen haben wir dann Fotos von Nazis, wie sie Menschenjagden veranstalten, die das selber fotografiert haben. Also auch sehr groß, wie sie dann zum Beispiel nackte junge Mädchen aus den Häusern ziehen und die auf der Straße zusammentreten und so weiter. Und wie dann blutüberströmte Menschen rumlaufen und so was. Und das ist auf einmal ganz anders, weil es so eine individuelle Person ist. Und dann auch so diese Erniedrigungen. Also wie die nackte Leute festhalten, ihnen die Haare abschneiden und Kremassen daneben schneiden und sich gegenseitig fotografieren, um es den Kumpels zu zeigen. Also was so die Leute auf eine ganz andere Art trifft. Und wo wir merken, das sind viele Fotos, also die zum einen nie gezeigt wurden bei allen möglichen anderen Ausstellungen. Also soweit wir wissen unveröffentlicht vieles von dem Material. Und zum anderen merkt man, das trifft Leute wieder ganz anders. Also weil es so individuell und halt so dieses zum Spaß erniedrigen ist und so.
Was ja auch durchaus in der aktuellen Jugendkultur so seinen Platz hat. Da gehen solche Fotos auch rum und haben natürlich auch einen ähnlichen Geschmack.
Ja, und das sahen wir. Also es gab so zwei oder so anderthalb Kritikpunkte an der Dokumentation eigentlich nur. Zum einen, dass wir diese Bilder zeigen. Das haben einige Leute kritisiert. Ja, aber es war halt so. Also zum einen, wir zeigen Fakten. Und wir wollen die Leute hier treffen. Wir wollen, dass die sich wegdrehen und sagen, das will ich nicht sehen, weil wir sagen, genau, das willst du nicht. Also sieh zu, dass es nicht wieder passiert. Also das ist doch genau das, was wir haben wollen. Was besonders spannend ist, dass dann immer kommt, aber die Kinder. Sagt ja, welches Kind hatte denn ein Problem damit? Zeig es mir. Wir haben viele Kinder und Jugendliche in der Ausstellung. Zum einen denken wir, kein 12-Jähriger kommt zufällig vor und sagt, ich gucke mir mal die Dokumentation an, weil der kommt da nicht hin, ohne gebildete Eltern, die das einfassen. Also das ist unsere Erfahrung. Und wir weisen natürlich vorher darauf hin. Und die Eltern sagen fast immer, ja, das ist doch klar, wenn es um den Zweiten Weltkrieg geht, dass so Bilder kommen. Also ich sage natürlich, was soll es denn sonst sein? Also ihr zeigt ja nicht Blumenwiesen und Hoppelhasen. Und wir haben dann gerade in den ersten Tagen, also quasi am Ausgang von den Räumen gestanden und auch viel mit Leuten gesprochen. Da war gerade die Reaktion von den Kindern und Jugendlichen spannend. Die haben zum einen gesagt, ja, also war mir so nicht klar oder also das ist das, was hängen bleibt. Oder sie haben gesagt, na dann gucke ich halt nicht hin. Dachte ja, also wie immer, die hatten so die geringsten Probleme damit. Und die Leute, die das Problem sozusagen groß thematisiert haben, die haben meist nicht gesagt, ich habe ein Problem mit, sondern die anderen könnten eins haben. Sagt okay, somit haben wir de facto kein Problem darin gesehen, sondern die Wirkung, die wir haben wollen, dass die Leute wirklich sich mit befassen. Und das ist ja die Idee von solchen Bildern. Und dann gibt es einen Raum in der Dokumentation Führerbunker, also ganz am Ende. Da war unser Problem. Wie zeigt man Leuten, wie es im Führerbunker aussah? Die erste Idee ist, man nimmt die Fotos. Allerdings, solange Hitler gelebt hat, stand es unter Todesstrafe, Fotos im Führerbunker zu machen. Wodurch die Menge an Material sich sehr beschränkt auf das, was danach fotografiert wurde, als es schon halb verwüstet war. Das kann man schon irgendwie machen. Aber so ein durchschnittlicher Turi, der verschwommene Schwarz-Weiß-Bilder sieht, das versteht man schwierig. Also haben wir Grundrisse genommen und haben dann gefragt, ob wir die Set-Bilder von der Untergang haben können. Weil die haben einen Führerbunker nachgebaut. Das gilt als ein akkurater Nachbau. Die haben erst gesagt, die Bilder geben sie nicht raus, weil machen sie halt nicht. Weil die auch Sorge haben, irgendein Nazi hängt sich das ins Wohnzimmer und feiert den Führerbunker. Aber nachdem wir das Projekt dann erklärt hatten, war es kein Problem. Und wir haben als Erster diese Bilder da hängen, was echt gut ist. Klar, das sind Bilder vom Set, aber um so als Durchschnittsmensch eine Idee zu haben, wovon wir reden, gerade so dieses Wasser predigen und Wein trinken, also mit fünf Leuten auf 250 Quadratmetern wohnen und dem Volk erzählen, Leute, wir hängen doch alle zusammen im gleichen Boot, dafür ist das schön plakativ. Und die Filmarchitektin Monika Bauer, die die ganze Inszenierung gemacht hat, die hat aber auch das Filmset für das Boot und für Liebe Mauer und so weiter designt, die hat gesagt, wie immer, ihr müsst was Bildliches machen. Die hat auch im Berlin Story Museum die ganzen Szenen gebaut, wo wir Wohnungsnot und so weiter darstellen. Und die hat dann halt gesagt, dann lass uns einen Raum aus dem Führerbunker nachstellen. Und da haben wir dann den Arbeitsraum von Hitler genommen, also einen Schreibtisch, eine Couch, zwei Sessel. Und das ist ganz interessant, weil einem beim Aufbau erst klar wird, wie eng diese Räume eigentlich sind. Also man kann in dem Raum nicht eine Tür öffnen, ohne dass man die Couch verrücken muss zum Beispiel. Was sagt, das ist jetzt kein Weltwissen, was man haben muss. Aber wenn man sich halt intensiv mit dem Thema beschäftigt, sagt man, warum hat er nicht eine kleinere Couch genommen oder einen größeren Raum? Also wieso ist dann das so eine Fehlplanung, was dann so Detailsachen sind, die interessant ist? Das Spannende ist, für uns war das halt ein Element von vielen auf zweieinhalbtausend Quadratmeter, diese acht Quadratmeter-Ecke. Aber für Journalisten ist das das Spannendste der Welt. Also bis heute erreichen uns so viele Anfragen, ob wir nicht ein Interview in diesem Raum machen können und da filmen können. Und wir machen es grundsätzlich mit Journalisten so. Wir sagen erst mal, müsst ihr die Ausstellung gesehen haben, weil sonst können wir nicht ernsthaft darüber sprechen. Und natürlich machen wir nicht ein lustiges Fotoshooting in Hitlers Zimmer. Zum einen ist es hinter Glas, damit man nicht reinkommt. Und zum anderen habt ihr dann nicht verstanden, worum es hier geht. Also weil deswegen haben wir noch 2.492 andere Quadratmeter. Was da aber ganz interessant war, so dieses Hacken und Beißen innerhalb von der Historik-Szene. Mir ist ja von der Topographie des Terrors vorgeworfen worden. Ich baue ein Disneyland für Nazis. Also wo die Nazis dann hinkörnen und sich schön einabfeiern können oder sowas im Prinzip.
Die Topographie des Terrors, muss man sagen, ist eine Holocaust-Ausstellung.
Genau, die große staatlich finanzierte, die Messlatte, könnte man sagen, in Deutschland für dieses Thema.
Auch unweit von eurem Bunker, das ist ja alles in Berlin Mitte.
Genau, fünf Minuten zu Fuß, also quasi unsere Nachbarn mit einem verwandten Thema. Und das halt im DPA-Interview, sodass das Reichweite hatte. Und dann hat die DPA uns dazu gefragt. Ich habe gesagt, also zum einen würde ich dem Herrn empfehlen, vorbeizukommen, bevor er eine Meinung hat, weil der war nie da. Das war vor der Eröffnung, wo ich dachte, das ist immer, finde ich, schon gut.
Also, das hilft.
Und habe dann auch da angerufen und wollte halt mal fragen, wie sie darauf kommen oder ob das vielleicht schlichtweg falsch zitiert wurde. Also, kann ich mir bei so was gravierendem nicht vorstellen, aber man weiß es ja nicht. Erst mal fragen, fand ganz interessant, dass die nicht mit mir sprechen wollten. Bis heute nicht. Also, es ist jetzt mehr als ein Jahr her, lehnen jedes Telefonat ab, beantworten meine E-Mails nicht, weil ich das halt mehrfach versucht habe zu klären. Und haben dann aber, also, die Ausstellung wird halt von einem Verein betreut, bei dem ich im Vorstand bin und einem anderen Vorstandsmitglied, haben sie da mitgeteilt, das haben sie aber nie gesagt. Und dann habe ich nochmal bei der dpa nachgefragt und habe gesagt, Leute, der Zitatgeber sagt, das stimmt nicht. Also, ich mag der dpa auch ungern unterstellen, dass sie falsche Zitate verbreiten, aber es dürfte irgendwie in der Natur der Sache liegen, dass ich ein hohes Interesse daran habe, diesen Punkt zu klären. Und die dpa hat gesagt, also, ihrem Tonband nach hat er das gesagt.
Und da hat er gesagt, okay, damit ist das Thema für mich dann auch erledigt.
Aber wo ich auch dachte, ich verstehe mal nicht, was sich Leute von sowas erhoffen. Oder was, keine Ahnung, also, man arbeitet in die gleiche Richtung, man zieht am gleichen Strang und es nicht mal gesehen haben, trotz Einladung. Also, das finde ich dann immer in solchen Szenen manchmal, also gut, wenn man Softwareentwicklung macht, ist man Schlimmeres gewohnt.
Na gut, ich meine, es mag, ich weiß es ja nicht, es mag ja auch dadurch getriggert sein, dass sehr wohl ja in diesem Feld sicherlich auch in der Vergangenheit mal einige Player aufgetaucht sein mögen, die denen so etwas zu unterstellen dann angemessener gewesen wäre. Weiß man nicht, aber da ist natürlich schon recht. Man sollte sie zumindest mal als Debattenbeitrag selber erst mal anschauen, bevor man da irgendwie ein Urteil bildet. Jetzt bist du quasi von der IT-Security zum Hitler-Dokumentator geworden. Das ist ja schon mal irgendwie ein ganz interessanter Lauf. Und hast dadurch aus deinem Interesse an Geschichte, letzten Endes ja auch aus Business-Erwägungen kann man sagen, dann auch so eine aktive Rolle übernommen. Langsam müssen wir ja mal auf unser Thema kommen. Deswegen frage ich mich, wo in deiner Entwicklung ist denn ausgerechnet das Land Kurdistan?
Dann noch mal schnell anders.
Wann ist das Thema Kurdistan das erste Mal bei dir irgendwie auf der Liste erschienen?
Ziemlich früh. Ich bin ja 1982 geboren. 1991 ist ein Freund der Familie nach Kurdistan, also in Nordirak, gegangen, um dort Hilfsprojekte zu machen. Seitdem habe ich da irgendwie mal was von gehört, aber so sehr am Rande. Und der hat dann wirklich bis vor zwei Jahren dort auch durchgehend gelebt. Und diese ganze Entwicklung von der Krieg 91 gegen Saddam mit den Aufruhen, 2003 Sturz-Saddam, bis halt vor zwei Jahren die ganze Sache mitbekommen. Und ich habe immer wieder so aus zweiter Hand über meine Eltern oder so mitbekommen, was der da wieder macht, sodass das aber so ein Dauerthema am Rande irgendwie war, wo ich mehr Kontakt so hatte als andere Leute. Und irgendwann habe ich dann gedacht, also ich hatte jetzt auch keine allzu gute Ahnung von der Gegend, aber habe immer gedacht, dass irgendwie ist das schon so anders, was ich mitbekommen, als das, was man hier so als Klischee sich vom Irak vorstellt. Also irgendwie so, dass die dadurch zerbombte Ruinen auf dem Esel reiten oder so was. Und dann berichtet er davon, dass er irgendwie sein Handy nicht auf mobiles Internet konfiguriert kriegt, weil er irgendwie nicht versteht, wie es geht oder so was. Man denkt irgendwie anders. Und dann hatte ich halt überlegt, eigentlich würde ich da gerne mal hin, zumindest wenn es so klingt, als könnte man da hin, als könnte man da zum Urlaub machen, hinfahren. Und es gab noch eine Sache, 2002, als ich mit dem Abi durch war und so weiter, habe ich überlegt dort zu studieren, weil ich mal geguckt habe, was kann man da machen? Da konnte man internationales Recht studieren an der Uni in Erbil. Und dann hatte ich Sigi, also dem Freund, eine Mail geschickt und gesagt, hallo, meinst du, da kann ich jetzt einfach hinkommen und studieren? Oder wie ist die Lage? Und der hat gesagt, naja, nee. Also hat gesagt, im Prinzip, also da studieren ja genug Leute, das geht schon. Aber wird er trotzdem nicht empfehlen, weil die Situation zu unklar ist. Und da war ja schon irgendwie absehbar, dass da Damm gestürzt wird. Oder also, dass zumindest es so wieder einen Versuch geben wird. Hat gesagt, da weiß man nie, was passiert, lass es erst mal. Also lieber ein paar Jahre warten, was Sache ist. Letzten Endes ist es so, das wäre überhaupt kein Problem gewesen rückblickend. Aber es kommt an dem Moment ja überhaupt nicht absehend. Ich hab gedacht, der wohnt da, der hat Ahnung, der wird schon wissen, was er sagt. Aber 2011 irgendwie, also so jahrelang das Thema schleifen lassen, hatte ich irgendwie wieder Zeit und nichts zu tun. Und hab gedacht, eigentlich will ich da mal hin. Hatte ihm dann noch mal geschrieben und gesagt, ey, ich würde gern vorbeikommen. Also geht das? Kann ich einfach mal eine Woche rüberfliegen? Und der meinte, ja super, ich wollte dich gerade anrufen. Wir haben ein deutsch-kurdisches Freundschaftsfest. Und sie suchen Speaker für verschiedene Themen. Und ob ich was erklären könnte zu Föderalismus, also im Sinne von, wenn Kurdistan irgendwann mal unabhängig wird oder so. Also was für Staatsform oder Organisationsform gäbe es und welche wären Möglichkeiten, sowas zu realisieren? Und ob ich Interesse hätte, was zum Thema Föderales System zu erklären, gerade weil sie da verschiedene Gruppen haben, die sich nicht so mögen, die aber eigentlich doch zusammenarbeiten wollen. Und wo ein Föderalismus mit einer starken Verwaltung auf der unteren Ebene, also so mit einer quasi schwachen Regierung drüber und einer starken regionalen Verwaltung, ja durchaus eine Möglichkeit sein könnte. Du sagst, ja klar, klingt interessant.
Da weiß ich auch immer wenig klar, dass unser Bundesländernmodell nicht unbedingt jetzt so das vorherrschende Konzept ist in anderen Staaten, die ja letztlich so schlecht damit nicht gefahren sind. Insbesondere, wenn man sich mal so 150 Jahre zurückblättert und man schaut, wie Europa da aufgeteilt war. Da hat es halt rundherum so die Länder im Wesentlichen, die du heute auch so hast, so Italien, Frankreich, England. Und Deutschland war halt ein Flickenteppich aus Hunderten von Grafschaften, Herzogtümern und sonstigen kleinen Burgen mit Feldern rum.
Ja, und auch Frankreich bis heute mit der Zentralverwaltung, also so als direkter Nachbar und gegenläufiges System. Und was ich da so spannend fand, also ich musste mich selber noch mal intensiver mit dem Thema hier und da beschäftigen. Was ich da noch immer ganz interessant finde, hab dann so im Prinzip die simple Frage gefunden, womit man guckt, ob jemand das federale System verstanden hat oder nicht. Da frag ich die Leute dann jetzt immer, ob sie mir denn sagen können, wie der Bundesratspräsident gewählt wurde. Und wenn man das kann, dann hat man das federale System verstanden. Das ist sehr lustig. Aber dementsprechend heißt das auch klar.
Die Antwort ist doch, das geht reih um, oder?
Aber wonach reih um? Der Ministerpräsident von dem Bundesland, was gerade dran ist, ist der Bundesratspräsident.
Also das geht durch die Länderreihe um.
Genau. Und das ist dann aber so, dass natürlich Wahlen in dem Land stattfinden können, während die Amtszeit für dieses Bundesland ist. Das heißt, dann wechselt der Bundesratspräsident, weil da eine Landtagswahl war oder weil der Ministerpräsident wechseln musste, warum auch immer. Und umgekehrt, während man Ministerpräsident ist, muss man die Bundesratspräsidentschaft abgeben, wenn der Turnus sich ändert. Also dadurch ist es, also es ist ja nicht synchronisiert. Und das war halt eine der Ideen von den Alliierten für die Nichtplanbarkeit von Macht. Also dass du im Prinzip den Bundesratspräsidenten absägen kannst, indem du eine Landtagswahl, also da eine Regierung aufplatzen lässt oder so, wenn Gefahr droht, dass der Mist baut. Also so auch, also dieses, also vieles von diesem Verworrenen bei unserem System basiert ja immer noch darauf, wie kann man Macht zerstreuen, dass sie nicht planbar ist. Was ich auch gar keinen blöden Ansatz finde für eine Demokratie. Also dass man eben theoretisch keine verkrusteten Strukturen haben sollte, was natürlich praktisch nochmal anders ist, aber so der Gedanke dahinter ist ja schon mal lobenswert. Ja, und dementsprechend habe ich dann gedacht, super, fliege ich da mal hin, guck es mir an. Und habe dann im Prinzip einen Tag wirklich gehabt, wo ich meinen Vortrag halten muss. Und sechs Tage, wo so halb organisiertes Programm war, wie so Touri-Programm, die Gegend angucken, Leute treffen und so weiter.
Das war dann in Erbil?
Genau, das war in Erbil und drumrum.
Erbil ist ja quasi so die Hauptstadt in Anführungsstrichen.
Genau.
Also das ist so der wichtigste zentrale Ort.
Also nicht nur in Anführungsstrichen, sondern auch laut Verfassung ist es von der autonomen Region Kurdistan die Hauptstadt. Also eben nicht von einer Zentralregierung, sondern von einer Regionalregierung.
Das war jetzt welches Jahr? 2011. 2011. Also alles noch gar nicht so lange her.
Nö, eigentlich nicht. Nur ein paar Jahre. Hat sich viel ergeben in der Zeit.
Mittlerweile bezeichnest du dich ja selber auch als Journalist.
Ja.
Das hast du damals noch nicht getan.
Nee, war ich damals jein. Nicht in Bezug darauf. Also ich habe damals auch schon Artikel über Technikthemen und so weiter geschrieben. Also ein bisschen ähnlich, wie es jetzt mit Berlin Geschichte ist. Damals versucht, technische Themen, so wie wenn man es Mutti erklärt, haben die damals immer gesagt, oder seinen Eltern, also runterzubrechen. Allerdings war es schon damals wie heute so, dass mir quasi sozusagen vorgeworfen wurde, dass das kein Journalismus ist, weil ich es nicht mit einer Gewinnerzielungsabsicht mache, was sich im krassen Gegensatz zu meinem Verständnis von Journalismus bewegt. Also ich denke immer, Journalismus sollte man doch die Idee haben, was vermitteln, erklären zu wollen, wie auch immer, oder berichten zu wollen. Und es ist gut, wenn man Geld mit verdient. Also Journalismus definiert sich ja nicht in erster Linie damit, dass man Geld verdient und dann, dass man was vermittelt, auch wenn das vielleicht Leute heute anders sehen. Dementsprechend habe ich damals schon viel geschrieben. Der wichtige Unterschied war, wenn man einfach Technikthemen runterbricht und Leuten erklärt und drüber schreibt und auch mal für irgendwelche damals aufkommenden größeren Blogs, dann braucht man halt keinen Presserausweis. Weil wozu? Ich kann auch so auf der CeBIT rumtouren oder zum Kongress gehen oder sowas. Und selbst Pressekonferenzen und so. Also was Leute mal erwarten, was einen Presserausweis ausmacht, ist ja auch ganz komisch, weil ich habe auch, wenn ich Pressekonferenzen gebe, noch nie einen Presseausweis sehen wollen. Sondern wenn jemand 30 Artikel für die Süddeutsche geschrieben hat, dann ist mir egal, ob er einen Presseausweis hat oder nicht. So das heißt, dieses Thema ist das jetzt sozusagen Journalismus oder nicht, war für mich nicht so entscheidend. Und durch das Thema Kurdistan wurde es dann sozusagen in der Definitionsfrage wichtiger, weil ich für die Akkreditierung für verschiedene Gebiete dort, also dass ich sagen konnte, ich möchte als Journalist an die Front und brauche Schutz, dafür wollten die einen Nachweis haben, dass ich journalistisch tätig bin. Also musste ich mich um Presseausweis kümmern. Das war sozusagen der Punkt, wo ich mich dann mal hinsetzen muss und sagen musste, erfülle ich die Kriterien oder nicht? Und wenn ja, was hat das für Einfluss auf mein Handeln, also auf meine Berichterstattung, was ist jetzt mit dem Pressecodex, was gibt es an rechtlichen Bedingungen und so weiter. Und das war auch ganz interessant, weil man ja im Prinzip sagen kann, da wird immer viel drum geredet, aber unterm Strich ist das ein sehr, sehr schwammiges Gebiet. Zum Beispiel schon die Sache mit, ja, ein Journalist muss neutral sein, natürlich, aber was heißt jetzt neutral? Also wenn jetzt ein Journalist schreibt, die AfD ist gefährlich, dann ist er nicht mehr neutral. Also könnte man zum Beispiel sagen, oder ist das doch? Also was ist jetzt neutral? Und dann habe ich gesehen, da kann ich viele Bücher darüber lesen. Das bringt mir nichts, weil die Zeit habe ich gar nicht. Und dann hatte ich mir halt mal angeguckt, was ist jetzt die Definition für ein Kriegsgebiet oder ein Krisengebiet? Also wo bin ich eigentlich? Bin ich in einem Kriegsgebiet an der IS-Front? Bin ich nämlich nicht, weil es nicht zwei reguläre Armeen gegeneinander sind, sondern es ist ein Krisen- oder Bürgerkriegsgebiet, blablabla. Also da fängt es dann schon an mit Schwammigkeiten. Dann eben der Punkt klar, man darf keine Waffen führen als Journalist. Also sagt man in Deutschland klar, in anderen Ländern ist das nicht klar geregelt. Also im Irak dürfte ich zum Beispiel auch Waffen führen als Journalist, um mich selber zu verteidigen. In Deutschland nicht. Also da merkt man schon, da kommt es jetzt drauf an, wo liegt die Messlatte? Also war für mich auch nie eine Frage, aber ich fand es interessant, wie das so auseinanderdriftet. Und dann eben auch, dass die Definition, oder die, auf die man sich so einigthalt ist, natürlich bezeichnet neutral, dass man vor Ort keine Partei ergreifen darf. Also ich kann jetzt schlecht mit einer Waffe auf Seiten der einen Seite schießen und mich umdrehen und in die Kamera moderieren, dass ich jetzt Berichterstattung mache. Das heißt ja beim Umkehrschluss nicht, dass ich nicht eine Meinung, die aber klar als Meinung erkennbar ist, in meinen Artikeln haben kann. Und da ist es halt so, häufig schreiben Leute ja, sagen wir, einen sehr neutralen Artikel und haben unten da noch einen Absatz und sagen so und ich finde jetzt, dass keine Ahnung, dass die, die die Menschen erschossen haben, auf der falschen Seite stehen, weil die haben dann Kriegsverbrechen begangen oder so. Während es bei mir halt nicht so klar getrennt ist, aber dafür erkläre ich halt auch immer ziemlich klar, wo war ich wie unterwegs und was halte ich davon. Also dass es eben nicht eine unterschwellige Deutung oder so ist, sondern dass ganz klar ist, das meine ich dazu. Wodurch das auch wieder okay ist, weil es halt nicht... Also ich versuche bei bestimmten Punkten, keine Neutralität zu vermitteln. Zum Beispiel würde ich nicht sagen, ich stehe dem IS neutral gegenüber und wir gucken mal, was da jetzt passiert, sondern da denke ich, da ist klar, das sind die Bösen. Das sehen zwar fast alle Leute so, aber bei diesem Neutralitätsgrundsatz müsste man ja eigentlich sagen, da muss man dem Ergebnis offen gegenüberstehen und erstmal gucken, wo das hingeht.
Genau, also das ist erstmal eine extremistische Gruppe mit...
Aber sind sie extremistisch? Kannst du das schon... Also ich meine, genau, wenn man da so den Flame-War startet, könnte man sagen, wieso sind die denn extremistisch? Und der Papst nicht. Also könnte man... Deswegen habe ich gesagt, ne, da... Also erstmal, es gibt nicht die Definition. Und deswegen habe ich gesagt, da muss ich auch nicht neutral sein in dem Konflikt, sondern ich muss mich vor Ort neutral verhalten, solange ich Presse-Schilder trage. Auf der anderen Seite ist es so, die Presse-Kennzeichnung und so weiter im Frontgebiet dient ja eigentlich dazu, dass keiner der Kriegsbeteiligten auf mich absichtlich schießt. Also ich muss mich aus der Schusslinie halten, aber niemand darf mich gezielt abschießen. Was im Bezug auf IS auf der anderen Seite auch lächerlich ist, weil die sich ja nicht an die Konvention halten, sondern die betrachten einen eher als Zielscheibe. Es waren auch so Erkenntnisse, die recht schnell kam. Bei einem der Trips, also als ich das erste Mal dann in einem gepanzerten Konvoi gefahren wurde, war es ganz hübsch, weil man hat halt ordentlich gepanzerte Fahrzeuge, die auch ordentlich gepflegt und geputzt sind und so. Und die erste Erkenntnis ist, das geputzte Fahrzeug wird zuerst beschossen, weil klar ist, da sitzt jemand Wichtiges drin. Wäre schlauer gewesen, im Dreckigen irgendwo zu sitzen. Und halt auch, die haben gesagt, du kommst hier mit einer blauen Weste und einem blauen Helm und einem Presseschild an, da kannst du gleich eine gelbe Zielscheibe auf den Kopf malen. Sondern zieh dir irgendwas Neutrales an, in einem beliebigen Tarnmuster. Dann genießt du halt, also es ist nicht verboten, du genießt nur nicht den Schutz der Genfer Konvention, den du aber de facto eh nicht hast, wenn du dem ihr es gegenüberstehst. Also das sind so Dinge, also nur deswegen so diese Frage, ab wann man das als Journalismus bezeichnet oder nicht, das fand ich auch gar nicht einfach. Ich dachte, das war auch wieder so ein eigenes langes Thema, mit was ist jetzt eigentlich Journalismus und was ist ein Journalist und was ist eine Redaktion, also wie, erstmal in Deutschland, wie man das klärt oder nicht klärt, also was sind Redaktionsräume? Sind wir hier jetzt bei dir gerade in Redaktionsräumen, die dem besonderen Schutz unterliegen oder nicht? Könnte man auch schon lange drüber diskutieren wahrscheinlich. Aber das ist eben so, oder wenn du dein Equipment mitnimmst auf den Kongress in den Nebenraum, werden es dadurch Redaktionsräume oder nicht? Und das fand ich auch total spannend und habe gesagt, okay, aber wenn ich da an der Front bin und von dort berichte und mich neutral verhalte und als Presse akkreditiert bin und alles, dann ist das Journalismus und fertig.
Das ist ja gerade diese Region, die irgendwie auch in letzten Jahren gerade diesen Journalismusbegriff auch noch in eine andere Richtung gedehnt hat. Ich erinnere mich da so an dieses Konzept der Embedded Journalists im Irakkrieg, wo die Amerikaner dann quasi die Journalisten dann so direkt mit in den Tank reingenommen haben. Da ist natürlich dann auch gleich so dieses, ich weiß nicht, Stockholm-Syndrom, das ist jetzt glaube ich nicht die richtige Bezeichnung dafür, aber es geht so in die Richtung. Man befreundet sich dann sozusagen und steht die Kämpfe gemeinsam durch und hat in dem Sinne auch überhaupt keine andere Informationsquelle. Das ist zu Recht kritisiert worden damals. Aber jetzt bist du quasi das erste Mal in Kurdistan aufgeschlagen, hast da deine Vortrag gehalten, fand dir das interessant? Und was hast du dann, also warst ja dann eine Woche da, sagst du, was hast du entdeckt? Also ich meine, was hast du vorgefunden? Was war vor allem anders, als du vielleicht gedacht hattest?
Also eigentlich war so direkt der erste Abend, also nach der Landung, so das Interessante, erstmal in einem Flughafen landen, der drei Jahre oder vier Jahre damals alt war, also wirklich im Top-Zustand. Wenn man hier in Berlin von so einer Art vergrößerten Busstation losgeflogen ist, denkt man, so sieht ein moderner Flughafen aus.
Das ist ja immer spannend.
Mit funktionierender Entlüftung und sauberem Rollfeld und alles, was man so aus dem Fernsehen kennt, irgendwie von hübschen Flughäfen. Also das fand ich schon mal spannend. Und dann, also ausgerechnet die Passkontrolle, an der ich war, war so eine blondierte, stark geschminkte Frau. Auch dachte, hey, die hat keine Burka an. Sagt, stimmt, das war das Nachbarland, nicht hier. Oder so zwei Länder weiter. Aber das wirft man ja doch so halbwegs in einen Topf, in seinem Klischeebild irgendwie. Das ist halt da drüben alles.
Man muss, glaube ich, an dieser Stelle auch mal festhalten, Kurdistan hat zwar viel Bezug zum arabischen Raum, aber es ist nicht unbedingt Teil dieses Raums. Wir reden ja hier wirklich von einer Region, eingeklemmt zwischen dem Irak, der Türkei, Iran. Das Siedlungsgebiet breitet sich auf all diesen Ländern auch aus. Es wäre dazwischen, wenn die Grenzen entsprechend verlaufen würden. Das ist auch eine der ältesten Siedlungsgebiete überhaupt. Erbil hat sogar die älteste durchgehende Besiedlung dort mit dieser zentralen Burg. Das ist jetzt nicht irgendwas, sondern das ist so ein bisschen, man sagt ja eh von dieser ganzen Region, so ein bisschen so die Ursuppe der Zivilisation. Das schließt natürlich Kurdistan an der Stelle eben mit ein. Und in dieser ganzen Wahrnehmung von Wahnsinn, der da abgeht, ich meine, das ist ja einfach umringt von Wahnsinn, diese Gegend. Nicht nur der Iran, sondern dann halt auch so nach Norden raus. Gut, das hat auch nicht so sehr viel mit zu tun, so Aserbaidschan, Armenien und so weiter. Alles nicht unbedingt gerade so die Gegenden, wo es easy abgeht. Und ja, und Kurdistan ist permanent eingeschlossen zwischen diesen ganzen Konfliktherden.
Und halt in den verschiedenen Kriegen halt auch, dass die Raketen bei ihnen rüberfliegen oder die Jets oder so. Also, dass man nicht nur so auf einer Landkarte dazwischen ist, sondern dass die Leute das halt auch immer wieder mitbekommen haben. Also, bis hin jetzt zu den letzten Jahren, wo zum Beispiel die russische Armee zum Waffensystem vorführen im Schwarzen Meer und Kasbischen Meer zum Teil Raketen abgeschossen hat von U-Booten, die dann über Kurdistan nach Syrien geflogen sind, um zu zeigen, wie das so geht. Also, wo einem auch immer wieder klar ist, oh, der Luftraum ist gesperrt, ich kann jetzt nicht abfliegen, weil wieder einer eine Waffenshow machen muss. Und hatte ich auch schon mal, dass wir einen Tag später fliegen mussten, weil die verschiedenen Luftwaffen, also in dem Fall auch Russen und USA, ihre Kampfjets verlegt haben darüber und dann einfach den Luftraum beanspruchen. Ja, aber das ist halt ganz spannend, also eben weil man das so im Pulk dieser Nachbarländer irgendwie so grob wahrnimmt, weil man ja auch nicht viel von der Region mitkriegt so im Alltag. Und dazu kommt halt erschwerend, dass die noch eine eigene Sprache, also ein Wort und Schrift haben mit Sorani. Das heißt, selbst wenn man vielleicht Arabisch spricht oder so, kann man davon immer noch nichts lesen. Oder Türkisch oder Kumanschi, was die Kurden in der Türkei sprechen, das hilft einem alles nicht weiter. Das heißt, das ist schon nachrichtentechnisch halbwegs isoliert. Also es gibt auch englischsprachige Nachrichtenquellen da, aber sagen wir im Alltag stolpert man halt nicht drüber. Das ist so der Punkt. Und wir sind dann vom Flughafen, als ich da ankam, rübergefahren in der American Sports Bar mit einer Kartbahn dran, was jetzt auch nicht so das war, was ich als Klischee von Erbil gedacht hatte. Und das war in der Nähe vom Sheraton Resort und am Fuße eines 5-Sterne-Hotels von einer türkischen Kette. Also so wirklich das luxuriöseste Hotel, was ich auf der Welt gesehen habe. Also ich war in mehr als 40 Ländern in vielen Hotels, aber der Standard da sprengt wirklich den Rahmen. Also selbst in Dubai sowas nicht gesehen. Und da war irgendwie so wirklich von Anfang an klar, hier ist ganz anders als was man sich so irgendwie vorstellt. Aber es ist so wahnsinnig polarisiert. Also man hat auf dem Basar zum Teil so Wellblech-Hütten mit so einfachsten Ständen drin, wo die Leute halt irgendwie Tücher und Taschen verkaufen. Da hat man 5 Meter weiter eine neue Shopping-Mall klimatisiert mit kostenlosen Wi-Fi, wo so eine Bimmelbahn rumfährt, um die Kinder zu bespaßen und so. Also die Kontraste sind einfach riesig. Und das, finde ich, macht es aber halt so aus, also auch auf dem Land, dass man im Prinzip diese Klischees hat, so Häuser, die 2 Stunden am Tag fließend Wasser und Strom haben und dann halt ihren Wasserboiler vollmachen, die kein Festnetz haben, sondern direkt auf mobiles Internet gehen. Also es ist halt auch lustig, man kommt zu so einer wirklich irgendwo, mitten im Nichts in der Pampa an so eine Bude und ich hatte keine irakische Dynamik mehr und hatte in meiner Verzweiflung gefragt, ob die Euros nehmen. Ich sagte, ja klar, ich gucke eben bei Google den Wechselkurs nach. Dann sitzt halt so ein 70-jähriger Typ, der aussieht, als wäre er gerade vom Berg geklettert und hat ein aktuelles iPhone und guckt da gerade YouTube. Also man so denkt, das ist halt das, was ich so spannend fand, wie das so völlig clasht, diese beiden Welten.
Sowas hat man in Deutschland nicht so leicht.
Ich hatte vor zwei Jahren mal mit einem General gesprochen, der ist auch knapp 70 und hat bei Facebook irgendwie mit seinen Fans geschrieben. Da ich halt auch gesagt habe, in Deutschland, ich glaube nicht, dass irgendwie hier so ein 70-jähriger General auf Facebook mit seinen Fans gerade mal chattet oder so. Und der sagte ja, hey sorry, ich benutze das auch nicht lang. Wir haben ja erst 1996 die Internetverbindungen über Satellit gehabt, davor habe ich das auch nicht benutzt.
Oh Gott, eine Andachtminute für den Standort Deutschland. Ja, okay, also du bist angekommen, Flughafen, alles. Also überhaupt erst mal so diese Wahrnehmung von rückständiges Land erfüllt sich nicht wirklich, sondern da gibt es große Metropolen, da ist Technik, da ist irgendwie wirtschaftliche Aktivität nicht zu knapp. Es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt gerade jetzt eine Buhn-Region insgesamt, weil in der Lage ist es natürlich etwas schwierig. Aber das Land hat auch Aktivität als Kurdistan.
Ja, jede Menge.
Es ist nicht unbedingt jetzt nur so Teil des Iraksystems, oder ist es überhaupt Teil des Iraksystems?
Überhaupt nicht. Also die haben eine eigene Verfassung, die haben eigene Organe wie ein Parlament, Regierungen, eigene Minister. Das ganz Entscheidende ist, sie haben ihre eigene Polizei und eigenes Militär. Die irakische Polizei und irakisches Militär darf laut Verfassung nicht nach Kurdistan rein, während die kurdische Armee, die Peshmerga, im ganzen Irak operieren darf. Was auch derzeit interessant ist, weil 1600 Peshmerga in Bagdad die Green Zone sichern, weil die irakische Armee selbst das seit vier Jahren nicht mehr auf die Reihe kriegt. Da dachte ich, wenn man in seiner Hauptstadt sozusagen die wenig beliebten Teile des Landes anrufen muss, ob die einem die Green Zone sichern, dann hat man echt ein Problem. Und die sehen sich auch überhaupt nicht als Irak oder Teil davon. Da hängen Kurdistan-Flaggen, so ein berühmter Flaggenstreit, ob Kurdistan- oder Irak-Flaggen dort hängen. Ende vom Lied ist, dass seit Jahren an allen öffentlichen Gebäuden, an den Grenzen, also die haben wirklich sowas wie Grenzübergänge in den Irak. Das heißt formal anders, ist aber das gleiche. Auf der einen Seite kurdische Armee, auf der anderen Seite irakische Armee mit den Flaggen auf den jeweiligen Seiten. Es gibt verschiedene Visa für beide Bereiche. Und an fast allen öffentlichen Gebäuden hängen kurdische Flaggen und nur an ganz wenigen hängen irakische und kurdische zusammen. Aber nur irakische gibt es nicht mal.
Das heißt, in dem Moment reden wir eigentlich von der autonomen Region Kurdistan. Das ist jetzt die konkrete Bezeichnung dieses Kernbereichs Kurdistans. Im Irak wären es vergleichbare Konstruktionen in den Siedlungsflächen in der Türkei und im Syrien und im Irak, im Iran so nicht gibt.
Nein, also nicht mal im Ansatz. Eher im Gegenteil, dass sie da halt aktiv unterdrückt werden, eigentlich in allen anderen Ländern, muss man sagen. In der Türkei haben sie noch zumindest den Vorteil, dass die Welt die Situation wahrnimmt. Es sind ja auch mehrere Zehn Millionen Kurden in der Türkei. Also das heißt ja mal so eine Minderheit. Aber bei einer Minderheit denke ich immer an so einen halben Prozent oder so und nicht an irgendwie 25 Prozent der Bevölkerung. Also es ist so, wie wenn wir hier von der Minderheit der SPD-Wähler reden würden im Land. Also nur mal den Größenvergleich zu haben, da würde man auch sagen, Leute, es ist eine Volkspartei und keine Minderheit. Also es ist halt schon merkwürdig. Also wie man auch merkt, wie durch die Sprache das immer so marginalisiert werden soll, sind die drei Terroristen da am Rand oder so. Und nicht ein großer Teil der Bevölkerung, die Forderungen haben, wie wir möchten gerne unsere Sprache sprechen dürfen, ohne im Gefängnis zu landen. Also die Forderungen der Kurden da in der Türkei sind jetzt auch keine abgefahrenen und wilden, sondern sie wollen Gleichberechtigung und Dekriminalisierung von der Benutzung des Buchstaben X zum Beispiel. Also es ist auch verrückt, wenn man ein X öffentlich geschrieben hat, kommt man ins Gefängnis geworfen werden, weil man das nur für die kurdische Sprache brauchte, nicht für die türkische. Also das ist so die Messlatte, um die es geht. Also wo man auch versteht, dass man da irgendwie sauer ist. Und im Iran nimmt man es, glaube ich, am wenigsten hier wahr, weil einfach im Iran die Nachrichten gut kontrolliert sind. In Syrien, glaube ich, eigentlich in erster Linie jetzt durch den Krieg und eigentlich durch den Kampf um Kobani vor zwei Jahren. Ich glaube, das war das erste Mal, dass so der Mainstream-Europäer wahrgenommen hat, dass es Kurden in Syrien gibt.
Das war so diese Events-Stadt direkt an der Türkei.
Genau, an der Türkei. Und wirklich, das ist ein Dorf, das hat keine Relevanz, militärisch oder politisch oder sowas. Aber es war in sicherer Kammerreichweite aus einem sicheren Gebiet. Also man konnte hinter dem Panzer in der Türkei stehen und dann ganz bequem rüber filmen. Und ich glaube, das war so der Grund, warum das so beliebt war. Aber trotzdem, das hat den Leuten vor Ort immens geholfen, weil es halt endlich mal was war, was die Leute gut sehen konnten.
Ja, was mehrere Sachen klargemacht hat. Also erst mal so dieses schwierige Verhältnis der Türkei, die ja dann teilweise sich lange geziert haben, überhaupt Hilfen sozusagen, also überhaupt eigene Peschmerga-Kämpfer reinzulassen über die Türkei, was für die ja schon so ein No-Go war. Dann eben auch so diese Rigidität, diese Auseinandersetzung mit dem Islamischen Staat. Ich weiß nicht, wer jetzt die Bilder so gesehen hat. Ich habe einiges verfolgt zu dem Zeitpunkt. Es ist, glaube ich, so ein paar Hügel eingefasst. Und dann ging es dann irgendwie schwer zur Sache. Und es war wirklich so ein Stellungskrieg, der letztlich dann von den Kurden sogar auch noch gewonnen wurde.
Genau. Also da war dann, das ist auch so ein, eigentlich das bringt so dieses verrückte Verhältnis von der Türkei zu den Kurden auf den Punkt. Also ich muss noch sagen, die Kurden, das ist ungefähr so einheitlich wie die Deutschen in der Zeit vom Kalten Krieg, kann man sagen. Also ungefähr so, so gehen die Grabenkriege dadurch, die kurdische Community. Während in der Türkei die Kurden im eigenen Land ja so als der Feind für viele Teile der Regierung und Militär gesehen wird, werden die Kurden im Nordirak, also in der autonomen Region Kurdistan von der türkischen Armee ausgebildet, mit Waffen versorgt, mit Munition versorgt seit Jahren. Es gibt auch vier Stützpunkte der türkischen Armee im Kurdistan-Irak. Und als der Kampf um Kobani also immer schlechter wurde für die kurdischen Truppen da, also für die JPG, haben dann nach einigen Verhandlungen die Türkei zugestimmt, das 300 Peshmerga aus dem Nordirak, also in die Türkei fahren, rüber, dann wieder nach Kobani rein und dort mitkämpfen und nachher auf dem gleichen Weg wieder zurück. Das war sozusagen eine historische Sache, die dem zugestimmt wurde unter Erdogan. Was es aber noch schwieriger macht, diese ganze Sache irgendwie zu erklären, was jetzt die Rolle der Türkei ist. Es wird immer verworrener, je länger man sich mit dem Thema beschäftigt. Am Ende war das dann aber ein entscheidender Punkt, weil Kobani befreit wurde und das auch sozusagen für die mediale Reichweite, aber auch für das Selbstwertgefühl der Leute wichtig war, und zum anderen zum Demoralisieren der IS-Leute. Also das bisschen, was ich wirklich von IS-Kämpfern direkt mitgekriegt habe, war, dass die Leute dumm wie Brot waren, also richtig so dumme Hanseln. Die unglaublich beeinflussbar waren. Und wenn es dann halt heißt, die haben Kobani befreit, dann ist das für die Leute drumrum schon irgendwie ein harter Schlag. Und dann kommen die ins Denken und ins Grübeln, können wir hier noch gewinnen oder nicht. Also weswegen das halt auch für den weiteren Kriegsverlauf schon nicht unwichtig war.
Ja, also jetzt zum Rückblick ist es so einer der Turning Points mit auch gewesen. An dem Zeitpunkt war das noch überhaupt nicht klar, ob der IS nicht sogar noch sich deutlich weiter ausdehnen würde.
Ja, also das war, also es gab da und parallel dann auch an anderen Stellen ein paar, also große Luftschläge, die damit synchronisiert wurden und so weiter. Und so, sagen wir so Luftangriffe von in dem Fall auch der jordanischen Luftwaffe zum Teil, die jetzt sagen wir mal nicht den entscheidenden militärischen Schlag da brachten, aber wo innerhalb der IS Leute es hieß, überall hat es geknallt. Rechts, links, vorne, hinten, in der Stadt, in der Stadt, die greifen jetzt überall an. Also wo man im Prinzip so Terrormechanismen sich zugute gemacht hat, einfach die ganzen Leute von mir erst verunsichern und überall mal was hochgehen lassen. Also dass man da das Gefühl hat, jetzt dreht sich's. Sodass man über einen kritischen Punkt kommt von Leuten, die nicht mehr sicher sind, ob sie kämpfen wollen. Und das hat in dem Fall scheinbar alles zusammen halt ganz gut funktioniert. Plus eben, muss man ja sagen, wenn viel in den Medien ist, dann gibt es auch immer mehr Hilfe. Und in dem Moment, wo es aus den Medien raus ist, fällt es wieder ab. Das heißt, das war die Zeit, wo auch die Regionalregierung im Nordirak zum Beispiel viel fordern konnte und viel Hilfe anfordern konnte. Wenn man dann vor der Kamera steht, zum Beispiel mit Frau von der Leyen und sagt, und kriegen wir jetzt die Hilfe? Dann kann sie schlecht sagen, ne, heute nicht mehr. Also solche Dinge, wo man natürlich das dann auch geschickt nutzen muss.
Also, um nochmal ein bisschen auf deine Rolle zurückzukommen, du hast also jetzt quasi Kurdistan für dich so ein bisschen entdeckt. Und begonnen, sagen wir mal, die Situation auch mehr zu verstehen. Ist ja klar, ich meine, wenn man da irgendwie so, kann man das sehr gut vorstellen, wo auch immer man so in seinem Leben mal eine Woche zumindest war und es einfach, wo alle Eindrücke sozusagen zu 100 Prozent zu diesem Bild beitragen, also nicht unbedingt zu dem Bild, was man vorher im Kopf hatte, aber man nimmt ja erstmal sehr viel anderes nicht wahr, man ist einfach entkoppelt von seinen eigenen Ablenkungen etc. Dann kommt man ja auch schnell ins Grübeln und kann auch sehr viel besser die Berichterstattung dann später, wenn man wieder zu Hause ist, irgendwie immer sehr gut in Kontext setzen. Also mir geht es so mit Ländern wie Mexiko oder so, wo ich einfach mal war und dann man hat so ein bisschen den historischen Kontext im Zusammenhang. Man weiß, dass irgendwie Personen oder Gruppen, über die vielleicht viel berichtet und geredet wird, eigentlich keine Rolle spielen in solche Aspekte. Mich würde nochmal so ein Bild interessieren. Also wie würdest du sozusagen dieses, ja, ich weiß nicht genau, welches Klammerwort ich jetzt nehmen soll.
Region.
Diese Region Kurdistan. Also vor allem auch so die kulturelle Region. Wie würdest du die beschreiben? Also was ist das für eine?
Also zum einen Tradition ist da sehr wichtig. Also wirklich die letzten hunderte Jahre. Und der Islam für oder nicht nur der Islam, aber Islam natürlich als dominierende Religion bei 80 85 Prozent der Leute merkt man im Alltag einfach. Also man hört die die Muezzin-Gebete da über den Lautsprecher und nicht so sehr die Kirchenglocken, aber auch da gibt es alles. Aber was ich da halt spannend fand, wenn dann das Gebet erklingt, geht der Alltag weiter. Es ist so wie wenn hier die Kirchenglocken klingeln. Da rennt ja auch nicht jeder hier in Berlin los zur Kirche, sondern die bimmeln halt. Das fand ich ganz spannend, weil man ja so aus anderen Ländern das Gefühl hat, dann schmeißen sich alle hin und beten schnell. Und da ist so, ja, kann ja nachher noch beten.
Ja, in Saudi-Arabien, da steht die Zeit dann einfach still. Ich hatte ja hier vor ein paar Ausgaben auch mal Saudi-Arabien im Fokus, was sich gelingen hat, das reinzulernen. Da war das ja dann auch so ein Ding, wo man sich auch denkt, so...
Und da war halt so, die haben halt auch jede Menge Christen da und die haben so Religionen, die sich eigentlich nur da konservieren konnten. Die Jesiden, Karkai, Zarathustra und so weiter. Also so Religionen, die 6.000, 7.000 Jahre alt sind oder wie die Zarathustra, die sagen halt, sie sind älter als die Zeit. Also, weil es gibt keinen Kalender, als sie anfingen zu beten, so. Und das ist da total normal. Also, was ich da interessant finde zum einen, Religion spielt für viele Leute eine wichtige Rolle, aber nicht exklusiv ihre, sondern halt Religion ist wichtig. Aber ob du jetzt die eine oder die andere hast, oder keine, ist auch okay. Und man diskutiert und redet auch nicht groß drüber. Aber man hat total Verständnis dafür, dass der eine hier hingeht, der andere dahin. Dass er sagt, die Woche kann ich nicht mit Feiern kommen, weil ich muss hier fasten oder so. Das ist so locker nebenher. Also, so wie man sich immer wünschen würde, wie Religion funktioniert, so wem es wichtig ist, dem ist es halt wichtig und der Rest respektiert es. Aber man kümmert sich halt nicht drum oder sagt, äh, warum machst du denn den Scheiß oder so. Und dann sieht man so halt in der gesamten Gesellschaft, also eine offene Gesellschaft, also es hängt sehr von der Familie ab. Merkt man so, wie sich die Leute kleiden. Es gibt sehr westlich Gekleidete, es gibt Leute, die haben lange Sachen an, es gibt welche, die tragen Kopftuch oder nicht. Es gibt aber auch Frauen in Minirock und mit Tanktop. Also man hat das ganze Spektrum. Aber es geht halt so nebeneinander her. Und im Vergleich zum Beispiel zu Nordirland, wo man dann ja möglichst durch das Gebiet des anderen marschiert, um ihm nochmal richtig auf den Sack zu gehen, ist es bei denen so, dass zum Beispiel Kirchen nicht direkt am Rand vom christlichen Viertel gebaut werden, sondern wir sagen, wenn die Kirche in der Mitte steht, dann hörst du es auch überall. Du musst ja nicht gegenüber von der Moschee vom Nachbarn deine Kirchenglocke hinhängen oder umgekehrt. Also ich denke so, was für ein vernünftiger Umgang doch miteinander. Und gerade in den Gebieten, wo jetzt so die verschiedenen Gotteshäuser fehlen, das fand ich richtig spannend, haben die so einfach Time-Shifting, also in einem Gebiet, was von mir erst zurückerobert wurde, hatten sie so ein Schild fotografiert, so irgendwie 9 bis 12 Uhr Synagoge, 12 bis 15 Uhr Moschee, 15 bis 18 Uhr Kirche. Und haben gesagt, die Ansprüche sind doch ungefähr gleich. Man braucht eine Kanzel, man braucht was unten zum Sitzen, also so unterschiedlich ist das jetzt ja nicht. Und was ich da auch spannend finde, dass die ganzen, also die Muftis, die Bischof oder wer da so zuständig ist, sagen, also bei uns steht nicht drin, dass das nicht geht. Also weder in der Bibel noch in der Thora noch im Koran steht, kann man nicht machen. Also auch so die Auslegung, wenn man so sieht, wie so Extremisten von allen Religionen das auslegen und wie es dann so Leute dort auslegen, die nebeneinander leben, die sagen, also hier steht nicht drin, dass ich nicht irgendwie und das schon seit 7000 Jahren mache. Ja genau und sagen, ey weißt du so, das haben wir schon vor 6500 Jahren so gemacht und vor 5000 als was brauchen, das ist nicht neu. Und das merkt man aber so im Alltag. Die Leute sind halt entspannt, die sind offen, sind interessiert, aber so eine Relaxtheit, also auch so, hey, da ist eine Brücke gesprengt worden, ja, fahren wir halt andersherum. Aber so passiert. Also so im ganzen Leben merkt man, dass die sind eine Menge gewohnt durch all die Kriege und so. Also durch die aktuellen, aber auch historisch. Und also egal, ob man zehn Jahre, 100, 500 zurückgeht, die hatten immer Probleme. Deswegen sagen die so, keine Ahnung, wenn jetzt mein Auto verreckt, da hat man schon schlimmere Probleme. Frag ich halt einen anderen, ob er mir eins leidt. Also so, das ist immer so schön gechillt, aber halt quer durch den Alltag. Und das ist interessant.
Das Verhältnis zwischen Männern und Frauen scheint mir ein bisschen anders gelagert zu sein. Ich meine, man sieht jetzt immer so bei den Peschmerga, halt so diese Frauen-Einheiten, die ja dann auch von Frauen kommandiert werden, etc. Ist das nur da so oder?
Ja, also zum einen muss man da sagen, wirklich an der Front habe ich kaum Frauen gesehen. Also die gibt es klar, diese Einheiten. Aber wirklich vor einem Kampfeinsatz werden sie eher selten eingesetzt, das muss man schon sagen. Aber trotzdem, die gibt es. Und es gibt ein paar sehr coole Bilder, wenn die Bundeswehr und die Peschmerger sich treffen und die Generäle reden und am Mikro stehen und die Presse kommen, ist oft irgendwo in der Gegend so eine Frau mit so dunkelblond gefärbten Haaren, eine junge Dame, 25, und das ist die Kontaktperson zwischen beiden Armeen, wo man auch denkt, also und die ist Kurdin. Und so dem Klischee nach passt das ja überhaupt nicht in das Bild. Die ist in Deutschland aufgewachsen, ist aber Kurdin und managt halt den Peschmerga-Bundeswehr-Kontakt. Die habe ich da auch mal kennengelernt in so einem Club. Also die sah aus wie so...
Also die gehört zur Bundeswehr?
Ja, ne, die gehört zu den Peschmerga. Und die sah im Club aus wie wenn hier jemand in Berlin feiern geht in dem Alter. Und dann habe ich halt gefragt, was sie macht, und sie hat mir das erklärt.
Da dachte ich irgendwie so, ja das ist ja gut, aber es passt so überhaupt nicht in dieses Bild rein.
Also irgendwie, da muss doch so ein alter Typ mit Bad und Orden oder so zwischen stehen. Und sonst ist es aber auch in der Gesellschaft so. Das fand ich auch ganz lustig. Wenn da so jüngere Männer zusammenstehen, da ist oft so ein Macho-Gehabe, wie man sich das vorstellt, aber nur solange Mutti nicht in der Nähe ist oder die Frau oder so, dann kippt das ganz schnell. Und oft verwalten die Frauen das Geld und haben damit die De facto Macht. Und es ist da auch noch viel so, dass die Frauen halt Haushalt und Familie machen und der Mann geht arbeiten, was dann hier immer so groß bemängelt wird. Da muss man sagen, dann frag mal im Freundeskreis, wer ist Hausmann und wo geht die Frau arbeiten? Das ist jetzt ja in Deutschland auch nicht so häufig. Also ich bin da, da sitzen wir immer auf einem sehr hohen Rost, bis man fragt, und bei dir zu Hause, wer hat den Vollzeitjob? Aber das Wichtige ist da, dass die nicht sagen, das ist ja nur der Haushalt, sondern die Frau kümmert sich um die Familie, die wichtig ist. Ich bringe ja nur die Kohle. Also so das Verhältnis, also die Sichtweise ist halt anders. Und dass das halt als deutlich gleichberechtigt gesehen wird. Ich denke, das ist ja der Punkt. Also wenn alle zufrieden sind, ist doch okay, aber der Respekt ist halt sehr deutlich da. Und wir hatten vor einem Jahr, ich glaube, nee, vor einem halben Jahr die Situation mal, da waren wir ein bisschen abseits in so einem, also als wir über Land gefahren sind, in so einem Café oder Restaurant-Dingen halt, haben irgendwas zwischendurch gefuttert. Und da kam ein Bus an mit irakischen Flaggen dran, irgendeine Reisegruppe oder so, und es brannte einen riesen Streit, den wir halt nicht verstanden haben, weil die sich halt auf Sorani oder Arabisch angekeift haben. Aber so 30, 40 Leute, die sich böse hin und her angeschrien und geschubst haben und so weiter, und wir saßen quasi in der Mitte um unseren Tisch und haben gegessen. Alle haben drauf geachtet, dass niemand vor unseren Tisch flog, oder so, es ging wirklich immer so um uns herum, was schon ein bisschen bizarr war. Und der Typ neben uns, der hat auch immer so ein Auge auf uns gehabt, dass auch nichts passiert. Und irgendwann holte er seine Jacke von über der Stuhle hin und zog so eine Maschinenpistole raus und hat den Leuten neben uns irgendwie klar gemacht, dass sie mal Abstand halten sollen zu unserem Tisch und setzte sich ganz ruhig wieder hin.
Wo ich auch dachte, so, okay, das war ja nett von dem.
Da war wieder ein bisschen mehr Platz. Und wir haben gedacht, was ist hier los und worum geht es eigentlich? Und irgendwann kam so eine Frau, also wirklich wie man sich so eine Hausfrau vorstellt, so ein bisschen gemütlicher, so um die 50 rein. Und da kam die eine aus dem Bus draußen und die andere aus der Küche. Also sozusagen die gegenüberliegenden Kontrahenten. Die haben sich jeweils ein paar von den Leuten gepackt.
Das waren aber nur Männer.
Nur Männer, die sich gespielt haben. Also fast nur junge Männer. Die beiden Frauen haben wirklich einmal in beide Richtungen gebrüllt. Und die irakische Mutti hat dem einen Typen rechts und links eine verpasst. Und es war wirklich in zwei Sekunden Totenstille. Alle sind in ihre Richtung gegangen. Der Bus fuhr weg und es ging weiter wie vorher. Also wie in so einem Western-Film. Schlägerei vorbei, Musik los.
Wir haben uns so gedacht, was zur Hölle ist hier gerade passiert?
Aber wir wussten, okay, man kann sich kloppen, man kann die Maschinenpistole rausholen, aber wenn Mutti kommt, ist Schicksal im Schacht.
Dann ist die Sache gelaufen.
Hast du noch erfahren, was der Streit war?
Nee, die waren alle sehr höflich und meinten, ach, das war irgendeine Kleinigkeit, ist nicht wichtig. Wir hatten dann gefragt, nee, nee, komm weiter, ist alles okay. Aber da habe ich auch gedacht, da war die Skala klar. Also Mutti kommt nach der Maschinenpistole. Und das habe ich dabei immer wieder erlebt. Oder auch so Straßen-Szenen. Da hat ein Mann eine Frau total angebrüllt und rumgekeift. Und ich hatte halt einen Dolmetscher dabei und habe gesagt, worum geht es denn da? Und der sagte, na ja, der Mann will sich das neue iPhone kaufen und die Frau sagt, dafür kriegst du die Kohle nicht. Und so kann sich die Situation halt ändern, wenn man die Sprache spricht oder nicht. Und das fand ich so, es waren so ein paar Erlebnisse. Wo ich einfach dachte, klar, das wird nicht in jeder Familie sein und so weiter, aber man sieht, das ist ein ausgewogenes Verhältnis. Also das ist ähnlich wie hier, würde ich sagen, dass man so eine meist funktionierende Gleichberechtigung hat.
Ist so ein bisschen abgestanden, dass man sowas schnell rausholt, aber so von meinem geringen Eindrücken, die ich so aus den Regionen des Nahen Ostens hatte, so eine Gastfreundschaft scheint schon ein wichtiger Teil des ganzen Spiels zu sein. Du bist ja quasi so als Fremder hingekommen. Ich habe schon so ein bisschen rausgehört, Deutschland scheint auch noch mal so eine besondere Rolle zu spielen in Kurdistan. Mich interessiert auch nochmal, warum eigentlich und wie sich das sozusagen so ausdrückt. Aber wie bist du denn da aufgenommen worden? War das jetzt nur, weil du gesagt hast, ich bin jetzt hier Journalist und ich berichte mal über die Krise?
Nee, also allgemein gibt es da halt wenig Tourismus. Also aus skandinavischen Ländern und aus den USA gibt es welche. Also weil das ist so die älteste durchgehend bewohnte Stadt der Welt. Die Hälfte der Bibel spielt da in der Gegend. Also aus Amiland kommen Christen oft in so organisierten Gruppen daher. Und auch so Missionare oder so diese christlichen Jugendorganisationen sind da, um gute Werke zu tun, um in den Himmel zu kommen im Prinzip. Na, ich denke, hey, am Ende, wenn sie helfen, ist ja gut. So habe ich ja nichts gegen. Da hatte ich auch ein paar getroffen und die waren auch nicht nervig oder wollten einen nicht selber in den Himmel bringen, sondern das waren so wie ganz normale Aid-Worker, die halt irgendwie da ihren Kram gemacht haben, die nur eben ihre Logos immer drauf hatten. Und wenn ich da bei irgendwo hingekommen bin, haben die Leute auch meist gefragt, bist du Erdölgesellschaft oder NGO? Und wenn man dann gesagt hat, beides nicht, ich gucke mir das Land an, dann war man schon so, oh, also das ist ja komisch. Aber halt immer interessiert und nett. Und auch bis heute, wo ja mehr Leute da sind, ist es immer wieder mal so, dass man zum Beispiel irgendwo nur kurz sich hinsetzt und Tee trinkt und will bezahlen. Die sagen, nee, ist schon okay, wenn du hier schon vorbeikommst, sei mein Gast oder so. Also dass die sich richtig freuen, dass Leute von woanders wieder dahin kommen. Und wenn man halt sagt, ich bin hier als Journalist, dann ist sofort eine Traube drumherum, weil alle irgendwas erzählen wollen. Und ich kenne einen, der ist wichtig und ich kann ihm was erzählen und ich weiß auch was. Das ist da manchmal ein bisschen anstrengend. Und es aber auch, wenn man das nicht sagt, die Leute sind immer also freundlich. Und also ganz oft ist es dann so mit Willst du nicht zu mir nach Hause kommen? Ich lade dich zum Essen ein. Ich kann dir was über Land und Leute erzählen und so weiter. Also dass die sich wirklich freuen, dass jemand kommt, der nicht da sein müsste. Also wenn man jetzt sagt, denke ich, ich bin Bundeswehr oder so, dann würden die sagen, hey, schön, dass du da bist. Aber wenn man halt nicht Geld für kriegt, dann ist nochmal so eine, nochmal so ein anderer Punkt, also wo die sich nochmal mehr freuen. Und Deutsche sind besonders gut angesehen. Also das Hauptargument, was ich höre, ist, dass die Deutschen die Kurden aufgenommen haben, als sie vor Saddam geflohen sind in den 90ern. Also das haben die nicht vergessen. Und häufig trifft man da auch Leute, die Deutsch sprechen, also zwischen schlecht und gut. Und die sagen, ja, ich war auch in Deutschland, ich habe da fünf Jahre oder so als Flüchtling gelebt. Das Spannende ist, also was einem da sofort auffällt, dass die immer erzählen, dass sie eine Wohnung und einen Job hatten, weil das damals ja noch anders war mit den Bedingungen, wo ich dachte, das ist doch das Paradebeispiel. Die kamen rüber, als sie fliehen mussten, haben ihren Job gemacht, haben in ihrer Wohnung gelebt, haben die Kultur und die Sprache kennengelernt und haben dann gesagt, vielen Dank, aber ich gehe jetzt zurück und war nett hier, aber eigentlich will ich wieder nach Hause. Also so, wie man sich ja im Prinzip Flüchtlingspolitik vorstellt, die meisten haben halt keinen Bock in Deutschland zu leben, weil das ist nicht ihre Heimat.
Ja, ich meine, kann man sich ja auch angenommen, wir hätten jetzt hier eine kriegerische Auseinandersetzung, die uns mal fünf Jahre irgendwie nach Syrien verschlagen würde. Also ich meine, wer würde denn davon ausgehen, kann ja passieren, aber wer würde denn davon ausgehen, dass man so denkt, ach, naja, also, hier scheint ja immer die Sonne. Ja, bleibe ich hier. Bleibe ich doch hier, ne?
Ja.
Leben ist halt nicht so.
Und genau, das denke ich immer, die Leute sehen immer Deutschland als das Paradies, wo jeder hin will. Guckt ihr mal die Gegend an, die ist auch nicht schlecht. Also ich finde es schon schwierig zu entscheiden, wo ich lieber bin.
Hat so beides eine Vor-
Ja, vor allem jetzt so im Oktober, wenn es wieder kälter wird, das überlegt man sich dann doch schon.
Ja, letzte Woche hatten wir halt 38 Grad, das war noch ganz angenehm.
Das wäre mir dann schon wieder zu viel.
Das sind die Herbsttemperaturen, im Sommer wird es warm.
Achso, okay.
Und dementsprechend so, also das ist wirklich auf breiter Masse, was die Leute im Kopf haben und was sie wirklich zu schätzen wissen und nicht vergessen haben.
Womit sich dann Deutschland auch allein über so eine Flüchtlingsaktivität, um das auch noch mal herauszuschälen, mit den Ländern, wo man geholfen hat, irgendwie eine Verbindung schafft, die vielleicht uns jetzt hier so im täglichen Geschehen nicht so klar ist, die sich aber in internationalen Beziehungen über Jahrzehnte hin entwickeln kann und hilfreich sein kann.
Ja, und auch jetzt aktuell, dass sie sagen, ihr schickt uns Ausbilder, die hier helfen, dass wir gegen den IS kämpfen können und alle kennen Merkel. Also es gibt ja auch wirklich einen Haufen Kinder in Kurdistan, die in den letzten Jahren Angela oder sogar Angela Merkel genannt wurden, weil die einfach gesagt haben, die ganze Welt hat gesagt, interessiert uns in Scheißdreck und nur die Deutschen haben gesagt, wir helfen euch. Also das ist wirklich so ein Bild, was die ganz massiv im Kopf haben, dass alle immer auf sie drauftreten und die Deutschen bei Saddam und jetzt bei den Flüchtlingsströmen gesagt haben, okay, wir helfen euch.
Weil es hat ja jetzt nicht nur Syrer betroffen, sondern eben auch Kurden in Syrien.
Genau. Und die autonome Region Kurdistan selber hat derzeit 2,1 Millionen Flüchtlinge aufgenommen bei 5 Millionen eigener Bevölkerung. Da ist das Interessante, davon sind eine Million Flüchtlinge aus dem Rest Irak, also die nach Norden einfach im Land geflohen sind, weil es da sicher ist. Und ungefähr eine Million aus Syrien, ein Großteil Kurden, also ungefähr 75 Prozent Kurden aus Syrien, einfach weil das kurdische Gebiet an der Grenze zum kurdischen Gebiet im Irak liegt. Ich habe auch selbst aus Damaskus und so weiter immer wieder Familien getroffen in den Camps, die gesagt haben, also sie wussten, sie wollen weg. Nach Israel geht es nicht. In Libanon, nur wenn man Kohle hat, das ist ganz interessant. Libanon hat so ein Problem mit Gentrifizierung durch Flüchtlinge, die reich sind. Also weil man mit Flüchtlingen ja immer assoziiert, das sind die Armen. Und gerade in den großen Städten im Libanon kommen die Flüchtlinge mit den Koffern voll Geld, kaufen die teuren Wohnung und leben drin. Also die Flüchtlinge halt, die mit Kohle aus Syrien kommen. Und das fand ich auch ein total interessantes Problem, was man sich hier überhaupt nicht vorstellen kann. Und Türkei, das ist so der Notnagel. Die lassen fast jeden rein. Also sie lassen einen am Leben und man kommt über die Grenze. Aber dann bist du auf dich selber gestellt. Aber es muss man bei aller Kritik an der Türkei sagen, ist immer noch besser als die Grenze zu machen. Also es ist halt auch immer so ein Punkt. Also sie kümmern sich nicht herzlich um die Leute, aber sie lassen die auch nicht an der Grenze stehen.
Ja, man hat auch viele Leute reingelassen.
Ja, Hunderttausende. Also das muss man einfach mal klar sagen. Und dann hat man eben die autonome Region Kurdistan, sozusagen als das geheiligte Land sagen, wenn man reinkommt. Also man kommt erst in so eine Art Aufnahmekamp für ein, zwei Tage, was relativ klar militärisch und so gesichert ist, weil man da die Leute identifizieren und erfassen muss. Aber das ist wirklich Übergang, ganz kurz. Also zwischen Stunden und zwei, drei Tage, je nachdem, wie gerade die Mengen an Leuten kommen. Und dann hat man eine lebenslange Aufenthalts- und Arbeitserlaubnis. Und die sagen, das ist der Grund, warum die Leute schnell zurückgehen. Weil man sich ja nicht final entscheiden muss, gehe ich jetzt weg und kann nicht wieder. Sondern man kann sagen, ich gehe mal zurück nach Syrien, guck, wie es ist. Wenn es nicht klappt, kann ich ja wiederkommen. Fand ich auch ein spannendes Konzept. Und solange man im Flüchtlingscamp ist, wird man mit allem Grundlegenden versorgt. Essen, Kleidung, Verletzung und so weiter. Also es ist wirklich Grundversorgung. Komplizierte medizinische Sachen können nicht versorgt werden und so weiter. Aber man hat eine solide Grundversorgung für mehr als zwei Millionen Leute, was schon mal beeindruckend ist. Aber sobald man das Camp verlässt, fällt halt diese Grundsicherung weg. Und es gibt in dem Sinne kein soziales System. Das heißt, dann ist man auch auf sich alleine gestellt und muss sich durchschlagen. Und das fand ich auch ganz spannend, als ich mit Kurden gesprochen habe. Hab gesagt, habt ihr hier Probleme mit den Flüchtlingen? Sagt, nö. Sagt, na, weil in Deutschland haben die Leute ja immer Angst vor Terroristen, vor die nehmen uns den Job weg und so weiter. Die sagen, ja klar, sie hatten acht terroristische Anschläge durch, also durch Leute in den Flüchtlingsströmen. Das fand ich auch spannend. Die haben nicht gesagt durch Flüchtlinge, sondern durch Terroristen, die mit den Flüchtlingen rüber kamen. Also alleine so diese Trennung, klar. Ja, und ich hab meinen Job verloren vor einem halben Jahr, weil die Flüchtlinge billiger arbeiten. Ich sagte, okay, dann habt ihr doch beides hier, was die Rechten in Deutschland immer predigen. Ich sagte, ja, da können die Leute doch nichts für. Und da habe ich gesagt, so hey, du hast deinen Job verloren, weil eine billige Flüchtlingskraft den übernommen hat. Ihr hattet Anschläge bei euch von Leuten, die sich im Flüchtlingsströmen getarnt haben. Und du hast kein Problem mit den Leuten. Du solltest mal rüberkommen und in Deutschland ein bisschen was erzählen über Umgang mit anderen Menschen. Und die haben auch gesagt, was in den Läden zum Teil ist. Also da wird immer noch gefeilscht, wie man es halt aus das Leben des Brian kennt, um jeden Preis so. Also es stehen im normalen Shop und so stehen schon Preise dran. Aber auf dem Basar wird halt gefeilscht, bis zum geht nicht mehr. Die sagen, und dann kommt so ein Flüchtling an und sagt, ey, ich hab keine Kohle. Man merkt es aber auch am Dialekt im Normalfall, dass der von woanders kommt. Und der kriegt sofort einen so billigen Preis, wie man ihn nicht verhandeln kann. Und alle drumrum sagen kein Wort dazu und fangen an weiter zu feilschen. Und sagt, das ist halt der Unterschied. Dass man sagt, klar, der hat keine Kohle. Natürlich wird der quasi subventioniert mit dem, was mir nachher wieder abgezockt wird. Aber so ist es eben. Und das finde ich schon beeindruckend, wie dieser Umgang mit den Leuten ist. Also dass sie sagen, ja, das ist aber gerade eine arme Sau und da gelten Sonderkugeln. Ja, ich denke, weil sie selber das erlebt haben, so viel. Also man muss bedenken, als hier die Mauer fiel. Also was ja jetzt mäßig lange her ist, also das haben wir ja alle noch mitgekriegt irgendwie. Da haben die Kurden in den Bergen an der iranisch-türkischen Grenze, also die aus dem Nordirak gesessen, sind von Saddam's Armee gejagt worden und von türkischer und iranischer Armee beschossen worden, damit sie nicht über die Grenze kommen. Und wenn man das halt so lange her hat, wie hier Mauerfall, dann glaube ich, versteht man gut, dass man nicht zu Leuten ist, denen es gerade selber schlecht geht, wenn man selber gerade einen verhältnismäßigen Wohlstand aufgebaut hat und eben nicht so egoistisch ist, dass man es vergessen hat.
Also könnte sich auch mal ändern.
Genau, wenn ein paar Generationen weiter ist oder so was, vielleicht auch. Also die, die es halt nicht mehr kennen, die sagen, keine Ahnung, interessiert mich nicht die alten Stories.
Trotzdem gibt es schon eine Kultur des Miteinanders.
Ja, definitiv. Also mir scheint da auch dieser Punkt, da sind halt, also man hat noch mit der weitgehenden Familie zu tun. So die kleine kurdische Hochzeit mit 500 Gästen oder sowas und die große da mit 2000, wo ich einfach denke, da hat man zwangsläufig mit arm und reichen Teilen der Familie zu tun oder mit verschiedenen Problemen oder so. Und da wird ja auch viel wirklich noch untereinander geklärt. Also wenn man auf dem Dorf zum Beispiel irgendwelche Straftaten hat, dann ist es immer noch so, dass selten das jetzt wirklich vor Gericht geht oder so, sondern man hat so die, so was wie die Dorfälteste oder wie man es nennen will. Und die sagen, okay, klar, gib ihm zurück, was du geklaut hast und tu irgendwas Gutes für ihn und die Sache ist okay oder so. Aber dass das so in der Community geregelt wird, was aber akzeptiert ist und was auch funktioniert in weiten Teilen. Und für größere Sachen und in den großen Städten gibt es auch halbwegs reguläre Sachen. Also da gibt es ganz normale Gerichte und Polizei und so weiter. Aber viel so in diesen, also so wie Micromanagement würde man im Business wahrscheinlich sagen, gibt es da noch. Ich denke, das ist dann aber auch nochmal ein anderer Punkt, wenn man also wenn man viele Dinge wirklich so im in der Gruppe klärt und halt nicht sozusagen outsourced an ein anonymes Gericht draußen oder sowas. Also ich denke auch diese, also manchmal diese Klagewut in Deutschland, so der Klassiker mit, da hat ein Ast in meinen Garten gehangen und jetzt klage ich. Wenn man das auf so einer Ebene hätte, dann würde der Dorfälteste sagen, so komm mal klar und nerv mich nicht und fertig. Das ist halt Vor- und Nachteil, je nachdem, worum es jetzt geht. Also es ist nicht per se das bessere oder schlechtere System, aber bei vielen, denke ich, klappt es da im Moment noch, also so wie die Strukturen jetzt sind. Man merkt aber auch, dass es da langsam umbricht, dass die jüngeren Familien halt wirklich mit ihrer Familie so in deutscher Größe, in einer eigenen Wohnung, in einem eigenen Haus oder so leben, also im kleineren Rahmen, und man halt nicht mehr mit Oma und Opa noch direkt in der Nachbarschaft lebt wie mit Onkel und Tante oder mit einem großen Haus, wo dann 20 Leute drin leben. Ich denke schon, dass sich das jetzt auch Stück für Stück über die nächsten wahrscheinlich 10, 20 Jahre oder so, das dauert ja eine Weile, auch ändern wird. Aber im Moment ist das noch ganz spannend zu sehen. Ich denke, dass das halt wirklich auch zu diesem Gemeinschaftsgefühl und zu man muss Sachen lösen und nicht quasi die Klage extern abgeben und dann kümmert sich einer drum oder so, dass das noch mehr im Bewusstsein ist.
Vielleicht daran anschließend frage ich mich jetzt gerade, man kennt ja so Bilder aus Afghanistan und so weiter. Man hat so Regionen, da gibt es dann die Warlords, da gibt es halt so starke einzelne Persönlichkeiten, die mit ihren Clans oder Milizen oder beidem in irgendeiner Form zumindest so Teilregionen haben und dass im Prinzip so die Idee Rechtsstaat eigentlich nur sehr, wie soll ich sagen, im Ansatz zu erkennen ist und regional quasi dann eben das Gesetz des, wer auch immer gerade das Sagen hat, gilt. Du hast ja auch eingangs schon gesagt, dass es auch in Kurdistan Gruppen gibt, die sich jetzt nur so begrenzt mögen und über Föderales nachgedacht wird und so weiter. Wie nimmst du das wahr, wie das in Kurdistan so de facto aussieht?
Das ist also zum Teil kompliziert auch zu erklären, auch historisch. Also so ganz grob, die relevanten Politiker da, die haben so ungefähr das Alter wie hier. Also die kommen so aus unseren Nachkriegsjahren. Die sind zum Teil seit den 70ern, 80ern in der Politik. So das ist so ein bisschen gemeinsam. Der große Unterschied ist, dass also die zwei Wesentlichen, also Massoud Basani und Jalal Talabani generell im Kampf gegen Saddam schon waren und dann in den 70er Jahren ihre Parteien gegründet haben. Also so Mitte der 70er, 74, 75, 76 konnten die Kurden Parteien gründen, die aber überhaupt keine Relevanz von irgendetwas hatten. Sie waren einfach nur da. Aber dadurch hat man so eine Verknüpfung von militärischen Führern und Parteichefs. Also was hier ja eine total obskure, komische Sache wäre, was sich aber dadurch begründet, dass sie eben den Kampf gegen Saddam militärisch geleitet haben und dann eben politisch das auch in die Hand genommen haben. Und die sind bis heute, also Massoud Basani ist der Präsident von der autonomen Region Kurdistan und Jalal Talabani war der Präsident vom Irak bis vor ein paar Jahren. Wobei der Präsident im Irak nicht das Entscheidende ist, sondern der Premierminister. Das heißt aber, die haben beide wichtige Rollen inne und sind halt Parteichef, Präsident vom jeweiligen Bereich und Generäle. Also so eine komplizierte Verknüpfung. Und wenn man sich die auch die großen Unternehmer, die großen Politiker so anguckt da in der Gegend, die heißen fast alle oder nicht fast alle, sagen wir ein großer Teil, entweder Basani oder Talibani mit Nachnamen, sich vorstellen kann, wenn man so in einem Machtzentrum sitzt, dann hat man natürlich schlichtweg Connections. Also selbst wenn man jetzt nicht bösartig sozusagen die Macht ausnutzen will, wenn man Leute kennt, hat man es einfacher im Leben. Also und wenn man dann zum Beispiel anfängt... Ja, ich wollte sagen, also ich glaube es gibt keinen Minister, dessen Kind Hartz IV bezieht in Deutschland zum Beispiel. Und also deswegen denke ich auch immer genau, so anders ist es hier auch nicht. Also da ist schon deutlich größerer, also es sind deutlich mehr Leute, die dann zum Clan gehören. Das muss man schon sagen, aber so von der Tendenz her kennt man es. Aber was da der Punkt ist, also zum einen bei den Wahlen, das ist auch immer interessant. Also wie oft ich höre, da gibt es Wahlfälschung und die Wahlen können gar nicht seriös sein. Und die jetzt regierende Partei, KDP, also zu der Masud Basani gehört, die hatte bei den...
Die demokratische Partei Kurdistans.
Genau, und das Gegenstück von Taliban ist die PUC, die Patriotische Union Kurdistan. Man kann halt sagen, das sind beides die großen Volksparteien, die meiner Meinung nach auch inhaltlich dicht beisammenliegen. Also das ist... Ja, genau so in etwa. Die haben aber geografisch extreme Mehrheiten, also so wie früher vielleicht NRW und Bayern oder so, wo jeweils eine Partei stark ist. Und so ist es durch die autonome Region Kurdistan. Der Nordwesten ist KDP oder Basaniland und der Südosten ist halt PUC oder Talibaniland. Ist im Alltag aber auch im Großen und Ganzen egal, aber es ist halt ganz, ganz klar so. Und das ist dann aber so. Die jetzt regierende Partei hatte bei den allerersten Wahlen in Kurdistan irgendwas um die 90 Prozent, bei der nächsten noch über 50 und bei der letzten 33. Und sagt, wenn die mit Wahlfälschung auf 33 Prozent kommen, dann machen sie es irgendwie falsch. Also irgendwie fällt dieses Argument dann immer schwierig zu glauben, dass sie die dümmsten Wahlfälscher der Welt sind. Weil dann wird man halt nicht koalieren. Dann hätte man 50,1 zumindest oder sowas. Und es halten sich so die immer gleichen Vorwürfe oder auch, dass auch jemand aus dem Basaniklan, das größte Telekommunikationsunternehmen, KOREK hat und gleichzeitig auch General in der Armee ist. Das stimmt auch, da spricht gar nichts gegen. Und der hatte natürlich gute Startchancen, wenn er alle Leute kennt und ein Mobilfunknetz aufbaut. Was bei SoStories dann aber auch oft unter den Tisch fallen gelassen wird, es gibt vier weitere Mobilfunknetze. Also und KOREK hat nicht mal das beste Netz und nicht mal die besten Tarife. Aber viele Kurden nehmen das sozusagen aus Patriotismus, weil die sagen, das ist unser Netz von einem von uns. Und ich gehe doch nicht zu ASIA SELL oder zum türkischen Netzanbieter. Aber könnte man auch oder umgekehrt bei den Talibanis, da gibt es zum Beispiel einen großen Bauunternehmer. Da kann ich mir auch vorstellen, klar, wenn man am Anfang, wenn es überhaupt darum ging, dass man wieder Sachen aufbauen konnte und man kannte die Leute im Ausland, dann war man der Erste, der mal einen Betonmixer überholen konnte oder so, da hat man einen guten Staat. Dann hat man als erster Häuser gebaut und wenn es Aufträge gibt, ist man der mit der Erfahrung. Also wenn man einmal einen guten Staat hat und sich nicht blöd anstellt, bleibt man ja dabei. Aber da halt auch wieder, es gibt halt auch andere Unternehmen, die es machen. Aber natürlich, wenn man da zum Clan gehört, ist es bequemer. Deswegen merkt man, da gibt es schon de facto Machtkonzentration bei verschiedenen Familien oder bei verschiedenen Clans. Aber auf der anderen Seite sehe ich halt nicht, zumindest bei einem, was ich erlebt habe, dass sie aktiv andere ausboten oder sowas. Und das, finde ich, ist halt der entscheidende Teil. Also natürlich kann man sagen, ich bin am längsten da, ich bin der Beste, ich bin der Coolste. Aber es gibt halt auch andere. Ich meine hier, also auch wenn das jetzt nicht mit Clanstrukturen zu tun hat, aber die Telekom hat hier immer noch die Vorherrschaft auf dem Markt, obwohl es andere gibt, weil sie halt lange da waren. Das kennt jeder. Sie haben den Vorteil, dass sie die Infrastruktur ordentlich stehen haben, diese nicht mal direkt bezahlt haben und so weiter. Das ist halt so ein klassisches Ding von wer zuerst da war oder auch mit Post und DHL, dass die immer noch den Markt dominieren und nicht weil alle sagen, die bringen die beste Dienstleistung, sondern man kennt es halt.
Ich habe gerade mal einen Blick in den Korruptionswahrnehmungsindex von Transparency International geworfen, weil ich höre oft, um mir da vielleicht eine Einschätzung abholen zu können, aber mangels staatlicher Struktur ist das hier nicht einzeln aufgeführt und der Irak wiederum landet auf Platz 166.
Wenig überraschend.
Wenig überraschend und von daher ist da jetzt kein Informationsgewinn zu holen.
Ja, das finde ich auch oft so schade, weil ich denke, dann räumt doch in so Berichten so eine Art Sonderstatus ein. Man muss ja nicht sagen, wir betrachten euch wie ein Staat, aber man kann doch de facto sagen, dass... Das ist eine andere Sache. Also man kann auch, finde ich, schwerlich Gaza und Israel in einen Topf werfen, weil dementsprechend wäre Gaza ein Hightech-Standort, wenn man so einen Durchschnitt bildet über alle Sachen und da müssten die Dotcom-Firmen nach Gaza gehen, weil die Grundstückspreise niedrig und der Development Index hoch wäre. Aber damit überzeugt man auch keinen. Und deswegen, das denke ich oft bei so Sachen, auch Pressefreiheit wird Kurdistan auf einem ganz schlimmen Platz mitgeführt, also Irak einfach. Bei der Karte von Reporter ohne Grenzen ist das halt farbe schwarz, also so kurz vor du wirst erschossen. Und da hatte ich auch so 2013 so ein tolles Erlebnis, da sind Soldaten irgendwie hin und her marschiert und also das ist auch so in den wenigen Jahren. Ich habe mich halt total an Unmengen Soldaten und wirres Equipment gewöhnt, aber als das neu war, war es so, oh da passiert was und da so wie wenn die Kinder vom Dorf nach Berlin kommen und spannend finden, wenn ein Polizeibus rumfährt, wo wir in Berlin sagen, ja das habe ich schon mal gesehen. Und hat halt die Soldaten gefilmt, wie sie da so irgendwie sich vorbereitet haben für einen Einsatz oder irgendwas durch den Zaun. Dann kam ein anderer Soldat her und hatte mich halt angesprochen, ich habe ihn halt nicht verstanden und habe erstmal die Kamera runter genommen und dachte, okay, offensichtlich darf ich hier nicht filmen und der gestikulierte aber rum und irgendwie lief das aneinander vorbei. Dann zeigte er mir halt, dass ich mitkommen soll. Da dachte ich, okay, also im schlimmsten Fall wollen sie, dass ich die Aufnahme lösche oder so. Die nahm ich dann mit rein zu einem Sprachmittler, der mir erklärt hat, also ich kann gerne filmen, ich soll doch reinkommen, weil mit dem Zaun dazwischen sieht das doch scheiße aus. Okay, also das war wahrscheinlich auch auf den Richtigen getroffen gerade, also Glück gehabt, aber trotzdem, wo ich so dachte, okay, interessant, also so wieder halt nicht das, was man erwartet. Und das ist auch bis heute so, immer wenn ich da bin und sage, ich bin hier als Journalist, ich will was berichten, dann heißt es immer, okay, nimm dir einen Tee, wir rufen den General, den Oberst, also den Höchsten, den wir hier haben, und was können wir für dich tun? Und ich meine, im Moment ist es ja auch klar so, sie sind die Gewinner moralisch und militärisch und so. Sie haben eine gute Story zu verkaufen. Und ich denke, dann ist man auch immer sehr gerne bereit, Presse ranzuholen. Oder halt in den 90ern, als sie der Underdog waren, der von Saddam verfolgt wurde. Also so in den ganzen Jahren ihrer Geschichte gab es ja auch nichts, was sie vor der Presse verstecken mussten. Also entweder das Leid oder die Erfolge ist immer gut, während Länder mit hoher Korruption und ähnlichen Kram ja meist auch pressescheu sind. Und deswegen denke ich immer, wenn man so offen gegenüber Presse ist, habe ich schon ein ganz gutes Gefühl dabei. Und auch selbst schwierige Gegenden, wo irgendwie die umkämpft sind und sonst was, da haben wir immer wieder gehört, wartet mal hier, weil da vorne knallt es echt. Also da wollen wir euch echt nicht hinschicken. Zum einen wisst ihr, was ihr hier tut und was ihr da wollt, wenn man dann sagt, ja, ich habe hier quasi die Beweisbilder. Ich war schon da, wo es knallt. Ich weiß, worauf ich mich einlasse. Dann heißt es, okay, dann lass uns aber warten. Wir holen dir ein paar Leute zum Schutz drum rum, weil alleine solltest du dich da nicht rumtreiben. Aber das ist so der Worst Case, den ich erlebt habe, dass man eine Stunde wartet, bis irgendeine Einheit kommt, die sagt, setz dich mal zwischen uns, weil dann fliegen dir nicht direkt die Kugeln um die Ohren. Aber halt kein, du darfst hier nicht oder das geht nicht oder das kann man nicht filmen. Und auch jetzt, als ich letzte Woche da war, es ist auch so bis zur Landung, ist oft unklar, was man genau macht und was passiert. Also ich habe oft so einen groben Plan, ich möchte die Ecke sehen, ich will das sehen, ich möchte da was angucken. Aber vieles ergibt sich vor Ort. Und als ich morgens um fünf oder sechs auf dem Weg zum Flughafen war, also jetzt vor zehn Tagen ungefähr, rief das Department for Foreign Relations von der kurdischen Regionalregierung an und hat gesagt, hallo, du kommst doch heute Mittag vorbei. Du bist zu einem Event eingeladen, also dass du dir das angucken kannst und wir holen dich vom Flieger ab. Sagt, okay, super. Ja und alles andere klären wir später. Okay, Wert abgeholt, das ist das Entscheidende. Und wurde dann am Flughafen, das war ganz lustig, da kam gerade eine Delegation vom britischen Unterhaus an, die sie also auch besonders versorgen mussten. Und dann haben sie halt gesagt, weißt du, bevor wir dich quasi über einen anderen Weg schleusen als die, um die wir uns auch kümmern müssen, ihr geht jetzt alle ins Regierungsterminal und fertig. Und dann saß ich halt schön im Regierungsterminal, am Flughafen, auf bequemen Couches mit Essensbuffet und allem zwischen dem britischen Unterhaus und habe da mein Pass einer Art Battler gegeben, der sagte, ich gehe mal eben zur Grenzkontrolle und hole dir einen Stempel und komme da mit deinem Gepäck wieder, möchtest du was trinken? Und dann bin ich halt von da zum Stadion in Erbil gefahren worden, wo der Präsident eine Rede zum Unabhängigkeitsreferendum gehalten hat mit 80.000 Leuten im Stadion. Und die haben mich dann halt einfach mit auf die Ehrentribüne vom Präsidenten gesetzt, weil man meinte, hier hast du einen guten Blick, hier kannst du filmen und fotografieren, viel Spaß. Und da saßen so, ich gebe mal auf, total geil, so auf 200 Leute oder so, die da in dem Bereich saßen. Und da saß dann der Premierminister, der Präsident, Verteidigungsminister, die großen Generäle, die großen Vertreter von den Scheichfamilien. Also das sind keine Scheichs mehr mit Ölquellen oder so, so einflussreiche Familien. Also alles, was Rang und Namen hat, saß da halt rum und dann saß ich dazwischen. Und das fand ich auch ganz spannend und hatte dann auch gefragt, will mich ja nicht beschweren, aber was tue ich hier? Die haben gesagt, naja, du berichtest doch immer von hier und irgendwer hat irgendweben gesagt, du kommst vorbei und wir sollen dich mal hinsetzen, dass du hier ordentlich filmen kannst und Bilder machen kannst. Aber so, ohne dass man jetzt so einen Presseoffizier daneben hat, der sagt, guck doch mal da und film mal das und jetzt hier mal das, dann wird halt reingeschmissen und ungefähr so plötzlich, wie es losging, endete es dann auch irgendwann war rege Betriebsamkeit und alle liefen los und dort, okay, laufe ich mal hinterher, so nach zwei Stunden. Ging es irgendwie aus dem Stadion raus, so was passiert jetzt, wie geht es weiter? Dann haben auch zwei Leute gesagt, wir gehen noch essen, willst du mitkommen? Okay, das war der Verteidigungsminister, den erkenne ich und das andere war der Chefdiplomat, der hatte vorher gefragt und sagte, hey, wir gehen noch mit ein paar Leuten essen, kommst du mit? Irgendwer hat noch mein Gepäck? Kein Problem, das finden wir schon, steig ein. Ich dachte so, okay, das ist zum Teil auch so ein bisschen wir und habe dann gesagt, okay, wo fahren wir hin, wer kommt da mit und worum geht es? Und dann fragten alle anderen im Auto erstmal so, wer bist du eigentlich?
Und dann hat er gesagt, ich sitze da mit, ich bin Blockhaut-Deutsch.
Die kannten dich gar nicht, haben dich einfach mitgenommen.
Genau, weil man muss ja höflich sein, wenn der da so ein bisschen verloren rumsteht und zu keiner Delegation oder Gruppe offensichtlich gehört, die grad hier im Konvoi rennen und...
Also ich dachte, du hast jetzt schon da so einen mega-Status, dass der da irgendwie... das Regierungsterminal freigeräumt wird.
Ich dachte, die sagen, den Enno nehmen wir mit. Also so eine Handvoll Leute kenne ich schon. Also den Chefdiplomaten, den kenne ich, weil der auch hier in Deutschland, der also der Konsul für die autonome Region Kurdistan ist, also einen Botschafter haben sie ja nicht, aber so ein Vertreter, also so wie früher ständige Vertretung oder sowas in der Art, den kenne ich von hier. Und ich kannte auch zwei, der Generäle und den Präsidenten, aber die restlichen 295 Leute halt nicht. Und davon die anderen haben dann einfach gesagt, nimm halt mit. Und dann saßen wir dazwischen irgendwie diversen wichtigen Leuten, die auch alle einfach höflich und nett waren. Aber wo ich auch dachte, hier könnte man sich das überhaupt nicht vorstellen, bei so einem Abendessen mit Merkel oder eine wichtige Rede, dass dann einer sagt, komm mal mit, wir gehen noch was fuddern, bevor du hier blöd rumstehst.
Das Gegenteil, du wirst ja auch mit Akkreditierung nach ein paar Tagen wieder rausgeschmissen.
Genau.
Weil Datenbankfehler.
Also da passiert so was häufiger. Und das ist dann auch der Punkt im Prinzip. Daran entscheidet sich dann, wie interessant die jeweilige Reise wird oder nicht. Hätte das nicht so angefangen, dann wäre ich wahrscheinlich mit einem Leihwagen so wie üblich rumgefahren, ein paar Flüchtlingscams angeguckt und so weiter. Und in dem Moment sagen alle, also ich fahre morgen da in die Front, ich fahre da in das Camp, ich habe da ein Gespräch, ich will jetzt mit. Sagt man auch so, wie unkompliziert das ist. Also ihr wisst weder, was für eine Reichweite ich habe, noch genau, was ich tue. Aber halt erst mal komm doch mit, wenn du was sehen willst, ich habe was zu zeigen.
Die Rolle wollte ich auch gleich nochmal genauer zu sprechen kommen, vielleicht mit der Pressefreiheit nochmal kurz abzurunden. So das allgemeine Medienlandschaft in Kurdistan.
Die ist gut, aber Parteien geprägt muss man auch. Oder wieder so zentriert um diese paar Interessengruppen, oder wie man es nennen will. Also die beste Quelle für Leute aus Deutschland ist Rudau oder also Rudolf geschrieben, weil die englischsprachige News am Fließband produzieren. Die sind finanziert oder querfinanziert jetzt nicht direkt über Leute von den Basanis auch. Also nicht nur die erwirtschaften auch eigenes Geld, aber sagen wir, die haben deutlich Starthilfe gegeben. Allerdings haben die Parteien auch richtig eigene Medien und meist Fernsehsender, also irgendein Satellitenkanal, wo echt so low budget ihre Nachrichten laufen und Webseiten und so weiter. Zeitungen haben gar keine Relevanz, allein weil es kein Verteilsystem gibt, gar kein richtiges Postsystem im Land. Das ist auch ganz interessant. Also wenn man was von A nach B befördern muss wirklich, dann ist es oft so, dass man das so einem Linientaxi oder einem Bus oder so mitgibt und sagt, hier kannst du das in dem und dem Dorf rauswerfen, hier hast du einen Zehner, so nach dem Motto. Oder dann sagt einer, ich komme aus dem Dorf, an wen soll denn das? Also so irgendwie, aber halt kein richtig geordnetes System. Und zumindest, also ich habe mir mal so ganze Nachrichtensendungen von den verschiedenen Sachen auch in der Originalsprache dann übersetzen lassen von Freunden hier. Die haben gesagt, die berichten auch eigentlich nichts Falsches oder so. Aber sie berichten dann zum Beispiel nicht alles. Also das ist zum Beispiel ein großes Meeting und es geht nur darum, unser Parteivorsitzender hat dort geschebrochen und alle haben gejubelt. Dass es eigentlich um US-Präsidenten ging, ist dann so am Rande runtergekippt oder irgendwie sowas in der Art. Also sagen, das sind jetzt nicht wirklich Fake News, aber optimiert auf die jeweilige Zielgruppe, könnte man sagen. Also so Mittel. Und es gibt aber auch ordentliche Nachrichten, die halt eigentlich auch, also wie ich meinen würde, unabhängig sind unseren Standards nach. Also gerade bei Rudao konnte ich es ein paar Mal testen, weil ich mit denen also irgendwo war, wo sie berichtet haben und ich auch. Und wir sind zusammen hin und her gefahren und konnte dann nachher ihre Artikel lesen und gucken, war das das, was ich auch gesehen habe. Und das war immer das Gleiche und auch regierungskritische Sachen immer wieder bei, also sodass man sagen kann, das ist okay. Aber bei fast allen Nachrichtenquellen ist es da so, dass sie halt finanziell also mehr oder weniger oder total von ihrer jeweiligen Partei abhängen und die natürlich das Geld abdrehen könnten. Also ich habe nie gehört, dass so was da de facto passiert ist, aber trotzdem ist das noch so eine Schwierigkeit. Also nicht, dass es im Alltag ein Problem darstellt, aber dass man immer sagen muss, es könnte ein Problem werden, wenn mal der Falsche am Drücker sitzt, so rum.
Das ist ja auch so eine Frage. Jedes Land hat ja in irgendeiner Form so auch so seine Vorbilder. Und vielleicht mal von den USA mal abgesehen, die sich ja selbst für die Geisten halten. Aber der Einfluss, man in Deutschland war es klar, nach dem Krieg der westliche Einfluss, gerade was so die Medienlandschaft betrifft. Aber oft gerade bei so Ländern mit Entwicklungspotenzial gibt es ja dann so im Prinzip so ein paar Leuchttürme, woran man sich eben orientieren möchte, die es so ein bisschen auch vorgeben. Was ja, sagen wir mal, gerade im Falle der Türkei zum Beispiel so auch so dieser Battle ist. Also wohin will die Türkei, woran orientieren die sich, orientieren die sich an die EU, orientieren die sich jetzt eher an Russland oder anderen schlechten Vorbildern. Was denkst du, wohin orientiert sich Kurdistan? Ich meine, das ist ja auch geopolitisch schon immer natürlich auch ein Streitpunkt gewesen, aber die Einflüsse sind ja nun mannigfaltig. Bis nach Russland ist nicht weit, bis Iran ist nicht weit, der arabische Raum, Europa.
Also im Großen und Ganzen an Deutschland und den USA. Also ich denke, USA, also von der Theorie der Demokratie her ist das da ja auch nicht schlecht. Also wirres Wahlsystem und so, das kommt dann auf die Ausführung an. Aber grundsätzlich ist ja nicht falsch, sich mal einer Demokratie zu orientieren. Da scheint man halt USA, weil die einfach derzeit wieder extrem helfen im Kampf gegen den IS. Also man kriegt immer mit, die helfen uns. Also müssen es die Guten sein, ganz simpel. Und in Deutschland ist es aber eigentlich das Gleiche. Also ich kenne wenig, dass Leute gesagt haben, hey, ich habe mir mal euer Grundgesetz durchgelesen. Und die Art, wie ihr Demokratie organisiert, finde ich ganz spannend, sondern eher, dass die sagen, er tut Gutes, ihr helft uns. Also könnt ihr nicht falsch sein in dem, was ihr macht. Was man dabei schon merkt, was ich spannend finde, die Leute finden alle Demokratie wichtig. Also was ja schon mal ein guter Grundkonsens ist. Natürlich findet jeder besonders wichtig, dass seine Partei dann auch gewählt wird. Da gab es auch große Schwierigkeiten in den letzten Jahren. Es gab, also es war klar, das war verabschiedet, dass es eine Änderung geben soll, wie Parlament und Präsident gewählt wird. Die wählen das unabhängig voneinander, was ich ganz spannend finde. Und es gab die Idee, dass die verschiedenen Zyklen haben, in denen sie gewählt werden, also dass der Parlament, das Parlament wechselt, während der gleiche Präsident dran ist und umgekehrt, was ich auch einen spannenden Ansatz fand, um so ein bisschen Macht zu zerstreuen. Und bei der einen Partei, also bei der PUC, die wollten gerne, dass das Parlament den Präsidenten wählt, weil das wahrscheinlich zu der Zeit für sie von Vorteil gewesen wäre, während die PDK wollte, dass das Volk den Präsidenten wählt, weil das zu ihrem Vorteil wäre. Man sagen muss, ist ja per se beides nicht schlecht, aber wo man merkte, der Streit eskalierte doch sehr, weil natürlich jeder gerne das demokratische System haben will, was zu seinem Vorteil ist. Aber immerhin hat keiner gesagt, wir wollen König oder eine Erdmonarchie, sondern es ging halt um Varianten von Demokratie. Und das fand ich schon mal sehr beruhigend.
Der Anlass an deiner Reise war, da zu sein während des Referendums, von dem, glaube ich, wenig Leute mitbekommen haben. Letzte Woche war dann auch eher das Referendum in Katalonien das, was Europa mehr so beschäftigt hat. Aber seit längerem war klar, dass die Kurden jetzt den nächsten Schritt gehen und nicht nur sagen, naja, wir haben das jetzt hier militärisch zumindest soweit abgesichert und haben uns jetzt auch noch hier so die Zecke IS so ein bisschen aus der Haut gepult. Jetzt wollen wir sozusagen auch den alten Traum wahrmachen. Weil man muss ja auch, wenn man noch mal zurückblickt, haben sie mit dem Nahen Osten, mit, also einer der Gründe, sicherlich nicht der einzige, aber wahrscheinlich sogar der Hauptgrund des fortgesetzten Stresses, ist halt die absurde Aufteilung dieser Regionen nach der kolonialen Besetzung vor allem der Briten. Ich weiß nicht, andere Gruppen haben ja auch noch eine Rolle da gespielt, aber gerade jetzt in diesem Bereich und diese ganzen langgezogenen, geraden Linien, die da durch die Wüste ziehen, wo man immer so denkt, naja, da ist ja wahrscheinlich nur Wüste. Ja, da machen wir halt mal eine Linie, weil was sonst so? Da gibt es ja sonst keine Orientierungspunkte. Der Grund ist halt einfach der, dass man sich eben nicht zu viel Mühe gemacht hat, damals die Einflussgebiete da neu zu ordnen und dann war es halt so. Und die Länder wurden dann zurückgelassen mit so, jetzt kommt mal klar, jetzt macht man hier Start, weil kann ja so schwer nicht sein. Wir haben jetzt hier noch vor der Sendung kurz gekichert über so eine ähnliche Zeichnung, wo mal jemand was Vergleichbares mit Europa gemacht hat, wo sich ein Greater Bavaria irgendwie quer über Belgien erstreckt hat. Was das für Stress bringen würde, kann sich glaube ich jeder ganz gut vorstellen. Und hier ist auch so. Und sicherlich gibt es viele kleinere Gruppen, die hier quasi mit dem Bagger überfahren wurden. Nur Kurdistan ist ja nun auch also ethnisch und geschichtlich eine der allergrößten Volksgruppen überhaupt und die wurden halt mit nichts abgespeist. Also es gab noch nicht mal irgendwas, was irgendwie so hieß. Und jetzt soll sich das ändern nach gefühlten 100 Jahren.
Genau.
Also es gab ja ganz kurz am Rande vom Iran die Republik Mahabat. Also es war so ein Kurdistan, was ein paar Jahre existiert hat. Allerdings, das war kurz da und war dann wieder weg. Und jetzt ging es eben um die autonome Region Kurdistan, also nur im Nordirak. Zum einen haben die halt seit 20 Jahren eigene staatliche Strukturen. Die haben vor allem durch Öl eigenes Geld und so weiter, was ja immer so die entscheidenden Dinge sind. Sie haben seit halt mehr als zehn Jahren eigene diplomatische Kontakte auch. Also so man sagen kann, die Grundlage ist zumindest da. Das ist jetzt nicht völlig aus der Luft gegriffen, dass man sagt, hey, wir hatten gerade eine Schnapsidee oder so, sondern... Die wissen, wie man es organisiert. Da haben wir eben eine eigene Kultur, Sprache, Flagge und so weiter. So ein Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl. Also das, wo man sagen könnte, was so eine Basis zumindest ist, dass man drüber nachdenken kann. Und vor ungefähr drei Jahren waren sie schon mal an dem Punkt, dass sie ein Referendum machen wollten. Und dann hat der IS Mosul überfallen. Da hat man noch gesagt, ja, müsste man ja loswerden. Allerdings, als dann klar wurde, dass der IS doch stärker ist, als man dachte, weil das ja vorher nicht abzusehen war, haben sie halt um internationale Hilfe gebeten. Und die Amerikaner haben gesagt, na, wir helfen gerne einem integralen Irak, der Bestand hat, aber wir helfen ungern so einer abtrünnigen Region. Also ist klar, wir helfen gerne Kurdistan, dem Bundesland im Irak, aber nicht der Republik Kurdistan. Und dann war das Thema erst mal vom Tisch, weil die Alpen im Rücken an der Wand standen und die Luftangriffe brauchten. Auch die Bundesregierung hat dann ja erst kurz danach reagiert und ja, wie die Kurden immer sagen, die Grundlage für ein militärhistorisches Museum geliefert und ein paar Waffen, was da ankam. Also es war, also zum Teil, also waren wirklich viele zweite Weltkriegswaffen bei, die da ankamen.
Aus Deutschland?
Also das G36 wird hier immer so gefeiert, als dass es rüber ging, wo die gesagt haben, darüber sind sie auch sehr glücklich. Die ganzen zweiten Weltkriegswaffen konnten sie jetzt echt nicht so richtig benutzen, leider, weil da ist die Kalashnikov doch ein Stück moderner.
So was hat Deutschland noch empfunden?
Jaja, jetzt nicht mehr. Und noch so eine Randstory ist ja, dass die Bundeswehr leider kein Flugzeug hatte, was bis Erbil fliegen konnte und deswegen von einer ukrainischen Sonderluftfrachtfirma Cargo Maschinen anmieten musste. Aber gut, es kam an, waren ja auch sinnvolle Sachen bei. Seitdem war das immer so schwebend so, man war kurz davor und so, eigentlich hätte man das gerne. Es hieß erst mal das Referendum machen, also de facto war allen klar, da wird eine deutliche Mehrheit für ja stimmen, aber die Regionalregierung hat halt gesagt, wir brauchen das als Legitimation, um in die Verhandlungen zu treten. Also die haben ja nie gesagt, wir machen das und ziehen die Grenze hoch und sagen Tschüss, sondern mit dem Referendum gehen wir in die Verhandlungen mit Bagdad, aber dann können wir sagen, sind es irgendwie 51 oder 99 Prozent, die hinter uns stehen, wenn wir hier am Verhandlungstisch sitzen. Und dann muss man sehen, wie man die Nummer geklärt kriegt, dass man sauberen Abgang hat. Und vor ungefähr zwei Monaten war klar, wann der Referendumstermin dann jetzt sein sollte. Und ich habe dann auch sofort mein Ticket gebucht für den Flug und gesagt, alles andere später. Und in den nächsten zwei Tagen haben die Flugpreise sich fast verdoppelt, wo ich dachte, okay, da fliegen noch ein paar Leute in der Zeit hin. Und jetzt in den letzten Tagen, also als dann als Folge des Referendums, der Irak eine Luftraum-Sperrung über Kurdistan angekündigt hat, sind die Preise für ein Ticket Erbil-Wien von 400 Dollar auf 2000 gestiegen, innerhalb von zwölf Stunden. Das fand ich auch noch ganz spannend. Aber genau, er sagt, fürs Referendum muss ich dahin. Zum einen, um wirklich da zu sein, um zu sehen, wie läuft das hier ab? Also wie ist so ein Referendum? Also ich meine, dass ein Staat entsteht und da ja auch eine gute Chance hat, dass das wirklich passiert. Das erlebt man ja nicht alle Tage. Also man kann ja nicht sagen, heute gucke ich mir mal eine Staatsgründung an oder so was. Und da habe ich gesagt, das ist so ein historisches Ereignis unter Umständen. Also das und wenn es klappt, dann der Tag der Unabhängigkeit, wenn es ausgerufen wird, das will ich halt erleben. Also das ist eine seltene Chance. Und gerade dadurch, dass ich da schon relativ viele Leute kenne, dass meine Chance hoch ist, dass ich zu den wichtigen Partys komme oder mich da rumtummeln kann, wo die wichtigen Leute sind, dass ich auch was mitkriege, also dass ich nicht sage, ja, ich habe eine Flagge auf der Straße gesehen, sondern ich sagen kann, ja, ich habe mit ein paar Leuten gesprochen, die was zu sagen haben und kann irgendwie fundiert so diesen Prozess mitbekommen. Also so auch aus purer Neugier. Wie ist sowas? Also wie ist das, wenn man sagt, wir machen jetzt einen Start? Wahnsinnig spannend. Dann halt gesagt, klar, ein paar Tage vorher hin, ein paar Tage später weg, weil man kann auch immer schwer sagen, sind die Tage davor oder danach die spannenderen? Also wenn Bagdad einfach gesagt hätte, alles klar, dann lass uns mal in die Verhandlung treten nächste Woche, dann wären die Tage danach total langweilig gewesen und die davor mit dieser Stimmung und so das Spannende. Oder es könnte auch umgekehrt sein, dass alle sagen, ist doch klar, dass wir ja stimmen und davor passiert nichts und danach ist das Spannende. Und das war für mich auch nicht nicht klar abzusehen, wie sich das entwickelt. Und dann hatten im Prinzip vorher so ein Programm gemacht für die Woche. Was wollen wir an welchem Tag machen? In welchen Städten sein? Mit wem sprechen? Also wohl wissend, dass das wahrscheinlich eh nicht hinkommt, aber dass man immer so einen Fallbackplan hat. Was hatten wir noch? Weil es manchmal so ist, dass man dann ein, zwei Tage total viel zu tun hat und dann auf einmal nichts mehr. Und dann ist immer gut, wenn man weiß, was man noch so auf der To-Do hatte. Und eigentlich wollte ich nach Schingal. Das ist so kurz vor der syrischen Grenze. Das ist da, wo die Jesidenleben hat vor drei Jahren traurige Berühmtheit erlangt, als der IS dort den Ort überfallen hat und Zehntausende abgemetzelt und entführt hat. Und die Folge daraus waren dann die Waffenlieferung der Deutschen auch an die Peshmerga und eben die Luftangriffe. Es gibt halt den Ort Schingal oder Sinjar. Es gibt ganz knapp nördlich davon die Gebirgskette, die genauso heißt. Wo dann alle zusammen getrieben wurden und dann oben in der Hitze bei genau bei 50 Grad auf dem Berg, also so ein Minigebirge. Das ist so 70 Kilometer breit, aber nur ungefähr 700, 800 Meter hoch und vielleicht 4, 5 Kilometer lang. Also es ist jetzt nicht wie die Alpen oder so, sondern es ist wie ein langgezogener Berg sozusagen, um den man im Prinzip auch drum rumgehen kann. Und da war ich im Januar 2015, also kurz nach diesem 74. Genozid an den Jesiden, also auch überhaupt, dass die das so akkurat zählen, finde ich, ist schon bezeichnend. Und 74 ist auch mal eine Messlatte.
Auf jeden Fall.
Und das hat in dem Fall aber nicht geklappt. Sondern, als wir gerade sozusagen am finalen Checkpoint waren, zwischen dem sicheren kurdischen Gebiet und diesem, was noch nicht als ganz sicher gilt, hat uns der Nachrichtendienst, der für die Vorausaufklärung zuständig war, gesagt, also wir würden euch nicht empfehlen, weiter zu fahren. Da hinten sind gerade neun Leute erschossen worden von Milizen, die rübergefahren sind. Da knallts gerade. Und dann gab es halt, also das ist immer so, die sagen, wir würden es nicht empfehlen, aber wir sagen auch nicht nein, weil wir einem Journalisten sagen, du kannst hier nicht durch. Aber wenn ihr echt durch wollt, dann müssen wir euch einen Konvoi zusammenstellen, der euch schützt, weil anders geht es nicht. Und das hätte so vier, fünf Stunden gedauert wahrscheinlich, und sie hätten von woanders Leute von einer Spezialeinheit abziehen müssen, die uns schützen sollen. Sagt vielen Dank. Aber also quasi zum einmal gucken, um es runterzubrechen, wollen wir euch jetzt auch nicht irgendwie 25 gute Leute von einem Grenzübergangspunkt abziehen oder so.
Und auch potenziell noch weiter in Gefahr bringen.
Ja genau, also weil die sind die Ersten, die sterben, weil die dicht um einen rumstehen. Und wenn man dann sagt, ich wollte eigentlich nur gucken, wie die Lage ist, und jetzt ist leider dein Vater tot, haben wir auch gesagt, ey. Also vor zweieinhalb Jahren, als ich hingefahren bin, war es noch viel gefährlicher, aber da wussten wir das vorher. Und da war klar, wir kriegen ein gutes Sicherheits-Team. Und da habe ich gesagt, ich möchte schon gerne hin, um das halt selber gesehen zu haben, um die Leute selber gesprochen zu haben, um zu wissen, worum es geht. Weil ich bisher nur so ein paar Aufnahmen aus dem Fernsehen kannte. Und die mussten eh hin, also ein paar von den Leuten, um dort auch vor Ort Gespräche zu führen. Sollte ich gesagt haben, das ist anders. Aber jetzt zum noch mal hinfahren, sagt, nee, komm, lass es sein. Und dann war aber gut, wenn man sagt, was haben wir dann jetzt noch auf dem Programm? Weil jetzt fallen gerade zwei Tage weg. Und dann hat sich ein Freund gemeldet, der da ganz in der Nähe einer Stunde weiter ein Waisenhaus betreibt. Also der ist Kurde, der in Deutschland groß geworden ist und jetzt wieder da ist. Und also jesidischer Kurde, oder auch wieder so ein Punkt, also Religion, Volk, Nationalität und so. Also da gibt es Leute, die sagen, ich bin Kurde, also ich bin Moslem-Kurde, ich bin jesidischer Kurde, ich bin Jesid, damit bin ich kein Kurde. Also es geht zum Teil auch durcheinander. Es ist nicht immer so einfach als externer zu fassen, wie jetzt welche Zugehörigkeit wohin ist. Und der hat da erst durch Spenden finanziert und betreibt jetzt ein Waisenhaus für vor allem jesidische Kinder, deren Eltern durch ein IS abgemetzelt wurden. Das neben einem großen jesidischen Flüchtlingscamp, im Hauptcampgebiet und so in so was wie in einer Zeltstadt drumrum ungefähr 40-50.000 Leute jetzt wohnen. Und dann haben wir halt einen Tag da im Waisenhaus verbracht und halt geguckt, was treibt der da? Also wie ist das? Was haben die für ganz simple Probleme und was funktioniert und was funktioniert nicht? Und das war auch ganz interessant, also auch wie immer die Grundversorgung haben sie, aber die müssen immer von einem auf den nächsten Tag gucken, wie sie das Essen finanzieren. Und also ich dachte erst, das sei so quasi symbolisch gemeint oder so. Es war wirklich so, dass sie also dann für den nächsten Tag gerechnet haben, wie viel Geld haben sie noch da und wie viel müssen sie jetzt sammeln, damit sie die nächsten Mahlzeiten wieder finanzieren. Und das ist echt ein hartes Niveau an Arbeit, finde ich. Na, ihr fragt, was braucht ihr denn? Also für 50 Kinder am Waisenheim. Also wovon reden wir hier im Monat? Gesamte Betriebskosten. Da hat er gesagt, na so 10.000 Euro. Das ist doch nichts auf der Skala, die man so hier für öffentliche Ausgaben hat. Und damit kann der das ganze Waisenhaus betreiben, monatlang. Und das fand ich halt auch immer krass an, was für verhältnismäßig geringen Beträgen so was scheitert. Also so zum Vergleich so eine Rakete, die so ein Kampfjet abschießt aufs IS-Gebiet, damit können die ein halbes Jahr das Waisenhaus betreiben. Also so vom Größenverhältnis her. Und das ist schon immer wieder krass. Das finde ich dann auch immer interessant, so diesen politischen Überblick sozusagen zu haben oder halt Diplomaten, Präsidenten und zu treffen. Und dann aber auch so ins Kleine. Wie ist das, wenn jetzt vor Ort wirklich einer sagt, ich mache jetzt was, also ich komme hier her und ziehe was hoch. Was hat der dann so auf der anderen Skala von sozusagen Wichtigkeit oder Macht für Probleme da, also so dass man das ganze Bild halt mitkriegt, eben durch dieses kleine, einzelne Sachen sehen, die großen wichtigen Leute sehen und halt selber im Land rumfahren und einfach sehen, was passiert auf der Straße.
Und zurückkommen auf diese Perspektive der Unabhängigkeit. Da kann man ja sagen, gerade wenn man so deren Erfahrungen mit anderen Ländern, die Flüchtlinge aufgenommen haben, also so schlecht müsste ja Kurdistan eigentlich in der Region gar nicht dastehen. Weil sie sind irgendwie kein Aggressor, sind einfach, soweit ich das überblicken kann, keinerlei Aspiration in irgendeiner Form, sich große Gebiete anzueignen, außer halt das, was sie eben meinen, was schon ihres ist. Und das ist halt derzeit irgendwie des anderen. Und das macht es natürlich schwierig. Und von daher kann man verstehen, dass das Verhältnis zu Türkei, das Verhältnis zum Irak und auch zum Iran, da muss man noch was anderes mit einbeziehen.
Syrien, da ist es eh...
Da ist ja eh jetzt erst mal unklar, mit wem man da eine Beziehung haben kann. Aber natürlich in der Vergangenheit auch der syrische Staat, dass das eben ein schwieriges Verhältnis ist. Was mich bloß wundert so ein bisschen, oder wo ich nicht genau weiß, woran es liegt, ist, warum sind denn jetzt alle anderen Länder so, vielleicht nicht unbedingt dagegen, aber zumindest nicht erpicht darauf, dass Kurdistan jetzt auf diesem Weg weiter marschiert? Was treibt die Amerikaner in dem Fall und auch die Deutschen? Warum ist denn das so ein Dorn im Auge? Wenn man andererseits doch eigentlich sieht, dass Kurdistan nun wirklich in dieser ganzen Region, was ein Flammenherd nach dem anderen ist, eigentlich die entspannteste Truppe von allen ist.
Also zum einen muss man sagen, in Deutschland ist es eigentlich so, dass gerade von der CDU extreme Unterstützung die ganze Zeit kommt. Aber das ist ja kein Mainstream-Thema, kann man sagen.
Warum gerade von der CDU?
Das hat mich auch gewundert. Aber da gibt es seit ewig persönliche Beziehungen. Also seit mehr als 40 Jahren kennen ein paar wichtige CDU-Leute, wichtige Leute in Kurdistan, die haben sich irgendwie mal kennengelernt, wie auch immer. Und da denke ich einfach, ein persönlicher Draht ist natürlich sehr wichtig. Wenn man das gegenüber kennt, dann will man, dass es dem gut geht. Aber gerade die CDU ist da ein Riesenunterstützer ganz lange gewesen. Was ich auch interessant fand, was ich so nie hier wahrgenommen habe und auch sozusagen von der politischen Linie her nicht so richtig verstehen konnte. Aber da kamen sehr viele in die richtige Richtung. Ich hatte ja vor einer Weile auch mit Steinmeier darüber sprechen können, als er noch Außenminister war. Eine große Errungenschaft bei ihm, er hat ein Foto von mir im Büro hängen, wo ich nämlich in Schingal stehe mit einem Je suis Charlie-Schild, kurz nachdem das war und im Hintergrund noch IS-Flaggen sind und die Stadt umkämpft ist. Das war aber auch der Einstieg, Kontakt zu ihm zu bekommen. Ich habe gesagt, das bin ich, der Typ neben mir ist Peschmerga mit dem G36 und ich muss versprechen dir Danke zu sagen. Und dann hat man einen guten Gesprächseinstieg. Im Prinzip das Gleiche. Er sagt, auf der Rückseite ist der Name von dem, der spricht Deutsch und seine Handynummer. Wenn du jemals was wissen willst, ruf ihn an. Kannst du direkt fragen, wie die Lage in Schingal ist. Ich glaube, das ist auch so ein Punkt. Die Distanz zwischen jemandem wie Steinmeier und den Leuten vor Ort dürfte ja eine riesige sein im Normalfall. Wenn er auf einmal ein Foto hat mit, und man sagt, das ist Yassir, und hier ist seine Handynummer. Ruf an, wenn du was wissen willst. Dann ist auf einmal eine ganz andere... Ich denke, immer wenn er in den nächsten Tagen das Thema hatte, hat er doch irgendwie an das Foto gedacht. Ich denke, das... Wollte er doch angerufen? Darüber schweigen sich beide Seiten aus. Ich dachte überhaupt, dieser Punkt, dass man auf einmal so was Direktes hat, ich denke schon, dass das unwillentlich im Kopf hängen bleibt. Einfach, weil es auf einmal anders ist. Und da war es auch so, dass Steinmeier sich sehr dafür ausgesprochen hat, dass da Hilfen rüberkommen und eben das Team drumrum und so, das hängt ja dann nicht an einer Person auch. Aber wo ich dann dachte, wenn sozusagen SPD-Steinmeier und CDU-Merkel und CDU von der Leyen da an einem Strang ziehen, dann ist das schon eine ganze Menge. Also und alle drei habe ich selber gesprochen und alle drei waren der Meinung, dass es eine gute Sache ist, also dass man die Richtigen unterstützt so rum, dass man, also einfach das sind die, denen man jetzt helfen muss, damit der IS nicht groß wird. Also egal aus welchen Interessen dahinter, aber erst mal auf der richtigen Seite.
Aber nicht unbedingt so, das ist jetzt das Land, dem man jetzt auch mal dabei unterstützen muss, Unabhängigkeit zu haben.
Nee, ich glaube nicht Unabhängigkeit, sondern das mal sagt, da muss man helfen, dass die Flüchtlinge versorgt werden. Da muss man helfen, dass der IS plattgekloppt wird. Und dazu gehören zwangsläufig Waffen, Nachrichtendienst, Aufklärung. Also all den Kram, den man eigentlich ungerne exportieren will, so als normaler Mensch, aber wo man sagt, hey, aber in dem Moment, was willst du sonst machen? Das sind genau die Dinge, die du gerade da brauchst. Dementsprechend war das immer ziemlich gut von dem Kontakt her. Die USA, bei denen ist die Argumentation total simpel, wenn Kurdistan sich unabhängig macht, dann könnte es nach außen so wirken, als sei der Irak-Krieg nicht erfolgreich gewesen, weil der Irak ja zerbricht. Während es bisher ja eine Erfolgsgeschichte ist. Also hab ich dann, also klar, man erkennt die Argumentationsschiene, es ist nur für uns nicht so ganz nachvollziehbar. Und das sind so die Hauptgründe. Und ich glaube, bei der Zentralregierung in Bagdad ist ganz simpel, sie verlieren die einzige sichere Region im Land, wo man auch sagen muss, verdächtig viele Minister und Parlamentsmitglieder aus dem Irak, also von der Zentralregierung, wohnen ja auch in Kurdistan und fliegen dann nur für die Sitzung rüber. Das hängen die nur nicht so gerne an die große Glocke.
Die aber eigentlich Irakis sind.
Ja, und die für den Irak im Parlament sitzen, aber die wollen auch nicht in Bagdad wohnen. Das ist da nämlich so sehr interessant dran. Und auch viele Botschaften.
Das heißt, spätestens daran kann man ablesen, wenn es eine stabile Region gibt im Irak, dann ist es Kurdistan.
Auch wenn man sich anguckt, da wo man Informationen kriegt. Also in Erbil gibt es ganz viele Konsulate von allen möglichen Ländern, die so auch Botschaftsgröße haben. Und wie oft die gesamten Botschaftsteams aus Bagdad in den letzten Jahren dringende Meetings in Erbil hatten, wo sie dann mal drei Wochen oder so bleiben mussten, wenn es in Bagdad gerade nicht gut aussah. Denk umgekehrt, habe ich nie gehört, dass alle aus Erbil nach Bagdad geflogen sind, zwei, drei Wochen. Also wo man einfach die Tendenz erkennt. Da muss man bedenken, dass jede Menge Öl in der Gegend und da sind große Getreidefelder und so weiter, also wirklich massiv, dass man da viel Essen und so anbauen kann. Das heißt, das ist wirtschaftlich und politisch eine interessante Gegend und die will man halt nicht verlieren. Also reiner Eigennutz halt einfach nur, warum man es halten will.
Obwohl es so richtig gehören tut es Ihnen mittlerweile auch nur sehr begrenzt, oder?
Das Öl wird seit mehr als zwei Jahren unabhängig vom Irak exportiert, gegen den Willen der Zentralregierung, was auch sehr spannend ist, wo man merkt, die haben de facto überhaupt keine Macht mehr. Da gab es vor zwei Jahren die sehr bizarre Szene, da sind Öltanker von BP an die Tanks in Cheyhan in der Türkei gefahren, am Ölhafen, wo das ganze irakische und also kurdisch-irakische Öl in die Silos gepumpt wird, um dann abgeholt zu werden. Und BP kam an und hat gesagt so, macht uns den Tanker voll und der Hafmeister hat gesagt, die Tanks sind leer. Wir haben das aber gekauft vom Irak und wir möchten es gerne abholen. Er hat gesagt, ja, aber da war gestern ein Schiff da und die Kurden haben es vorher verkauft, an jemand anderen. Und wozu hieß das? Das geht ja gar nicht. Also vor allem nicht nach unseren Maßstäben von Handel und Organisation und so. Und dann hieß es, ja, es ist aber weg. Also was macht ihr jetzt? Das war das Öl aus Kurdistan, was formal von der Zentralregierung gehandelt wird und die Kurden haben einfach an eine andere Gesellschaft das verkauft und gesagt, dockt an dem Silo an und holt es euch ab. Und das haben die seitdem regelmäßig gemacht. Das Problem war nur, dass der Irak dann halt angefangen hat, rechtlich dagegen vorzugehen und wollten den Öltanker beschlagnahmen lassen. Der dümpelte da aber in internationalen Gewässern rum. Sollte eigentlich in Texas andocken, dann haben sie in Texas bei so einem hohen Gericht sich die Beschlagnahme des Schiffs erwürgt, dämlicherweise als das noch in internationalen Gewässern war. Deswegen, die halt einfach woanders hingefahren sind. Und dann tauchte das Öl in Israel auf. Und dann haben die Israelis gesagt, wir haben es gekauft. Hände hoch, wer was dagegen hat.
Israel gehört ja auch so ein bisschen zu den Fans von Kurdistan.
Also auch bei der Aktion hat man es gemerkt, Israel weiß, wie sie in der UN auf den Putz hauen können. Und die haben gesagt, lass uns darüber reden. Wer hat ein Problem mit? Niemand. Danke. Dann ist das Thema wohl durch. Man hätte es ja auch dezenter machen können. Aber Israel ganz klar unterstützt diese Unabhängigkeitsbestrebungen auch.
Aus derselben Sichtweise heraus. Das sind ja quasi jedes halbwegs demokratisch funktionierende Land, was so Stabilität verspricht, in dieser Region einfach nur Gieb und Recht sein kann.
Ja und gemeinsame Feinde sozusagen. Also während die Kurden früher Saddam als Feind hatten und die israelische Regierung ja die die palästinensische Regierung doch durchaus als Feind sieht, zumindest in Teilen, ist es so, dass die Saddam-Regierung und viele palästinensische Organisationen befreundet waren. Also so über die Schiene. Und zum anderen haben beide, also Israel und Kurdistan, Syrien als Nachbarn dazwischen, mit denen sie beide nicht klarkommen. Und ich glaube, das ist natürlich für Israel hoch interessant, wenn sie sozusagen die Spange schließen und auf der anderen Seite von Syrien Militär stationieren können. Da sind jetzt auch zwölf Kampfjets, soweit ich weiß, von der israelischen Luftwaffe in Erbil derzeit stationiert. Insgesamt aber mehr als zehn Länder, die ihre Kampfjets da stehen haben. Also es heißt immer die US-Sachen oder so, die S-Kampfjets. Aber korrekt sind es die alliierten US-geführten Luftstreitkräfte und da waren auch Niederländer bei Belgien, Dänemark. Alle möglichen haben da mal ihre Kampfjets permanent oder vorübergehend gehabt. Dänemark fliegt seine alle paar Monate zurück zum Servicen und dann wieder hin. Das ist so unterschiedlich. Kanada, Italien hat ein paar Kampfhubschrauber da stehen. Es war ein bisschen schwierig. Die sind vor ein paar Tagen über uns geflogen. Ich habe die immer fotografiert und die gängigen US-Kampfhubschrauber an Flugzeugen erkenne ich noch. Dann hörte es aber auf, da ist zu viel Wild wuchs. Dann ist es immer super. Man schmeißt Dinge auf Twitter und in fünf Minuten hat man solide Ergebnisse. Da hat einer gesagt, das passt nicht. Das ist 100% der Mangusta, den die Türken benutzen. Aber der kann da ja nicht rumfliegen. Aber Fotos verglichen, ganz exakt. Und nicht der, der so ähnlich aussieht und nicht der und so schön mit Bildern markiert. Für den wären die Räder zu weit vorne, der hat die Kanone anders. Es muss der sein. Und dann hat er noch mal gesucht und sagte, hey Moment, die Italiener benutzen den aber auch. Die sind da und die sichern den Mossel-Damm derzeit. Aber die haben nicht viele davon. Aber dann ergibt das wieder Sinn.
Mossel-Damm ist dieser riesige Staudamm im Irak, der ein Riesenproblem ist, weil er einfach jetzt während des Krieges schlecht gewartet wurde und der ganze Boden beschaffen hat, eigentlich eh nicht so richtig gewesen ist. Und wenn ihnen das Ding irgendwie kaputt geht, dann ist Bagdad fünf Meter unter Wasser. Dann ist richtig Schicht im Schacht.
Aber die autonome Region Kurdistan hätte exakt null Schaden. Das ist das Wichtige daran. Mossel und Bagdad werden überflutet und der Rest nicht. Deswegen, also, das haben italienische Ingenieure, aber schon vor fast einem Jahr, repariert. Die haben gesagt, die Sicherheit ist jetzt gewährleistet. Also da, der kann nicht mehr brechen, aber er produziert viel zu wenig Strom. Da müssten neue Turbinen rein. Das Problem ist nur, dass man die gerade da nicht rüberbekommt. Das heißt, der Mossel-Damm wurde lange vom italienischen, von der italienischen Armee gesichert und jetzt soll er der Bundeswehr übergeben werden. Und die haben gesagt, jetzt haben sie aber alles, was sozusagen kaputt war, gefixt. Und jetzt geht es halt nur noch um Servicen, was eine ganze Menge einfacher ist. Wenn man halt die Serviceintervalle einhält für die Erosion und was die da haben, dann ist das alles kein Hexenwerk. Allerdings erzeugt der Mossel-Damm massiv Energie, also dafür sei er aufgestaut für die ganze Region und auch für den Irak und könnte noch viel mehr erzeugen, wenn sie die modernen Turbinen reinkriegen würden. Was aber da wichtig ist, der ist unter kurdischer Kontrolle. Das heißt, lässt man kein Wasser durch, hat der Irak keinen Strom, lässt man alles Wasser durch, ist Bagdad 5 Meter unter Wasser. Und bisher wurde diese Karte nicht gespielt oder das nicht mal angesprochen, aber allen ist klar, mit dem Mossel-Damm hat man im Prinzip den Irak bei den Eiern, wenn man das wirklich mal durchzieht und zum Beispiel den Strom abdreht. Und sowohl Wasser als auch Strom ist der Irak unglaublich abhängig von diesem Mossel-Damm. Und da ist es so, die Leute, mit denen ich bisher gesprochen hatte, die haben gesagt, sie wollen diese Karte nicht spielen, weil das ja quasi null gegen die Regierung und 99 Prozent gegen das Volk geht, weil der Premierminister geht es Wasser nicht aus, wenn der Mossel-Damm ding ist. Dem geht auch der Strom nicht aus, sondern dann leidet nur wieder das Volk. Also sie haben gesagt, eigentlich sollte man schon immer im Kopf haben, was sie da für ein Faustfand halten. Das ist aber den anderen Ländern klar. Also gerade USA und Russland, die ja beide da um Einfluss buhlen. Und die versuchen da ja auch deswegen massiv zu vermitteln und zu sagen, Leute, wenn, also sagen wir mal, es läuft schief. Sagen wir mal, irgendwas läuft da total schlimm und jemand sprengt einfach den Mossel-Damm oder sowas. Dann wäre das Referendum in Bagdad aber eher ein Problem gewesen. Weil dann, dann gibt es euch einfach nicht mehr. Und dementsprechend versuchen die da gerade ganz massiv zu vermitteln. Und das finde ich auch lustig, wenn Russen und Amis zusammen mit dem gleichen Ziel hin vermitteln. Das hat man ja jetzt auch eher selten historisch. Also da gab es ein paar Vorfälle, wo die ja so zusammengearbeitet haben, aber auch man lernt da eine Menge über Politik einfach, wenn man da ist, so im Fokus von Supermächten, von Wirtschaftsinteressen, von Flüchtlingsinteressen und allem, also wo das so ein Brennpunkt ist. Und wer sich da alles die Klinke in die Hand gibt und irgendwie versucht, Einfluss zu gewinnen auf der einen Seite, aber zum anderen auch bei sowas, wo die sagen, da geht es jetzt gerade nicht um Einfluss, sondern um Schadensbegrenzung.
Wie schätzt du denn das ein? Ich meine, es ist jetzt immer so ein bisschen schwierig, über die Zukunft zu spekulieren, aber das Referendum ist jetzt durch. Es gibt auch ein vorläufiges Ergebnis. Ich glaube, so was wie 92 Prozent waren jetzt dafür sicherlich auch nicht überraschend, dass das so ausgegangen ist. Und jetzt wollten sie ja behandeln. Jetzt sehen wir schon, es gibt da diverse Schwierigkeiten für den Irak, eine starke Position einzunehmen. Schönen Damm haben sie hier irgendwie.
Wäre ja schade, wenn dem was passiert.
Denkst du, es wird in absehbarer Zeit zu einem erfolgreichen Verhandlungsergebnis kommen können?
Ich finde es im Moment unglaublich schwierig, das voraus zu sagen. Also die erste Reaktion von der Zentralregierung im Irak war ja, Luftraum wird gesperrt. Also und ist seit Freitag für alle zivilen Maschinen über Kurdistan der Luftraum gesperrt. Seit gestern Abend dürfen Ausländer immerhin über Baghdad ausreisen. Aber der Irak hat ja angekündigt, alle Grenzen dicht zu machen. Hat ja auch letzte Woche schon seine Armee in die Türkei geflogen, um dort dann Grenzübergänge besetzen zu können. Also die machen ja gerade mit der irakischen Armee und der iranischen Armee zusammen Militärübungen an der Grenze.
Was der Irak und Iran machen?
Ja, auf einmal, wenn es sein muss, sind es wieder dicke Kumpels.
Also immerhin zwei Länder, die irgendwie so Gifthaskriege etc. extrem zerstörerische Kriege in den 1780ern geführt haben. Und also nicht lange her. Okay, aber wenn es gemeinsame Feinde gibt.
Eben, dann super. Und was ich da so die bizarrste Meldung war, dass der Ayatollah sich zu Wort gemeldet hat und gesagt hat, Leute, jetzt bleibt mal ruhig und setzt euch da an den Verhandlungstisch.
Wo ich auch dachte...
Aus Iran.
Ja, wo ich dachte, von dem sowas ist irgendwie jetzt auch nicht so ganz das, was ich erwartet hatte.
Das ging, glaube ich, gestern oder vorgestern rum. Also...
Ja, ist der Vogel noch mal gleich?
Ayatollah, findest du ja damit.
Du kennst ja nur einen, irgendwie den einen.
Wer sind gerade Papst? Und deswegen... Also mir scheint im Moment, das ist ein extremes... Genau, das ist ein extremes Säbelrasseln von allen Seiten. Ich glaube nicht, dass richtig was passiert. Aber der Irak hat gerade das Problem, also der Premierminister, der muss den harten Mann markieren und der muss seine Wählerschaft befriedigen. Und mir scheint so das, was ich von ihm mitkriege, der hat so ein Riesen-Ego-Problem auch einfach. Also der muss der Mächtige im Land sein und der kann niemandem die Hand reichen, weil er ist der Chef im Ring. Und ja, genau, also, na ja. Und dementsprechend muss er jetzt draufkloppen, weiß aber de facto, dass er nichts machen kann. Auch die Luftraum-Sperrung. Ich glaube immer noch nicht, dass sie die ernsthaft durchführen könnten. Also die wird jetzt akzeptiert von allen, sozusagen freiwillig. Man hält sich dran.
Wir reden vom Ministerpräsidenten. Genau, al-Abadi.
Genau, also al-Abadi. Und als ich halt jetzt noch letzte Woche in Erbil war, sind halt jeden Abend über uns die Kampfhubschrauber geflogen, Truppentransporter, Kampfjets, alles Mögliche. Also die Amis haben massiv Präsenz auch in der Luft gezeigt und haben halt Systemtests gemacht. Also wir standen eine Stunde da und haben zugeguckt, wie ein Kampfhubschrauber nach dem anderen hochgeflogen ist, eine Runde gedreht hat, gelandet. Dann der nächste hoch, eine Runde gedreht, gelandet. Also einmal gucken, ob noch alles läuft. Dann Außentanks dran, eine Runde drehen, Außentanks ab, Last runter, eine Runde drehen und so weiter. Also wirklich einmal gucken, geht jeder Haken, geht jede Halterung. Das machen die selten. Und wir reden da nicht so von Paarhubschraubern, sondern von vielen Dutzend und auch von Dutzenden Kampfjets, die da stehen mit der ganzen Versorgung. Also die haben da bestimmt 10-, 20-mal so viel Luftwaffe stehen, wie der Irak überhaupt hätte. Das heißt, in Kurdistan, aber nicht eigene, sondern nur Fremde. Genau.
Nur ausschließlich Fremde.
Ja, sie haben keine eigene. Aber trotzdem die schiere Menge zeigt, wer da die Macht hat. Und man muss bedenken, dass die, also das obskurste Flugzeug der irakischen Luftwaffe, finde ich immer noch, die Cessna 208. Das ist so ein Ding, was hier so ein Sportpilot hat, der mit der Familie rumfliegt. Und das haben sie dann umgebaut zum Kampfflugzeug. Aber das ist so ein bizarres Zwischenlösungsding. Prop Maschine, also so ein Sechs- oder Acht-Sitzer oder vielleicht zehn, aber mehr hat das Ding halt nicht. Und dann haben die auch moderne Kampfjets, also F-16C, aber die sind halt von den Amis geliefert in der Exportversion. Und dann denke ich mir mal, wenn man als Ami mit der Heimversion gegen die Exportversion kämpfen müsste, habe ich so eine Idee, wer gewinnt. Und gerade weil die da auch alles moderne angekarrt haben, was sie so haben. Das heißt also de facto, glaube ich nicht, dass sie es könnten. Und da wüssten sie ja auch. Also sagt man, die zivilen Airlines werden da nicht reinfliegen, weil die gehen das Risiko nicht ein. Aber richtig durchführen könnte man da nichts. Jetzt ist aber das Problem, wie kommt man so aus diesem Part raus? Also wenn man einmal richtig auf den Tisch gehauen hat, also so stellen wir es vor wie so zu Hause, wenn sich zwei Leute so richtig ankeifen, wo fängt man jetzt an zu sagen, okay, lass uns doch mal unterhalten, gerade wenn die ganze Welt mit den Kameras drauf guckt. Und das ist, glaube ich, das Schwierige, wenn man einmal so auf den Tisch gekloppt hat, da ohne Gesichtsverlust wieder den Rückzug zu machen. Und Abadi hat auch starke Forderungen gestellt, also er redet kein Wort, bevor das Referendum nicht storniert wird. Also vorher wird kein Wort gesprochen. Nur ich denke, mit sowas verbaut man sich natürlich eine Menge, weil sobald er sich an den Tisch setzt, verliert er quasi sein Gesicht vor seinen Wählern. Das ist aber selbst schuld. Sein Vize hat aber schon gesagt, ich komme gerne an den Verhandlungstisch und lasse uns mal, lasse uns einfach klären, was Sache ist. Also nicht, dass ich das akzeptiere oder irgendwas, sondern also sozusagen ergebnishoffend, genau, lasst uns erstmal an den Tisch setzen und gucken. Und wo ich denke, das ist ja die Grundlage. Und so ein bisschen historisch zurück, warum es das Referendum gibt oder die letzten Jahre. Also natürlich war da irgendwo immer der Wunsch. Aber man könnte auch sagen, zum Beispiel Bayern wollte auch immer wieder unabhängig werden. Aber denen geht es gut genug, dass sie jetzt nicht einen akuten Handlungsdrang hätten, das jetzt durchzuführen. Weil warum? Also und auch hier in Europa. Wir haben alle unabhängige Staaten. Wir machen die Grenzen immer weiter auf. Wir haben immer mehr Recht auf EU-Ebene, weil es uns gut geht. Also wir müssen uns nicht mehr vor dem Erbfeind schützen oder irgendwie sowas. Da ist es eben so, wenn man vor 25 Jahren noch von der Zentralregierung ausgerottet werden sollte und dann die Regierung, die nach Saddam kam, also erstmal Likki, der hätte so die Chance gehabt, das Volk zu ein und zu sagen, Leute, jetzt lass uns mal alle an einem Strang ziehen und wir holen die Kurden ins Boot, die Sunniten, die Shiiten und dann lass uns mal gucken. Da muss man sagen, haben die Kurden, also auch die Regionalregierung, wie ich meine, eine Wahnsinnsleistung gebracht. Die haben also schon als Saddam geschlagen war, total unterbunden, dass es Racheakte gab. Also es gab zwei Tage lang Aufstände, wo ich glaube 300 bis 400 irakische Soldaten umgebracht wurden. Also jetzt nicht im Kampf auf dem Feld, sondern in eroberten, also in bereits eroberten Garnisonen dann noch erschossen wurden oder auch einzelne am Auto hinterher geschliffen wurden. Also all die Scheiße, die nicht passieren darf. Ja, das war ein oder zwei Tage und dann haben sie es im Griff gehabt und gesagt Leute, das machen wir nicht. Das ist genau der Unterschied zwischen denen und uns. Und dann haben auch die Saddam Soldaten eine freie Passage in Irak zurückbekommen, mit Bussen organisiert und allem. Und die haben gesagt, und wir beteiligen uns einem ganzen Schrott nicht, also nicht Schwamm drüber. Wir müssen daran erinnern. Aber wir fangen nicht an, die zu erschießen, die auf uns geschossen haben, wenn der Krieg vorbei ist. Und da denke ich, das ist so die größte Handreichung, die man machen kann. Also das ist unglaublich zu sagen, nee, wir schießen jetzt nicht mehr zurück. Die Sache ist gelaufen. Maliki hat allerdings dann das Volk einfach in die andere Richtung gespalten. Also hat gesagt, okay, jetzt sind nicht mehr die Sunniten die Guten, sondern die Schiiten und wir packen die anderen raus. Und die Kurden sind sowieso doof und hat im Prinzip die gleiche Schiene mit leicht vertauschten Rollen, also bei diesen drei Hauptgruppen dort, weiter gespielt, was natürlich der Sache nicht zuträglich war.
Vor allem dann auch dazu beigetragen hat, dass die Sunniten dann sich sozusagen so sehr verabschiedet haben, dass sie dann auch massenhaft zum IS gelaufen sind. Weil der IS ist ja jetzt nicht nur so gegründet worden von irgendwelchen religiös verbremdenden Vollhorsten, das auch, aber vor allem ist das Ganze befeuert worden durch viele abtrünnige, auch Entscheider des alten Armieses.
Und auch zum Beispiel Saddam Generäle und so weiter. Also man muss ja bedenken, die irakische Armee ist ja einfach aufgelöst worden. Also ich finde, das ist auch immer schwierig. Man will so eine Armee nicht sozusagen reformieren und die alten Leute drin lassen. Also so ähnlich wie als Nazi Deutschland aufgelöst wurde und ganz viele trotzdem noch in der Verwaltung saßen, weil man gesagt hat, man braucht die Leute. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man so einen harten Schnitt macht, dann hat man die Leute nicht mehr da. Und so ein Saddam General, der 20 Jahre lang der King im Land war und dem sagt man auf einmal so, du bist jetzt der Arsch vorm Dienst und du bist raus. Natürlich sitzt der gefrustet rum. Und wenn der dann so irgendwie mitkriegt, hey, da gibt es so eine Gruppe, die wollen hier mal wieder irgendwie an die Macht oder die wollen was machen, dann sagt der, hey, da bin ich doch dabei. Ich kenne das Land. Ich bringe noch ein paar gute Jungs mit.
Ich habe ein riesiges Netzwerk. Ich weiß, was gelaufen ist. Ich weiß, wen man wie noch erpressen kann.
Und ich weiß genau, wie die vorgehen. Also weil das ändert sich ja nicht viel. Und da denke ich genau, all dieses, also das hat das alles begünstigt. So da haben sich dann die falschen Leute zusammengefunden. Und dann haben alle gesagt, okay, also die Kurden haben gesagt, gut, Maliki schießt nicht auf uns. Das ist der einzige Vorteil. Aber das wird halt auch nichts. Also so, da geht die Distanzierung dann schon weiter. Und Abadi jetzt macht also genau das Gleiche wieder. Also so politisch die Leute teilen und durch seine Agitation und so weiter. Und man sagt, Leute, ihr hattet die Chance, so zehn Jahre lang ungefähr das zusammenzuführen. Und voll dagegen gehauen, die ganze Zeit. Also nicht einmal gesagt, so, jetzt irgendwie bringen wir das alles an einen Tisch. Weil dann bin ich mir auch sicher, hätte die Regionalregierung also klar hart verhandelt und gesagt, Leute, wir wollen hier richtig Vorteile rausschlagen, aber wir bleiben, weil es ja eine komfortable Situation ist. Also wenn man ein stabiles System hat, wenn man profitiert, warum nicht? Aber aus all dem kam dann halt das Referendum. Und wenn man dann jetzt wieder diese Gegenwehr von der Zentralregierung kriegt, also die kurdische Regionalregierung fällt sich da immer noch locker und sagt, lass uns drüber reden, lass uns, ne? Also fang jetzt nicht an, das Gleiche im Gegenzug so zu argumentieren oder so draufzuhauen. Aber klar, da sind total verhärtete Fronten. Und jetzt ist das also eine ziemliche Sackgasse derzeit, finde ich, so weil die Zentralregierung irgendwie aus ihrer Situation raus muss. Einen Krieg führen können sie de facto gar nicht. Also die haben überhaupt nicht die militärische Macht, Kurdistan einzunehmen oder irgendwas. Und es wäre ein Verfassungsbruch, weil ihre Armee nicht nach Kurdistan gehen darf. Also was man auch noch bedenken muss. Und da sitzen halt die ganzen Amis rum mit insgesamt 5000 Marines derzeit. Da sitzt kanadische Armee, da sitzen alle möglichen europäischen Armeen und so weiter. Also das wird nicht passieren. Und wenn sie Nachschub brauchen für ihre Kampfjets, müssen sie die in den USA bestellen.
Also was halt auch so ein kleines Problem ist, wenn die sagen, ne, wir liefern gerade nicht.
Aber trotzdem ist ja Amerika noch gegen diese.
Genau. Aber wollen halt auch keinen Krieg. Also die müssen jetzt so ganz hübsch da irgendwie ausbalancieren. Und die sind auch die, die am meisten dazwischenhängen und das jetzt befrieden wollen, um eben dieser Situation zu umgehen. Und die wollen gerne einen zusammenhängenden Irak, aber wollen natürlich, dass die Kurden auch also wirklich drin bleiben wollen, dass man eine Lösung findet, dass sie das nicht wieder jahrelang an der Backe haben. Also auch schlichtweg, das kostet alles Geld. Und wenn man statt Geld für die Armee dort zu zahlen Kohle verdient mit Erdöl, dann ist das wirtschaftlich schlichtweg interessanter für die USA. Und eine unstabile Region ist immer schlecht zum Ölexportieren. Und auch der Punkt, wenn eine von den großen Pipelines jetzt mal hoch fliegt. Also wenn eine Pipeline vom Irak, also in die Türkei, wenn die gesprengt wird, irgendwo im kurdischen Bereich, wo man dann vielleicht noch sehr mäßig anfängt, die zu flicken oder so, dann ist das auch ein riesen wirtschaftliches Problem.
Das heißt, die irakischen Ölpipelines gehen alle durch Kurdistan?
Die eine, ja. Also es gibt nur eine. Und die, also deswegen, das sind auch so Dinge. Und die gehen in der Türkei zum Teil auch durch die PKK-kontrollierten Gebiete. Also was auch, wenn jetzt, also die PKK und die Peschmerga und so, die mögen sich alle nicht so. Also es ist ein bisschen kompliziert. Solange nichts zu tun ist, mögen sie sich nicht, bis sie einen gemeinsamen Feind haben. Dann mögen die sich nicht wirklich, aber dann ziehen sie irgendwie mehr oder minder an einem Strang. Aber wenn jetzt der Irak nach Kurdistan einmarschieren würde zum Beispiel, dann könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, dass die PKK sagt, na wir helfen mal unseren Kumpel, und sprengen die irakische Pipeline oder sowas. Also das würde ich jetzt nicht ausschließen. Ja genau. Da sind wir wieder bei dem Thema, wie sowas alles zusammenhängt. Das wird dann richtig kompliziert. Deswegen denke ich, dass eigentlich allen klar ist, sie müssen aus der Nummer friedlich raus. Das ist auch Abadi klar. Nur ist der wie so der besoffene Agrovater in der Familie, der rumgreift gerade und sagen muss, ich bin hier der Chef und alle hören auf mich, und der Rest hat keinen Bock drauf und jetzt muss aus der Nummer raus. Deswegen finde ich sehr spannend. Also ich denke, das ist der Hauptpunkt, wie kommt Abadi raus, ohne das Gesicht zu verlieren. Das ist glaube ich der Knackpunkt an der Nummer. Aber die kurdische Regionalregierung wird vom Referendum jetzt auch nicht mehr zurücktreten. Da bin ich mir auch total sicher. Also das ist jetzt genau der Punkt, dass man da so zwei Gegenpunkte hat, die sich nicht mehr vereinen lassen durch die ganze Entwicklung der letzten Jahrzehnte. Und jetzt kommt die ganze Welt und sagt, ihr könnt euch aber nicht unabhängig machen und sagen, wo wart ihr denn als die Giftglasangriffe waren und wo wart ihr, als wir den IS alleine bekämpfen mussten, weil die irakische Armee uns keine Munition geschickt hat und so weiter. Da hat keiner was gesagt. Aber jetzt, wo wir unabhängig sein wollen, da sagt ihr, das geht nicht. Und das kann ich auch verstehen, dass man da sagt, hey, die Welt hat uns so auf den Stich gelassen, da hören wir jetzt nicht drauf, wenn es um unseren Vorteil geht. Und deswegen finde ich, ist es so extrem offen, dass man da nicht mal eine Tendenz klar sagen kann. Also das wird jetzt einfach interessant.
Deine Zeit, ich meine, wir haben jetzt so ein bisschen den Anfang, so ein bisschen das Ende beleuchtet. Was mich ja nochmal interessieren würde, ist so dieses, du bist da so ein bisschen hingekommen aus dem Interesse, bist dadurch eigentlich auch so ein bisschen erst so in diese Journalistenrolle nochmal ein bisschen aktiver reingekommen. Was hat dich denn überhaupt motiviert, an diesem Thema so dran zu bleiben? Also was und vor allem, was hat dich dann dazu gebracht, dich auch so richtig an die an die Fronten zu stellen?
Also zum einen war es so, was du gesagt hast, wenn man vor Ort ist, sieht es oft so anders aus, als was man hier in den Medien mitbekommt. Was ich hier spannend fand, wie hier so im Mittelpunkt stand, die Soniten und die Shiiten und die kloppen sich da und vor Ort habe ich die Wörter nicht mal gehört, weil es den Leuten völlig egal ist. Also das ist nicht der Punkt. Da geht es darum, wenn jemand meine Familie abknallt, dann habe ich was gegen ihn. Aber die fragen nicht erstmal, sag mal, bist du Sonit oder Shiit, wenn du da gerade schießt, ne? Und dann war es auch so, dass ich zum Teil hanebüchende Sachen hier irgendwo gelesen habe und dachte schon nach meinem geringen Verständnis, von da kann das überhaupt nicht sein. Oder es waren Orte angegeben, das passte geografisch überhaupt nicht, dass jemand sagt, hier war gerade eine Schlacht irgendwie oder zum Beispiel vor einer Weile der IS steht jetzt kurz vor Erbil. Wie gesagt habt, die waren doch vorgestern noch 100 Kilometer weg, haben jetzt gerade 80 Kilometer gut gemacht und keiner von meinen Freunden, der dazwischen wohnt, hat es mitgekriegt oder wie, weil ich gerade noch mit denen gechattet habe. Oder auch der Raketenangriff auf Erbil, den ich glaube NTV berichtet hatte und haben dann jemanden in Erbil angerufen, der eine Minute späterhin sagt, ne, hier ist überhaupt nichts los. Und im Nachrichtenüberblick kommt wieder, dass es angegriffen wird, weil sie das offensichtlich nicht ordentlich zusammengeschnitten hatten oder so. Und so Sachen hatte ich oft. Na, ich gesagt, okay, jetzt will ich mal selber wissen, also zwei Punkte. Zum einen, wo ist eigentlich genau die Front? Wenn es da so verschiedene Angaben gibt. Warum ist das so kompliziert? Wenn der Journalist doch da steht, dann muss der doch nur auf seinen Google Maps gucken und sieht, wo er steht. Und so schwer ist das nicht. Und zum anderen, wenn der IS im Prinzip ein Haufen Idioten sind, also oben ein paar Leute, die planen können, aber unten, das sind ja keine Spezialeinheiten, das sind Trottel, die in Kalaschnikow in Erntan waren. Warum kriegt man die nicht einfach weggekämpft? Also was ist denn bitte das Problem daran? Und deswegen wollte ich dann wirklich an die Front gehen, um das genau einfach mal zu sehen, damit ich selber verstehe, also was ist da los? Und eine der wichtigen Erkenntnisse dann vor Ort war nämlich, warum wissen die Journalisten vor Ort so schlecht, wo die Front ist? Weil die meisten, die darüber berichten, überhaupt nicht da sind. Also nicht mal in dem Land. Dann gemerkt, als ich hier dann Leute angemailt habe, zum Teil gesagt habe, hey, ich habe deinen Artikel gelesen, vielen Dank, alles toll. Aber als ich da war, hatte ich das anders wahrgenommen. Also irgendwie, wir waren doch in einer ähnlichen Gegend. Also wie kann das sein, dass unsere Wahrnehmung so anders ist oder einfach so Interesse dran? Und die Reaktionen waren zum Teil bezeichnend. Also ich habe zum Beispiel jemand von, oder ich habe mal SpiegelTV angemailt. Die haben gesagt, hey, wir geben das mal weiter an den, der es wirklich gemacht hat. Und der hat gesagt, hey, ja, ich war da und da und bin dann da lang gefahren und da und habe mit dem und dem gesprochen. Und vielleicht warst du in der Ecke und die sehen das ein bisschen anders. So im Nachbardorf sozusagen. Okay, interessant. Erkenntnis gewinnen, super. Und die anderen Leute, wo sowas kam, wie ja, wenn sie Zweifel dran haben, dann müssen sie sich an die Rechtsabteilung wenden. Die klären das. Wo ich so dachte, wieso kommen zwei so verschiedene Reaktionen? Und hab dann einfach den, also die Journalisten, mit denen ich sozusagen halbwegs sinnvollen Kontakt hatte, mal gefragt und haben gesagt, na frag den mal, von wo aus er berichtet, ob das vielleicht Berlin ist. Weil die sind oft sehr verhalten, wenn man fragt, wo sie genau waren. Weil wenn man dann sagt, am Kudam in meinem Büro, dann ist klar, warum man nicht versteht, was vor Ort war. Das war für mich sozusagen ein entscheidender Punkt, wo ich dachte, das können doch nicht so viele von woanders über vor Ort berichten. Und ich gemerkt hab, doch viele tun das.
Was waren denn deine eigenen Erfahrungen mit Krieg bis dahin, außer dass so Museumsausstellungen über längst vergangene Kriege?
Gar nichts eigentlich. Also ich bin in Rwanda groß geworden, da waren wir aber weg, bevor der Krieg losging, also der Genozid.
Wie lange warst du da?
Bis 87.
Also bis welchem Alter?
Fünf.
Genau. Aber sonst gar nichts mit zu tun gehabt. Also insofern, das war so die erste Begegnung da. Ja, lernt man Stück für Stück, wie alles. Ist am Anfang total aufregend, spannend und angstmachend. Und was ich da auch so interessant finde, im Laufe der Jahre, alles nicht mehr so wild. Also wie extrem man sich an Dinge einfach allgemein gewöhnt.
Aber war das dann sozusagen schon bei deinem zweiten Besuch gleich das Thema?
Ja, bei meinem zweiten Besuch war ich schon an der Front südlich von Kirkuk, Dakuk heißt die Region. So ungefähr 50 Kilometer südlich von Kirkuk. Und da waren wir dann schon so dicht, dass ich also mit bloßem Auge IS-Flaggen sehen konnte. Und da war es auch das erste Mal, dass wir Beschuss durch Scharfschützen hatten. Und da also ging das so von 0 auf 100 direkt, also so von man ist in einer sicheren Stadt zu da vorne knallt.
Wie bist du da hingekommen?
Genau, also ich hatte vorher also erst hier mit dem Konsulat gesprochen und gesagt, ich also mit dem kurdischen Konsulat in Deutschland und gesagt, ich will dahin. Also habe den erklärt, die Nachrichtenlage hier finde ich nicht zufriedenstellend. Ich will einfach mal selber also mehr Ahnung haben, weil es nervt mich. Also so da so someone was wrong on the Internet. Also irgendwie ich will es jetzt wissen. Also so ich will auch eigentlich nicht dahin, wo es gefährlich ist. Das ist nicht die Intention, aber es bedingt nun mal das eine, das andere gerade. Die haben gesagt, ja das würden wir jetzt nicht raten, weil es gibt einen Grund, warum das gerade keine Urlaubsregion ist. Haben sich da aber auch erst mal rausgehalten, aber haben mir einen Kontakt vermittelt vor Ort, dass ich zum Gouverneur von Kirkuk konnte, der solche Dinge entscheiden kann. Und das war ein total spannendes Gespräch. Also ich bin dann von einem Fahrer, also vom Protokoll vom Gouverneur abgeholt worden, bin zu ihm gefahren worden und der spricht exzellentes Englisch. Also weit besser als ich und ich hatte mich nicht vorbereitet ordentlich, wie man das so macht. Und der hat 25 Jahre als Gehirnchirurg in den USA gearbeitet und war Leiter der Notaufnahme, als Reagan angeschossen wurde zum Beispiel. Und wo ich dachte, was es für Kreuzungen in der Geschichte gibt. So das ist spannend und habe dem halt erzählt, was ich da so mache und der fand das alles ganz interessant und nachvollziehbar und sagte, ja, also empfehlen würde ich es nicht, weil da knallt es halt immer wieder. Aber klar, also wenn du sehen willst und wenn du nicht holst, wenn du getroffen wirst oder so, dann fahr halt gucken und ich gebe dir Leute mit, dass das klappt. Und dann sind wir erst zum Flughafen Kirkuk gefahren. Also es ist kein genutzter Flughafen mehr. Die Amis haben das 2003 noch als Airbase benutzt. Inzwischen ist das, also der Runway, also die Landebahn ist kaputt und so, aber es ist ein Militärstützpunkt, ein wichtiger Punkt einfach.
Aber die haben schon noch einen anderen Flughafen?
In Kirkuk nicht, aber in Erbil und Sulmaniyah haben sie internationale Flughäfen in Kurdistan. Und da war es dann so, dass ich da einen General getroffen habe und mit dem erst mal sprechen konnte und der hat gesagt, ja, also wenn du da noch hin willst, da fährt gleich ein Team von mir rüber, da kannst du mitfahren. Aber halt nur, wenn du schussigere Weste und Helm und so weiter bei hast. Und das hatte ich halt alles vorher gekauft und bei, weil klar war, wenn man da hin fährt, sollte man sinnvoll geschützt sein.
Okay, also hier quasi komplett mit so einem Zeug, gibt man denn da hin?
Das ist gar nicht so einfach, weil es eine Selbstverpflichtung gibt, diese kriegstauglichen schussigeren Westen nicht an Privatpersonen zu verkaufen. Also das funktioniert überraschend gut. Also ich bin erstmal so die normalen, also so Ausstatter für militär Zubehör, also nicht so in die Army-Shops, sondern in die größeren gegangen, hab dem das erklärt und ihm gesagt, joah, verstehen sie. Aber sie verkaufen halt nicht an quasi an jeden dahergelaufenen, also entweder muss ich einen Nachweis haben, dass ich für eine Sicherheitsbehörde arbeite oder dass ich dort vor Ort journalistisch tätig bin, da wo ich sowas wirklich brauche. Und dann hab ich halt gesagt, okay, ganz dämlich, wie sieht das aus? Also was brauche ich da? Und die hatten dann gesagt, naja, also da gibt es jetzt nicht so den Formbrief oder so, es muss halt irgendwas Nachvollziehbares schlichtweg für sie sein. Man muss auch sagen, heutzutage ist das einfacher. Heute kannst du so Kram echt auf eBay bestellen, einfach wenn du genug Geld hinlegst. Auch ein Sonderfall in Deutschland, in den meisten Ländern ist es sogar illegal, sowas privat zu besitzen. Es geht total auseinander, die Rechtslage. Also alles, was dem Schutz dient, sind wir hier ja recht locker. Das fand ich aber auch interessant, wie das so durcheinander geht. Und dann habe ich mich halt wieder dort an die Regionalregierung gewandt und gesagt, hallo, ich würde hier gerne Schutz kaufen. Ich brauche einen, wie auch immer gearteten, Nachweis, dass ich zu euch kommen will und da Journalismus machen. Und da haben die mir auch ein Schreiben geschickt und haben gesagt, ja, der Herr Lenze steht mit uns im Kontakt. Der war hier schon und der also quasi hat uns gesagt, dass er hier an die Front möchte und deswegen wäre es nett, wenn sie ihm was geben, dass er hier nicht auseinanderfällt.
Na gut, das kriegt jetzt so der Hobby-Militarist, kriegt so einen Brief jetzt nicht so ein weiteres generiert.
Wo ich auch dachte so, das ist ja eine faire Messlatte sozusagen. Und das heißt also, den Kram hatte ich. Dann saß ich da irgendwie in Kirkuk mit den Soldaten, mit dem Auto. Also sie fahren meist mit so Landcruisern einfach. Und waren halt vier Leute drin und ich hinten in der Mitte. Und ist dann auch ganz schön eng, weil die alle groß sind. Und dann ging es halt so halbe, dreiviertel Stunde nach Süden, also so ungefähr 40, 50 Kilometer. Da sind Orte wie Tavuk und Daghuk und auch Kobani heißt da ein Dorf, fand ich dann auch interessant. Und dadurch, dass das so lange dauerte, also so dachte ich, eigentlich müsste ich hier doch Irak anfangen. So also eigentlich demnach, was ich so an Karten und Flaggen kannte. Und dann ging es immer weiter und die waren aber total entspannt. Die saßen da völlig locker drin und haben irgendwie lustige Katzenbilder auf Facebook geklickt und so weiter. Und irgendwann sagte der eine nur, na, zieh mal einen Helm auf. Also weil hier gibt es manchmal Scharfschützen. Er sagte, ihr habt auch keine auf. Also so klar mache ich, aber warum habt ihr keine auf? Er sagt, wir haben keine. Ich sagte, okay, aber Westen oder so?
Nö.
Er sagte, was macht ihr, wenn ihr getroffen werdet? Sterben.
Ich dachte so, okay, das ist einfach hier. Okay, so ist das also.
Ich dachte, ja gut, dann ziehe ich mal den Helm auf. Und dann waren wir da halt an der Front auch, also wirklich so das letzte Ding, bevor dann so ein Erdwald kommt, den sie mit so Baggern aufgeschoben haben. Da lagen halt Scharfschützen rum, da waren auch Panzer, also so russische 70er-, 80er-Jahre-Panzer, also nichts modernes. Die werden dann so halb eingegraben, dass sie vom Rückschlag nicht zurückfahren. Also es stehen in so einer Art Mulde und das Rohr zeigt halt oben über diesen Erdwall rüber. Und so Jeeps, die wie so ein Panzerrohr draufhaben, also einfach ein Jeep mit so einem fetten Rohr. Das ist so eine britische Behelfskonstruktion oder so, sodass man also ein richtig fettes Projektil schießen kann, wenn man kein Panzer hat einfach. Also wirklich so sieht aus wie so ein Self-Mating, aber gab es irgendwie eine Weile lang. Und für mich war das spannender, also man konnte so mit bloßem Auge so eine Flagge in der Ferne erkennen und mit dem Fernglas hat man dann gesehen, ist eine IS-Flagge. Und ich dachte, jetzt musste er die ganze Zeit geballert werden und was los sein oder so an so einer Front und die saßen da alle irgendwie auf ihren Decken, haben Tee getrunken, sich unterhalten. Er sagt so, was ist da, also was passiert jetzt hier? Und ich hab gesagt, wir sitzen halt rum und also wir greifen nicht an. Warum denn? Wir halten die Linie und hab gesagt, okay, wie oft passiert denn hier was? Und er sagt, also ein paar Mal in der Woche schießen die rüber, aber jetzt nicht gezielt als Angriff, sondern eher so gucken, ist da noch einer, passiert noch was, schießen die noch zurück oder könnte man bequem vorgehen? Also so ein Rantasten. Das war halt so aus meiner Sicht total bizarr, weil man stellt sich das vor wie so ein Rambo-Film oder so. Und dann sitzen die da und dann hab ich halt auch gesagt, okay, habt ihr denn hier irgendwie Versorgungsprobleme? Oder wie ist das Leben hier? Oder was macht ihr hier den Tag lang? Und die haben gesagt, ja im Moment ist echt blöd. Also der Tee ist alle und sie haben halt keinen Shop in der Nähe. Und hätten wir doch was gesagt, hätten wir Tee mitbringen können. Also das ist das größte Problem. Nee, also und Sonnenhüte, weil sie sitzen da. Ich dachte irgendwie, das war so überhaupt nicht, wie ich es mir vorgestellt hab einfach. Und dachte dann aber, okay, ja, also Krieg ist halt nicht ein Dauergeballer. So ja klar, wenn der IS sagt, wir gehen nirgends. Also der IS vermeidet Kämpfe, wo es geht. Weil wenn man kämpft, kann man verlieren. Sonst hat man immer so dieses Mysterium. Man ist halt da und niemand hat einen wirklich geschlagen. Und die Peschmerger sagen, wir gehen da nicht hin. Warum denn? Also wir lassen uns nicht abknallen, um fünf Meter leere Wüste zu gewinnen. Also wir sollen nicht hier rein.
Das heißt, das Gebiet, was in dem Moment jetzt von dem IS besetzt wurde, war nicht wirklich Kurdistan?
Nee, das war südlich davon genau. Also es war insgesamt so. Der Kern von Kurdistan ist nie vom IS auch nur besetzt oder eingenommen worden. Nichts davon, sondern ein Teil der sogenannten disputed areas, also die so irakisch verwaltet, aber mehrheitlich kurdisch bewohnt sind. Deswegen hatte die Regionalregierung letztes Jahr auch gesagt, sie haben jetzt 150 Prozent von ihrem Gebiet IS frei, weil sie halt 50 Prozent Fläche eingenommen hatten, wo die irakische Armee weggerannt war und wo dann die Bevölkerung gesagt hat, bitte kommt zu uns. Dazu zählt auch Kirkuk. Das müsste eigentlich von der irakischen Armee gesichert sein und bis 2007 hätte ein Referendum stattfinden müssen. Ob Kirkuk zum Irak gehören will oder zu Kurdistan, das ist in der irakischen Verfassung drin mit Tag. Und bis heute fand es nicht statt. Und da haben die Kurden halt auch gesagt, Leute, es gäbe da schon so ein Referendum, was ihr hättet haben müssen. Also was verpflichtend in der Verfassung steht. Und selbst daran haltet ihr euch nicht. Und als dann die irakische Armee auch 2014 aus Kirkuk weggerannt ist, hat der Gouverneur von Kirkuk halt die zentral, die die kurdische Regionalregierung angefragt und sagt bitte gewährt uns Schutz.
Weil weggerannt wegen des IS?
Genau, zur Sicherheit, dass sie nichts passiert. Also es war kurz nachdem Mosul überrannt war und der sagt, oh nicht, dass die hinkommen, da gehen wir lieber schnell. Und die Peshmerga dürfen halt im ganzen Irak operieren. Und um das sozusagen formal juristisch auf die richtige Bahn zu lenken, hat dann der Gouverneur angefragt, dass die Peshmerga seine Stadt sichern sollen. Und dann kann die kurdische Regionalregierung sagen, wir haben eine Anfrage vom Gouverneur, der ist gewählt, der ist im Amt und wir entsprechen dem Wunsch vom Gouverneur, weil keine andere Armee sein Gelände schützt. Da kann keiner eigentlich was gegen haben, weder moralisch noch.
Und deswegen sind wir hier. Und dann ging das so ein Stück weiter. Südlich von Kirkuk leben die Karkai. Das ist so eine Religion, die auch tausende Jahre alt ist, also älter als der Islam, und vielleicht 200-300.000 Leute. Die haben gesagt, wenn der IS die Jesiden so abschlachtet, sind wir die Nächsten. Und Kirkuk ist eine große Stadt. Das ist auch interessant. Also hatten Sorge, dass das parallel läuft wie ein Mosul. Da haben sie gesagt, liebe Peschmerga, bei uns sind die Irakis auch weggerannt. Könnt ihr noch so ein paar Meter rüberkommen, also so bis ihr bei uns seid. Und dann haben die gesagt, na ja, das ist jetzt, also da hat jetzt nicht der Gouverneur das so angefragt, aber sozusagen die Vertreter von der Bevölkerung, die haben gesagt, bitte kommt her, es ist kein anderer mehr da, also entsprechen wir dem Wunsch. Die haben bei so Sachen immer darauf geachtet, dass sie halt die Form halten, also dass sie sagen, wir gehen dahin, wo wir gewünscht sind und irgendwie legitimiert, aber wir machen jetzt keinen Expansionskrieg woanders hin. Und das war halt so der Punkt, also gerade 2014, so von Mitte des Jahres bis Ende des Jahres, wo die früher sogenannten disputed areas oder umstrittenen Gebiete klar in kurdische Hand fielen, weil die Peshmerga das Gebiet eingenommen und gesichert haben, aber eben nur da, wo keine irakische Armee mehr da war. Und in dem Jahr war es auch so, dass die irakische Armee im Großen und Ganzen auseinandergebrochen ist. Also die haben gesagt, sie haben zwischen je nach Quelle 50 und 80 Prozent des Sateure, die halt dann doch nicht mehr so kämpfen wollten und der irakische Verteidigungsminister hat dann im Herbst 2014 gesagt, also ja, sie haben massive Probleme, aber er ist sich sicher, dass sie die Kampffähigkeit wieder herstellen innerhalb der nächsten zwei Jahre. Und das hat dann auch ein Journalist nochmal gefragt, ob das jetzt ein Übersetzungsfehler war oder ob er wirklich von zwei Jahren gerade redet. Nein, das war so gemeint. Also was auch realistisch war, muss man sagen, am Ende, aber es war irgendwie nicht die Ansage, die man so hören wollte.
Ja, insbesondere mit den großen Gebietsvorschritten, die er in kürzester Zeit gemacht hat.
Ja, und halt genau deswegen, also und ist klar, wenn einmal so ein kritischer Punkt überschritten ist, man sieht die Kollegen rennen weg, dann sagt man ja nicht, ich bleibe hier und kämpfe.
Also Beine in die Hand und ab geht's.
Und also eine der obskursten Sachen da war, war auch bei dem Trip im Sommer 2014. Da waren also, da waren wir in einem Flüchtlingscamp, knapp neben den ersten Peschmerger-Stützpunkt in Richtung IS-Gebiet, so Richtung Mossul, also 10 Kilometer vor Mossul oder 20 damals noch. Und da war einer, der hat gesagt, hier kommt mal mit zu den Peschmerger, die den Checkpoint besetzen, müssen euch unbedingt eine Story erzählen. Die haben gesagt, da kam so ein Opel Vectra angefahren, mit irakischen Frauen drin. Und sozusagen Klischewitze von Kurden ist oft, wie hässlich irakische Frauen sind, also wie Blondin- oder Mantafahrer-Witze, so die hässliche irakische Frau oder so. Und die meinten, so in etwa sah das auch aus, so richtig dicke, müffelnde Muttis irgendwie. Und sie haben gesagt, klar, da macht man dann ja in dem Moment keine Witze drüber. Das brannte ihnen im Kopf die ganze Zeit, ihre ganzen blöden Witze so. Und die waren halt auch verhüllt und haben gesagt, da musst du ja schon mit Respekt denen begegnen. Sie wollten auch sicher sein, dass das jetzt nicht die S-Terrorist mit der Weste drunter ist. Sie waren aber nur Männer am Checkpoint. Also haben sie aber mit denen geredet und gesagt, Leute, ihr müsst zumindest mal aussteigen und euch mal drehen oder so. Und die wollten aber nicht und hatten Angst, wenn man sie anguckt und so. Sachten aber, irgendwie war ihnen das zu komisch. Und irgendwann hat der eine, also es ist wohl so rumgeschlichend, hat sich in so eine Position gebracht, dass er mal ein bisschen was mehr sehen konnte und sagt, also die Beifahrerin hat einen Vollbart.
Sagt, raus.
Dann waren das zwei irakische Offiziere, die irgendwerem die Klamotten geklaut und die Karre geklaut haben und sich aus Mosul abgesetzt haben Richtung Kurdistan. Der sagt, Leute, geht es euch noch gut? Ihr seid Armee. Also ihr klaut der Bevölkerung die Karre und die Klamotten, um als irakische Frauen rüberzukommen und die haben sie in dem Fall dann, also die haben gesagt, zurückschicken können sie auch nicht. Sie sind ja auch nur Menschen. Da haben sie gesagt, sie wissen nicht mal, ob die rein dürfen, weil die sind ja in Uniform, die dürfen Kurdistan nicht betreten. Da haben sie dann der Polizei übergeben und gesagt, das müsst ihr sagen, wie das jetzt ist, also was da ist. Aber haben gesagt, das fanden sie schon, eine ganz schön heiße Nummer.
Hatst du denn alle deine Frontbesuche jetzt so langweilig abgelaufen und ist jetzt sozusagen der Mangel an Aktivität da so endemisch, dass man sich wundert, dass da überhaupt noch gekämpft wird? So wird es auch sicherlich nicht immer gelaufen.
Nee, nee, das ging schon hin und her. Aber zum einen ist auch so, es gab oft so einzelne Angriffswellen, also wenn der IS kam oder so, dass es also einzelne Wochen gab, wo es richtig heiß herging, oder jetzt im Frühjahr, als das Gebiet zwischen Erbil und Mosul, also es sind so 50, 60 Kilometer oder so, als das frei gekämpft wurde von den Peshmerga bis sozusagen kurz vor Mosul, wo dann die irakische Armee übernommen hat, um Mosul einzunehmen. Wir hatten aber auch Sachen, zum Beispiel in Shingal, dass wir vom IS mit Granaten beschossen wurden, unser Konvoi, und auch mit Maschinengewehren und so weiter. Bei Duhuk, nicht Duhuk, bei Kirkuk, also südlich davon in Dakhuk hatten, war Scharfschützenbeschuss, also der an uns vorbeiging. Und wir hatten das einmal...
Während ihr im Konvoi wart oder einer?
Also als wir ausgestiegen waren. Also das ist immer das Gefährliche, sobald die Fahrzeuge stehen. Und ich hatte es vor anderthalb Jahren, als wir quasi Richtung, also zurück auf dem Rückweg nach Kyrgyzstan vom umkämpften Gebiet, dass wir einen Selbstmordattentäter hatten, der auf den Konvoi also aus noch Entfernung zu Grant kam. Und die haben gesagt, also erst mal, also erst vorher kam der Funkspruch, dass sie davon ausgehen, dass unser Konvoi aufgefallen ist. Sie haben nur Funk abgefangen, dass ein Konvoi irgendwie aufgefallen ist. Und wir sind der einzige Größrenner in der Gegend gerade.
Also ihr wart gewarnt sozusagen. Genau.
Dann haben die gesagt, dann rannte oder lief ein so ein Typ quasi durch die Wüste da Richtung Straße. Und die haben gesagt, eigentlich wer läuft bitte quer durch die Wüste? Also wenn er ein Moped hat und irgendwo lang fährt, manche fahren komisch. Okay, ein Auto ist auch schon komisch. Aber jemand, der zu Fuß unterwegs ist, im Nix, das ist auffällig. Und wenn er dann noch bei 50 Grad eine Weste trägt, nicht gut. Die haben gesagt, im Normalfall machen sie es simpel, sie geben Gas und versuchen einfach vorbei zu sein, bevor der an der Straße ist. Dann hat sich das Problem erledigt, weil dann fliegt der eh in die Luft, weil die dann meist mit dem Handy fernzünden. Also um zu gucken, ob sie noch irgendwen mitreißen. Aber dann sind sie aus der Nummer solide raus. Und da waren sie sich aber nicht sicher, ob sich die Wege kreuzen oder nicht. Und ein Begleitfahrzeug hat dann einfach mit Maschinengewehr so in seine Richtung, also davor geschossen, weil die gesagt haben, im Normalfall, wenn jemand auf dich schießt, dann läufst du nicht weiter, weil dann verstehst du die Message so. Und gerade in der Gegend, wenn jemand weit vor dich schießt, dann ist klar, der wollte dich jetzt nicht treffen, der wollte nur mal klar sagen, hier geht's.
Bis hierhin noch nicht weiter.
Und der ist dann losgerannt und dann sagt, okay, also wenn du auf einen schießt und der rennt zu dir, dann ist es ein ganz klares Zeichen.
Wie hast du dich an dem Moment gefühlt?
Also erst mal, also so halb halb. Zum einen denkt man, okay, der ist weit weg. Zum anderen saß ich in einem gepanzerten Auto, wo ich wusste, wenn der so weit weg ist, passiert mir hier drin nicht viel. Aber dann denkt man auch immer wieder, warum sitze ich eigentlich im gepanzerten Auto und alle anderen nicht. Also das ist auch immer so, also man freut sich, dass man selber sicher ist, aber man weiß, man ist auch der Einzige. Also das ist auch nicht optimal. Und dann halt noch der Punkt, ein gepanzertes Auto ist ja nicht unkaputtbar oder so. Also zum einen, wenn so ein Projektil, also wenn wirklich eine große Waffe auf die Scheibe schießt, dann geht eine Schockwelle durchs Auto. Also so wirklich, als wird einem jemand vom Kopf hauen. Also alles vibriert kurz und der ganze Staub aus den Sitzen und so fliegt hoch. Das heißt, sofort ist man im Staub. Deswegen sollten so Autos immer gut geputzt sein. Sobald man einer atmet, hustet man halt und sieht und sieht nichts mehr. Und das ist schlecht, wenn der Fahrer das nicht weiß vorher. Deswegen, wenn man sowas lernt, im Detail lernt man auch, wie die Karre zu putzen ist, dass sich kein Staub fängt. Aber die Leute dort sind meist nicht gut ausgebildet. Der nächste Punkt ist, die Scheibe und die Tür, also je nach Explosion, kommen die fünf bis zehn Zentimeter rein. Das heißt, wenn man so mit der Kamera gerade an der Scheibe ist, um noch ein Foto zu machen, dann fliegt einem einfach mal die Kamera ins Auge. Oder auch wenn die Tür vorkommt, kann man sich also wirklich schwer den Kopf verletzen. Also sollte man immer weit weg sitzen und einen Helm aufhaben und den Mund aufhaben für den Druckausgleich, wenn was kommt und so weiter. Es ist halt eine Menge, was man bedenken muss. Das hatte ich vorher alles gelernt. Das kommt dann auch ganz schnell in den Kopf, dass man das artig macht und halt auch das. Man sollte nicht gaffend hinter der Scheibe sitzen, weil die ist nicht unkaputtbar. Die ist das empfindlichste Ding an der Karre. Besser ist es trotzdem in den Kopf runter, weil wenn der mit einem richtig fetten MG schießt, dann geht die Kugel auch durch die Scheibe. Das ist halt nur bis zu einer bestimmten Klasse sicher. Das waren so ganz viele Dinge, wo ich auch dachte, okay, nehme ich einfach mal den Kopf runter, setze den Helm auf und warte einfach mal. Ich muss mir das nicht im Detail angucken, während hinter uns das MG gefeuert hat. Also wo man immer wieder die Salven hörte. Und irgendwann gab es einen ziemlichen Knall, gefolgt von einem großen Jubel und großer Freude auf unserer Seite. Ich auch immer denke, das ist so bizarr. Also ich habe das auch später noch mal erlebt, wenn zum Beispiel eine Rakete abgeschossen wird auf ein IS-Auto. Und es gibt einen riesen Knall und es kommt wie bei so einem, wie wenn man so diese Atomexplosion-Video sieht, kommt so eine Schockwelle über den Boden, also so dass dieser ganze Staub aufgewirbelt wird. Also nur ein paar Zentimeter, aber es sieht halt richtig wild aus. Und alle freuen sich. Man selber denkt auch, boah, geil, zum Glück ist der tot. Denkt so auf der anderen Seite, aber eigentlich sollte ich mich nicht freuen, wenn gerade einer gestorben ist. Also das ist dann so eine ganz merkwürdige Sache halt. Also nach dem Motto, ein Glück, dass ich sicher bin und nur der tot. Und die haben gesagt, okay, damit war es definitiv ein Selbstmordattentäter, weil wenn jemand so knallt, wenn man drauf schießt, dann hat er auf jeden Fall noch was dabei gehabt. Genau. Das war schon ganz schön beängstigend. Also auch, dass man so sonst sagt man, ja, ja, da kann was passieren. Und es könnte und klar und irgendwie. Es ist so wie hier, wenn ich rausgehe, könnte ich vom Auto überfahren werden. Aber eigentlich passiert ja doch nichts.
Man hat es auch noch in gewisser Hinsicht ein wenig in der Hand.
Genau. Und dann war das oder sagen wir, ich könnte hier Opfer eines Gewaltverbrechens werden, ohne es in der Hand zu haben. Eigentlich im Alltag geht man ja doch nicht von aus, dass es einem passiert. Und da war das halt so ein ganzes Stück dichter auf einmal, wo man gesagt hat, so okay, das ist irgendwie, also ja, das ist nicht eine theoretische, sondern eine ganz praktische Gefahr, wovon wir hier gerade reden. Und das fand ich schon ganz schön wild in dem Moment.
Auch danach? Kriegt man das so psychisch? Der mag ja jeder anders sein.
Also es geht eigentlich. Also mir schien, in dem Fall geht's. Also hatte ich nachher keine großen Probleme mit, weil man vorher ja weiß, so was könnte passieren. Und dann war es ja nicht, dass es proletztlich geknallt hat, sondern dann gab es erst den Funkspruch dann, oh, da hinten ist einer. Jetzt ist aber komisch. Also ich denke, das ist auch ein Unterschied, wenn sich das so aufbaut und wenn man sich so darauf vorbereiten kann, Stück für Stück.
Das hat nicht diesen Terror-Effekt. Wenn einmal geht was los, Panik.
Genau, also nicht wie hier, wenn man am Breitscheidplatz irgendwie einen Glühwein trinkt und auf einmal sind die Leute vor einem Tod. Zwar sind die genauso tot, wenn man in Kurdistan ist, aber man hat im Prinzip drei Wochen vor Abflug Zeit, sich darauf vorzubereiten, dass das passieren kann und da auf dem Hinweg und dann in der Situation. Und ich glaube, das ist halt der Unterschied, dass dieser Schock-Effekt nicht da ist, sondern eher so dann im letzten Moment das Warten nur noch wann knallt. Also nicht ob und wie, sondern irgendwann gleich ist es soweit. Und ich glaube, das macht einen riesen Unterschied. Und eben auch dieses Vorbereitetsein. Also ich habe zum Beispiel letztes Jahr, vorletztes Jahr, weiß ich gar nicht mehr, also vor einer Weile dann noch ein Training in Dubai gemacht. Ein Freund von mir, Fidelis Cloer, der baut seit fast 30 Jahren gepanzerte Fahrzeuge, also entwickelt die, baut die und verkauft die. Hat unter anderem an Nelson Mandela und an Arafat und so weiter Fahrzeuge verkauft, also an Kasei, also wirklich großen Kram. Und der bietet halt auch die entsprechenden Trainings an. Wie fährt man so ein Fahrzeug? Wie verhält man sich in Krisensituationen bei Entführung, Verletzten, Versorgung und alles? Das machen also in dem Fall Leute, die bei den Special Forces von der Belgischen Armee waren, also die auch wirklich wissen, wovon sie reden, die jetzt nicht so theoretische Instruktoren sind, sondern der eine bei dem ich war, der war zwölf Jahre lang Schafschütze im Auslandseinsatz. Also ich denke, der weiß, wovon er redet, wenn er einem Gefahrensituation erklärt. Da habe ich halt eine Woche lang so Training gemacht mit, auf was man achten muss, wie das funktioniert und auch halt dieses, wie ist das ganz praktisch, wenn ein Auto getroffen wird, wenn der Nachbarwagen in die Luft fliegt und so weiter. Da dachte ich mir dann auch, wenn man das, also je genauer man das weiß, desto besser ist man ja vorbereitet. Also weil man zum einen relativ genau sich vorstellen kann, was passiert. Und zum anderen haben wir da bis zum Umfallen Abläufe geübt. Also zum Beispiel, wenn irgendwas knallt, erst mal gucken, ob man selber getroffen ist. Sagen, das klingt dämlich, aber du merkst nicht, ob dich ein Schrapnel oder ein Projektil getroffen hast im ersten Moment, weil du so unter Adrenalin stehst, dass du nicht mal eine Schussverletzung mitkriegst. Du hast aber nur ungefähr 100 Sekunden, die zu versorgen, bevor du tot bist. Und das ist halt ein ziemlich gefährlicher Wettlauf, wenn du davon die Hälfte der Zeit das nicht mitkriegst und dich dann wunderst, warum dir schummrig wird und du dann überlegst, wo eigentlich deine Versorgungssachen sind. Das heißt, so Sachen bis zum Umfallen üben, also dass man jedes Mal sich abtastet und selbst wenn es dreimal in einer Minute ist, immer wieder, immer wieder, immer wieder. Und wenn man irgendwo die entsprechenden Verletzungen findet, wie versorgt man die ganz schnell mit Kram, die man in einer Gürteltasche hat? Und eben wie macht man das selbst, wenn man nichts mehr sieht, weil es staubig ist? Und das ist also so lange automatisiert, bis wir es wirklich nachts im Hotelzimmer hatten, wenn die anklopfen und sagen, Schussverletzung, linker Arm! Und dann liegt man da im Bett, okay, ja, habe ich dran, gut, weiterpennen.
Das war so der Test sozusagen.
Oder auch man macht theoretische Bilder, gucken und so weiter, und da macht man das und da macht man das. Und Paul, rechtes Bein abgerissen. Und mitten im Klassenraum springt man dann drauf und versorgt das oder so. Die haben gesagt, wirklich, das muss man total übertrieben eine Weile machen, aber dann hat man es so im Kopf und sagen und zum anderen. Dann ist man auch viel ruhiger, weil man, also sagen, man macht weniger Fehler, weil man im Kopf hat, wenn was passiert, dann weiß ich doch, was ich zu tun habe. Also muss ich gar nicht so nervös sein. Und kann mich mehr auf das konzentrieren, was wesentlich ist. Mir scheint, ich habe da ungefähr zehnmal so viel gelernt, wie ich je brauchen werde, aber trotzdem, das beruhigt einen extrem, dass man sagt, ja, ich wüsste aber in den meisten Situationen, was ich machen soll und vor allem, was nicht.
Ja, diese Ungewissheit, die ist raus. Und das ist das, was einem Angst macht. Ich glaube, ja. Bist du so aus der Kategorie Mensch, die irgendwie gleich zu Boden geht, wenn sich mal ein Finger schneidet, oder war das für dich eh nie so das Problem?
Nee, das geht ganz gut. Also ich bin halt in Rwanda aufgewachsen, wo die Versorgungslage ja eh mäßig war. Also ich habe mir da mal als Kind eine Machete in den Fuß gehauen und ähnliche Sachen. Meine Eltern sagten, dass ich damit immer sehr locker umgegangen bin. Ich bin dann immer erst mal zu ihnen gegangen und habe gefragt, was man da jetzt tun sollte.
Kannst du mir mal den Löwen vom Bein nehmen?
Ich habe mal versucht, einen kleinen Löwen mitzunehmen. Die waren zum Glück sehr voll gefressen. Und ich habe eben, weil ich auch noch klein habe, ich versucht, an den Ohren und am Schwanz wegzuziehen. Und die haben dann gesagt, geh doch mal weg von dem. Der mag das grad nicht. Da haben sie gesagt, das ist auch so, das ist halt auch, die Viecher sind halt nicht gefährlich, wenn die voll gefressen in der Sonne liegen. Da denken die, der Typ ist jetzt keine Gefahr, da bleibe ich liegen, da bewege ich mich nicht mal für, ne? Ja, aber deswegen, da... Also ich glaube, das war auch dadurch, dass ich da so Stück für Stück rankam. Man gewöhnt sich halt total dran, man bleibt ziemlich ruhig. Wir hatten das jetzt auch im März. Da sind wir irgendwo durch eine total sichere Gegend gefahren. Auf einmal haben wir Maschinengewehrfeuer gehört. Das Lustige ist, wir haben genau die Sache auch auf Video, weil gerade so eine Erdölpumpstation in der Nähe war, wo so riesige Flammen rauskommen, also wo die oben so das Gas abfackeln. Und das wollte jemand im Auto filmen. Und genau in dem Moment hört man dieses Ramm, Ramm, Ramm, Ramm, Ramm, Ramm. Und im ganzen Auto keine Panik, sondern in der Gegend, wo kam das denn her? Also so weit sagt, hier kann doch, also hier kann ja eigentlich nichts sein. Also wo man sonst schon wahrscheinlich Angst hätte, dann ja komisch. Und erst waren es nur Pistolen-Schüsse. Und da sagt einer, es war doch keine Kalaschnikow so.
Nee.
Und dann hört man halt, das Kalaschnikow war ja, das war eine. Jaja, komisch. Hier?
Ja, warum denn?
Also als wir das dann später geguckt haben im Hotel, dachten wir auch, ja, da merkt man, man gewöhnt sich eine Menge. Also vor drei Jahren werden wir noch panisch aus dem Auto gesprungen oder so wahrscheinlich. Und da war so, das ist ja komisch. Ja, nee, fahren wir weiter.
Ja, ich kenne das, ohne direkte Erfahrung in dem Bereich zu haben, irgendwie ganz gut nachvollziehen. Das kennst du sicherlich auch, gerade im IT-Bereich. So mit den Rechnern zu arbeiten, Probleme dann zu begegnen. Und was weiß ich, der Bildschirm zerlegt sich schon irgendwie. Und komische Dinge geschehen, dann jemand anders, dem dieser Rechner gehört, so oh Gott, meine Daten. Und dann darf ich jetzt überhaupt irgendwas anfassen. Aber wenn man einfach so dieses Wissen hat und diese Ruhe und dann erstmal mit dem Ohr auf die Festplatte und was macht ein Teil.
Klackert schon.
Dann kann man irgendwie auch so eine professionelle Ruhe verbreiten, die die anderen Leute dann irgendwie nicht so richtig gewechselt bekommen.
Ich glaube 2001 oder 2005 bei dem Camp im Holland, wo der Airwax rüberkam, ich glaube das war 2005, wo irgendwie das in der Nähe ja irgendwie so ein Flughafen für die, wo ich auch dachte, bei anderen Camps wird man scheiß sagen, was macht das komische Flugzeug da? Und da alle so, guck mal, ein Airwax, lass mal ein Foto machen, abgefahren, was macht der denn hier? Ja, ist das gleiche denke ich auch. Oder als ich das erste Mal so einen abstrus teuren Switch in der Hand hatte auf dem Kongress, also so beim, wo dieser Kram angeliefert wurde von Cisco oder so, dachte so, boah, das Ding kostet 30.000 Euro, das muss ich jetzt mit Samthandschuhen anfassen und so drei Jahre später und sagt, ah, noch einer, noch einer, noch einer. Man gewöhnt sich an vieles. Ja, aber es ist halt das gleiche wie immer, man gewöhnt sich an Kram und dann hat man aber auch wieder den Blick frei für andere Dinge und dann ist nicht mehr so, oh, eine Front, sondern okay, und was habt ihr hier letztes Jahr gemacht und wie verändert sich die Lage? Da werden dann die Gesprächsthemen auch anders.
Was hast du denn so aus dieser Fernbeobachtung, aus der Nähe, so über die Welt gelernt? So, das ist das Ganze, ich meine, steckt ja dann neben den ganzen regionalen Aspekten, die schwer nachvollziehbar sind, steckt ja auch sehr viel, so wie geht denn überhaupt dieser Planet so miteinander um?
Ja, also das fand ich ganz spannend, gerade da, wo halt sowohl USA als auch Russland versuchen, Einfluss zu gewinnen, dann auch die Rolle Chinas zum Beispiel zu sehen, die wie immer auch überall dabei sind, aber man hört und sieht nichts von denen, man sieht nur, dass die ganzen Brücken, die da gebaut wurden, da viele auf einmal chinesische Firmennamen drauf haben und so was in der Art, also wo man sich so wundert, während alle anderen noch mit viel Tamtam irgendwie überlegen, was sie machen, haben die Chinesen schon wieder die Aufträge im Sack und freuen sich, dass sie da Kohle verdienen. Und dann auch der Punkt, also wie das so hin und her geht, macht man jetzt mit den Amis was, macht man mit den Russen was, wer liefert was? Also dieses ganze bizarre Theater und auch wie viel ist einfach nur Theater vor den Kameras und wie viel kommt dann wirklich bei rum. Also wie die Sache, als jetzt Erdogan gesagt hat, ey, wir marschieren da ein und irgendwie, ich weiß nicht was und wo ich halt ein paar Kilometer von der Grenze entfernt saß und mir einfach nur dachte, machst du doch eh nicht. Also das weiß ich doch ganz sicher, das ist jetzt nur Säbelrasseln. Also auch da, was man für, also wie sehr man anfängt, so was einzuschätzen. Und zum anderen, was mir echt immer wieder da durch den Kopf geht, ist so wirklich im Prinzip dieser Punkt, so wann ist die Welt eigentlich so kaputt gegangen? Also das, das eine Mal hatten wir das, da war ich halt erst in Schingal bei den Jesiden, die mir erzählt haben, halt wie ihre Familien entführt und abgeschlachtet wurden und so weiter, wo ich wirklich direkt mal mit den Leuten gesprochen habe, denen das passiert ist.
Also die, die ihre Genozide durchnummerieren.
Genau, die bei Nummer 74 schon waren und die zehntausende Menschen an den IS verloren haben durch Ermorden und durch Entführen für Sexsklaven und so weiter. Von da mussten wir direkt nachdem wir da einen Tag waren und mit Granaten beschossen wurden und so weiter zurück auf dem Rückweg noch einen recht schweren Autounfall gehabt, weil man muss sehr schnell fahren, damit man nicht beschossen werden kann. Mit so einem Ford Pickup. Die fahren so 180, 190 ungefähr. Allerdings ist vor uns ein Stück weiter eine Granate auf die Straße geflogen. Die hat uns nicht erwischt, aber die hat ein Loch in der Straße gemacht und wir sind durch das Loch geflogen und bei ungefähr 180 von der Straße geflogen mit dem Wagen. Wir hatten noch Westerhelfen alles an. In dem Moment auch offensichtlich keine Verletzung. Das Auto war verhältnismäßig okay. Der Rest vom Konvoi fuhr noch. Also dieses Weiter, Weiter, Weiter alles.
180, es hat sich durch ein Loch geballert.
Aber auf den Rädern aufgesetzt zum Glück. Neben der Straße und kein Minenfeld gehabt. Ja, wirklich. Also ich bin eingepennt gewesen im Auto und bin halt aufgewacht, weil der Motor so aufheulte und dachte so, wieso sind die anderen Autos neben uns und nicht vorne und hinter uns. Also wirklich so, wo man in dem Moment auch erstmal mal braucht so, was passiert gerade eigentlich? Warum sieht das so komisch aus, aus dieser Perspektive?
Du fliegst gerade mit 180 Sachen zehn Meter durch die Luft in einem Kriegsgebiet.
Der Wagen, also der war in keinem guten Zustand mehr, aber er fuhr noch. Er hat gesagt, weiterfahren, alles andere später, weiter, weiter, weiter. Der Beifahrer war verletzt, der hatte sich das Bein gebrochen und so weiter und die haben gesagt, ja, aber trotzdem, das geht noch. Also so gibt es Schlimmeres, versorgt das bei der Fahrt, fahr weiter. Haben es dann auch geschafft.
Du hast da gar keine nennenswerten Bläsuren?
Also in dem Moment nichts. Später hat sich dann rausgestellt, eine Prellung von der Wirbelsäule quasi runter, Rippen, Serienfraktur und so weiter. Also schon alles nicht dramatisch. Also Kram, wo man einfach ein paar Wochen ruhig machen muss und dann geht es wieder. Aber wo ich dann auch gemerkt habe, so Dinge, die echt schmerzhaft sind, die ich überhaupt nicht mitgekriegt habe in dem Moment. Also null, gar kein Problem mit gehabt. Und halt diverse Prellungen so rundum, diverse fette Beulen. Also das habe ich dann erst beim Duschen gesehen irgendwie. Wir sind dann in die nächste größere Stadt gefahren, wo mein Leihwagen auch stand. Also weil wir da halt mit dem Militärkonvoi gefahren sind, mit dem Leihwagen dann zurück in die Hauptstadt, weil ich am nächsten Tag fliegen musste. Und die Nacht war ich halt im Divan Hotel in Erbil. Das ist echt das luxuriöseste Hotel der Welt. Und dann war so quasi von losfahren in dieser echt zerschossenen, übelen Gegend. Und dann die Nacht in so einem premiumschönen Hotel irgendwie mit Whirlpool im Zimmer. Und so waren schon irgendwie denkt, das ist irgendwie, das kann doch nicht sein. Also irgendwie, das ist so bizarr. Und dann aber direkt ins Bett gefallen, gepennt und am nächsten Morgen direkt zum Flughafen viel zu spät da, abgeflogen. Also so gar keine Zeit, richtig nachzudenken, sondern halt so von Stress zu Stress zu Stress die ganze Zeit. Beim Umsteigeflughafen war dann so das erste Mal, wo ich irgendwie Zeit hatte, sozusagen darüber nachzudenken, was denn eigentlich passiert war. Und wo ich dann auch die Interviews mir noch mal angeguckt habe mit den Leuten und alles. Und da war dann so der Punkt, wo das alles so, wo man das erst richtig realisiert, was da alles passiert ist mit diesem bisschen Abstand und mit in Wien am Flughafen sitzen und nicht irgendwo noch im Auto sein oder so. Da ich dann auch gedacht so, also was für eine verworrene, kaputte Welt ist das denn bitte, wo das auch heutzutage so eng zusammenhängt. Also wie weit man innerhalb von 24 Stunden reist, wenn so was hart auf hart kommt und man sich beeilen muss. Und also so diese Kernfrage, warum sitzen wir hier jetzt gerade hier in der Metaebene völlig entspannt rum und ich kann in viereinhalb Stunden mit dem Flugzeug dahin gehen, wo die Leute echt am Arsch sind. Also warum sitzen die nicht auch hier oder also, das ist so, ich denke immer, man kriegt einen relativ großen Blick für die Welt oder also nicht richtig für die Welt, aber für was alles kaputt ist. Vor allem sagt, ich weiß nicht, wie ich es repariere, aber ich sehe doch ganz klar, wo die Schäden hier sind und was eigentlich nicht sein kann.
Vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt sein müsste.
Genau, also wir haben genug Geld, Platz und Versorgung auf der Welt. Denke ich ja bei dem Film Elysium, der vor zwei, drei Jahren oder so in den Kinos war, wo die Weltelite auf einer Weltraumstation lebt und jeder hat zu Hause so eine Art Röhre, die Brüche heilen kann, Krebs heilen und alles. Also die Medizinstation und die leben da im Schön. Und die Weltbevölkerung ist nur noch so die arbeitende Bevölkerung. Wenn man sich das anguckt und denkt, das ist ja echt übel, das geht ja gar nicht. Und wenn man sich dann denkt, hey, wir sind hier in Elysium sozusagen, muss man sich halt mal in die eigene Nase fassen. Also welchen Grund gibt es denn, dass wir nicht nach Erbil mal irgendwie ein komplettes state-of-the-art-Privatklinik-Krankenhaus liefern? Einfach nur, weil hier gerne jemand Geld für hätte. Aber sonst kein inhaltlicher Grund oder sowas. Und das finde ich halt immer so schlimm. Also auch wenn man so Star Trek guckt oder so und sagt, boah, abgefahren, Raumschiff und so weiter, und sagen muss, hey, wir haben doch Raumschiffe, wir können auch heute nicht bemannt, aber wir können zum Mars fliegen, wir können zum Mond fliegen. Der Unterschied bei Star Trek ist, es ist verfügbar, ohne dass man Geld für zahlt. Das ist genau der Punkt. Aber Technologie haben wir doch den verrücktesten Scheiß seit 40, 50 Jahren eigentlich. Es ist nur nicht verfügbar. Und das ist der Punkt.
Ja, und was ziehst du da so für Schlüsse draus, außer dass das sozusagen zu beklagen ist?
Das ist, finde ich, immer der große Punkt. Was macht man jetzt mit dieser Erkenntnis? Und zum einen denke ich immer klar, der Punkt ist, man möchte es ändern. Aber wie? Und so der Weg, den ich halt gefunden habe, wo ich zumindest ein bisschen machen kann, ist eben Politiker zu nerven, bis zum Umfallen, die ich hier treffe, die aber Entscheidungen treffen. Also nicht irgendwen in der Kette, also jetzt nicht, keine Ahnung, nicht mal mein Direktkandidaten hier, weil der hat nicht genug Einfluss, sondern wirklich Minister, Kanzler, alles in der Ebene. Da ich auch oft gehört, da kommt man ja gar nicht ran oder so. Ich muss sagen, wenn man in Berlin wohnt, kommt man da super einfach an. Die haben öffentliche Kalender, wo ein Teil der Termine sind. Da muss man halt hingehen und muss in zehn Sekunden seinen Punkt vermitteln können, so wie damals mit Steinmeier und dann hat man den Kontakt. Dann kann man darüber sprechen. Es ist halt viel, viel Arbeit, wie immer bei Lobbyarbeit im Prinzip, aber das geht.
In der Stelle verlässt du natürlich deine journalistische Position vollständig.
Ja, aber da würde ich auch nie sagen, dass ich jetzt hier als Journalist bin, sondern ich denke, man macht ja verschiedene Dinge im Leben. Auch wenn ich bei mir im Verlag sitze und arbeite, mache ich ja auch nichts journalistisches. Da bin ich Kaufmann. Das ist auch was anderes. Da habe ich aber auch nicht das Label Journalist oder so drauf, sondern das ist dann eine andere Schiene. Zum Teil ergibt es sich auch zufällig. Ich hatte zum Beispiel im Bunker eine Gruppe von Leuten vom Auswärtigen Amt, die einfach sich die Ausstellung angeguckt haben, die zum Bereich gehören Humanitäre Hilfe Irak, wo ich gesagt habe, hallo, ich flieg nächste Woche rüber, lass uns mal reden. Und sowas ergibt sich dann halt auch manchmal. Und mit denen sehr viel gesprochen, weil die es natürlich interessant finden, wenn man wirklich selber da ist. Also weil die kennen die Gegend zwar auch, aber sagen, so viele Leute kennen sie jetzt auch nicht, die darüber fliegen. Das ist immer interessant, den Kontakt zu halten. Dann habe ich es aber auch so gemacht. Ich habe zum Beispiel Politikern, also im Bundestag, die in den entsprechenden Ausschüssen sitzen, einfach mal meine Artikel über die Reisen geschickt und habe also einfach wirklich individuell die 10, 20 Leute angeschrieben, denen gesagt, hey, ich war gerade da.
Welche Ausschüsse betrifft das?
Also zum einen die für, oh Gott, im Prinzip die für humanitäre Hilfe, da ist irgendwie anders, dann Sicherheit im Ausland, also und die Rüstungsexport-Sachen. Das sind also eigentlich sind es drei im Kern. Und diese, der Rüstungsexport-Kram ist ja ein bisschen schwierig, weil der im Geheim-, oder es nennt sich nicht Geheim-, aber de facto im Geheimtagen. Da habe ich denen einfach auch Mails geschrieben und gesagt, also so hier, lieber Peter, ich bin da vor Ort immer wieder, ich kann dir quasi aus erster Hand berichten, wie es da ist. Und hier ist mein Artikel und würde mich freuen, wenn du den liest und wenn du Fragen hast, melde dich. Klar, die kriegen drei Millionen Mails am Tag, aber ich denke trotzdem, dass es heraussticht, wenn man selber da war und nicht irgendwie sagt, hallo, ich möchte gerne Geld verdienen mit dir. Da hatte ich es auch immer wieder, dass einzelne Leute sich gemeldet haben, oder auch ganz interessant, als diese Diskussion war, ist das G36 scheiße oder nicht und hin und her und funktioniert das in der Wüste, da hat sich auf einmal jemand von der Bundeswehr bei mir gemeldet und gesagt, hey, du warst doch dort und die Leute dort hatten G36. Haben die zufällig was darüber gesagt, wie das da funktioniert? Und er sagt, ja, die sind sehr zufrieden. Also, wobei das ist keine qualitative Aussage. Natürlich sagen die, hey, danke, das ist ein tolles Ding. Aber ich kann dir einen Kontakt hingeben und dann kannst du, wenn du quasi in der Runde nachher sozusagen, also ich habe da gerade angerufen, der sagt, das ist okay, was glaube ich ein sehr gutes Argument in diesen Runden ist, wo es so eher theoretisch zugeht. Und das hat dem wohl geholfen, zumindest als Argumentation. Und umgekehrt hat er dann halt gesagt, hey, wenn du mal das Truppenkontingent dort besuchen willst oder irgendwas, sag mir Bescheid, dann hat man da halt wieder ein Gefallen gut. Man denkt, das schadet zumindest nicht. Aber wo ich so sehe, ich kann halt mit meiner Arbeit in Kontakt treten mit Leuten. Und ich finde es auch nicht falsch zu sagen, man muss denen helfen, die gegen den IS kämpfen. Also, weil das ist eine Sache, wo ich denke, das kann ich gut vertreten. Das ist jetzt keine Nischenmeinung oder so. Und wenn ich dann halt helfen kann, auch mit meinen Artikeln, dass ich sage, lest euch doch den Artikel durch, ich war dort und ich kann euch einen direkten Einblick geben, eure Rückschlüsse zieht ihr halt selber, dann kann ich da auch gut mit leben. Also anders wäre es, wenn ich jetzt, also für mich ist immer der Punkt, wenn ich damit Geld verdienen würde, wenn ich sagen würde, gib mir doch mal den Auftrag, dass ich vor Ort für euch, was weiß ich, was recherchiere oder so, ob das G36 besser schießt als die Kalashnikov. Da würde ich sagen, klar, das ist dann nicht mehr sehr journalistisch. Das ist dann in erster Linie Geld verdienen. Dazu fällt mir noch ein spannender Punkt ein. Ein Freund von mir war lange Herausgeber von Waffenmagazin Visir, also David Schiller, der war bei der israelischen Armee, ist eigentlich Deutscher, hat Spezialeinheiten ausgebildet. Und der hat auch gesagt, der Punkt Journalisten und keine Waffen ist sehr schwierig, wenn man der Herausgeber von einem Waffenmagazin ist. Also sagt klar, jeder versteht den Unterschied, ist überhaupt keine Frage, dass es da um was anderes geht. Er sagt trotzdem, sieht man da wieder, dass auch dieser Punkt nicht einfach ist, weil natürlich geht er auf Waffenmessen, redet mit Militärs und ballert in der Gegend rum. Aber für seinen Fachbereich ist das eben wieder nötig. Und das war nochmal sein Beispiel für, das ist halt, also deswegen sind diese Regeln so kompliziert. Also natürlich trägt er keine Waffe im Kriegsgebiet und so weiter. Aber für seine Arbeit ist auch durchaus wichtig, schießt das Ding in der Wüste oder schießt es unter Wasser, weil das eben sein Gebiet ist. Das fand ich halt auch wieder interessant, wo ich dachte, ja eben die Regeln sind nicht so simpel starr. Also wenn ich mich jetzt dahinstelle und sage, ich teste mal alle Waffen der Peschmerga zum Spaß, dann wird das schwierig zu vermitteln, warum man das tut. Wenn er jetzt aber als Waffenjournalist sagt, Waffe A schießt präzise als Waffe B, dann ist das natürlich klar Teil seiner Aufgaben. Aber was ich halt auch mache, dass ich halt auf Waffenmessen gehe, also ich war auf der Millipol oder der Enforce Tech und so weiter, also wirklich die großen Fachbesuchermessen im Sicherheitsbereich, weil ich da inzwischen auch Einladungen zu kriege. Das finde ich auch total spannend, weil ich...
Wie heißt denn die Millipol?
Millipol, die ist in Paris und Enforce Tech in Nürnberg. Also Millipol ist wirklich was, wo man richtig fette Maschinengewehre mit Nachtsichtgeräten und kleine Helis kaufen kann und so was. Also richtig Kriegsgerät, während Enforce Tech so Polizei und so auf dem Niveau ist. Also es ist eine Nummer drunter sozusagen. Da war es auch vorher so, ich dachte, ich weiß nicht genau, was ich da will. Also ich könnte nicht vorsagen, ich gehe dorthin, um diese und jene Sache zu berichten oder so. Ich habe gedacht, das ist so ein typisches Ding von, ich kenne niemanden, der je da war und alle finden es irgendwie interessant oder bizarr oder also so. Ich kenne genug Leute, die sagen, klar finde ich waffenmessen scheiße, aber mich interessiert trotzdem, was da los ist. Also weil, was ist das? Er sagt, dann fahre ich mal hin und sage einfach, wie ist das, wenn man einen Tag als Unbedarf sozusagen da rumlungert? Was passiert da? Und das war auch ganz interessant. Zum einen, dass die meisten Leute, die Waffen verkaufen, selber nie in den Gebieten waren, wo die eingesetzt werden, sondern wirklich so richtig Salesman so, ha und hier guck mal und da, wenn du zehn kaufst, gibt es das elf drum sonst und wir haben es auch in lila und auch in blau. Aber so völlig distanzlos während die Militärs, die ich da getroffen habe, zwar auch klar sagen, naja, sie brauchen was, was kosteneffizient Leute abwehrt oder tötet, klar, aber die, die wirklich im Einsatz waren, da hat man gemerkt, die hatten einfach einen anderen Bezug zumindest dazu. Also die haben zumindest noch verstanden, dass sie da mit Menschen töten am Ende und haben das nicht als ihren paycheck am Monatsende gesehen oder so. Das war halt so der Unterschied. Und so bizarre Dinge oder die Ironie ist auf der Millipol, der Hersteller von diesen Bomben-Schutzanzügen, von den Bombenentschärfern aus den USA nicht angereist ist aus Sicherheitsgründen, weil die Angst hatten vor Anschlägen in Paris.
Hätte mal jemand fragen sollen, der sich damit auskennt, sich davor zu schützen.
Da habe ich auch nur gedacht, das ist so, das kann man halt nicht fassen. Oder auch schon beim Eingang, da waren halt so wie Flughafen Sicherheitschecks mit durch Leuchten und allem. Und direkt dahinter waren die ersten Stände, wo man Waffen ausprobieren konnte.
Also, wo ich auch dachte, dass irgendwie, ja, sein könnte, dass du irgendwie, was weiß ich, einen Liter Milch oder so was reinbringen willst, oder ein Überraschungsei, wo wir gelernt haben, hat verschluckbare Teile.
Das ist sehr gefährlich. Aber das fand ich auch, das sind so, also wo ich denke, und das sind so zum einen die lustigen Bizarrensachen. Und zum anderen habe ich auch gesehen, gerade der Artikel über die Millipol, den ich geschrieben habe, ich glaube, den haben 100 oder 150.000 Leute gelesen, was für mich eine abstruse Reichweite einfach ist. Auf Deutsch? Auf Deutsch, genau. Also wirklich auch mit einem beschwenkten Einzugsbereich. Ich hatte auch immer wieder überlegt, ob ich meine Sachen mehr ins Englisch übersetzen soll oder ich selber eh nicht. Das würde ich dann jemanden machen lassen. Hätte ich auch gemerkt. Eigentlich ist es umgekehrt. Ich kenne viele Leute, die gerne mehr auf Deutsch lesen würden. Also in meiner ganzen Peergroup spricht jeder Englisch und liest Englisch. Kein Problem. Aber trotzdem merke ich dann immer, dass es ja doch viele Leute gibt, denen selbst Englisch lesen schwerfällt. Also was aus meiner Filterbubble total obskur ist, weil das irgendwie gerade bei Techies ja parallel läuft, aber gibt es viel. Deswegen bleibe ich meist bei Deutsch. Und wenn sich jemand findet, lasse ich es halt auf Englisch übersetzen. Gerade meine Artikel aus Kurdistan, meist nach ein, zwei Wochen übersetzt das irgendjemand. Das klappt gut.
Freiwillig oder beauftragt?
Freiwillig meist. Also, irgendwer meldet sich meist oder sagt, hey, soll ich das nicht doch mal besetzen? Das ist auch ganz angenehm, eigentlich, finde ich, dass auch solche Sachen funktionieren. Also so, ohne dass man sich groß drum kümmern muss, weil die sagen, ich kann gutes Englisch, also auch dieses spezifische, ich kann dir das mal machen, dauert halt eine Weile, wenn ich Zeit habe. Das ist auch ein Punkt, wo ich sehe, also ich blogge ja auch zu anderen Themen, mal mehr, mal weniger Sachen, oder wenn ich hier auf Neonazi Demos war, erzähle ich halt, wie, also auf den Gegendemos, wie war die Stimmung oder was passierte einfach, so Dinge, die mich halt betreffen irgendwie, aber das lesen halt ein paar Leute und fertig. Aber diese Sachen Waffenmesse und Kurdistan, die Artikel lesen regelmäßig so in der Größenordnung von 100.000 Leuten, wo ich auch dachte, das finde ich immer total krass, wie viele Leute das lesen, weil ich denke, erst mal es gibt viel über das Thema zu lesen. Also ich bin ja bei Weib nicht die einzige Quelle. Und es gibt auch immer wieder Leute, die irgendwie drüber bloggen, was sie persönlich da erlebt haben oder so. Also es ist kein breiter Markt. Aber wenn man danach sucht, findet man was. Und 100.000 Leser ist selbst für eine Zeitschrift, also gezielte Leser, ist immer noch eine große Reichweite. Und das wundert mich immer, wie dieses Interesse an diesen Themen so extrem groß ist, wenn man da sozusagen persönlich drüber berichtet. Also das hat mich am Anfang schon gewundert, wo die ganzen Leute herkommen. Also warum lesen die das? Gerade weil meine Texte halbwegs lang dann oft sind.
Na gut, ich meine, ob sie jetzt zu Ende gelesen werden und so, wissen wir ja nicht. Aber was ziehst du da selber für eine Schlussfolgerung draus?
Also mir scheint, dass Leute zum einen so ein bisschen, wie bei der Sendung mit der Maus, die interessieren Dinge, die sie nicht kennen. Also so nicht, dass sie unbedingt darauf warten, dass ich was über Kurdistan schreibe. Aber wenn es durch die Timeline geht und man ist jemand, der so durchschnittlich Nachrichten konsumiert, dann sagt man, habe ich irgendwie am Rande gehört? Ist ja interessant. Gerade, sagen wir, wenn du so was teilst und sagst, hey, mein Kumpel Enno war da, dann hat man so diese Chain of Trust. So das ist nicht so ein anonymer Artikel, sondern wenn der Tim das sagt, dann wird das schon irgendwie sinnvoll sein. So nach dem Motto, dann klingt man schon mal eher. Und dann denke ich gerade dadurch, dass ich das so aus meiner Sicht erkläre oder also so versuche, auch immer ein bisschen Kontext zu geben. Also zum Teil, also meist, wenn ich den Artikel schreibe, dann schicke ich die Rohfassung vorher an so 20, 30 Freunde oder so, die das so ein bisschen interessiert und sag mal was zu, ist das verständlich? Und da war so manchmal der Kritikpunkt, dass ich Dinge erkläre, die ich doch vor anderthalb Jahren schon im Blogpost hatte, im Detail. Und ich denke ja, aber die, die bei mir lesen, ich glaube nicht, dass ich eine große Fanbase habe, die jeden Artikel von mir liest, sondern die meisten werden zufällig draufkommen. Wenn ich zum Beispiel nur schreibe, ich wollte nach Schingal und das ging nicht, dann wissen die meisten nicht, wo es geht. Und wenn ich sage, ich wollte dahin, das ist der Ort, wo die jesiden, blablabla, so einfach mal zwei Sätze Kontext geben. Ich glaube, das ist für viele Leute angenehm, dass man sozusagen sagt, man liest das einmal und hat das ganze Thema im Prinzip fürs nächste halbe Jahr abgefrühstückt. Man kann sagen, jetzt bin ich der Experte, ich weiß alles, aber ich muss nicht so viel drüber lesen. Also irgendwie so eine Kombination daraus und dass ich denke, dass das so eine gewisse Authentizität hat. Also auch wenn man mich nicht kennt, dass wenn man es liest, aber sagt, dass das ist halt nicht gestalzt oder steht nicht immer bei. Und wie die CDU sagt, ist das besonders gut oder so. Also nicht, dass es offensichtlich gefärbt ist von einer Partei oder Organisation oder so, sondern dass das so ist, das ist jemand, der ist da und erzählt mir, wie er es erlebt. Also auch ohne den Anspruch auf, ich habe das Weltwissen gefressen, sondern das ist meine Sicht nach meiner Erfahrung, nach was ich so kenne. Also das würde ich mir so vermuten. Denke ich auch bei deinen Podcasts teilweise, die höre ich dann sehr unregelmäßig, aber wo ich auch immer denke, das Thema hätte ich mir selber nie angeguckt. Aber es ist total interessant, irgendwas zu erfahren und wo ich denke, so das Übliche, wenn du das machst, gehe ich von aus, das ist sinnvoll aufbereitet. Also es ist keine Zeitverschwendung, dass ich mir das anhöre, weil du lang genug sozusagen die Forschungsloben bekommen hast. Mir scheint, so rum profitiere ich von meinem Netzwerk. Also wenn Leute, die irgendwie bekannt sind, seit Journalisten oder Podcasts oder Blogger oder sowas, und die teilen meinen Artikel, dass deren Leser schafft, dann halt dem folgt.
Welche Rolle spielen denn so die sozialen Medien dann in dem Zusammenhang konkret?
Die allerwichtigste. Also meine Hauptreichweite, wenn ich selber was teile, ist Facebook. Da habe ich halt ungefähr 40.000 Fans auf der Fanpage. Bei Twitter sind es dann im Verhältnis nur irgendwie sechseinhalbtausend Follower oder so. Aber was ja immer schon ganz okay ist. Dann den Vorteil hätte ich nie gedacht, dass der so groß ist, dass ich sowohl auf Facebook als auch auf Twitter diesen blauen Haken habe. Das ist für viele Leute offensichtlich ein Qualitätsmerkmal. Auch wenn es das ja gar nicht genau inhaltlich überhaupt gar keinen...
Zu welchem Zeitpunkt hast du den bekommen, als sie schon irgendwie richtig Unterlagen sehen wollten oder als sie die noch so frei verteilt haben?
Ich habe das von beiden einfach so bekommen. Ich habe mich da selber nie drum gekümmert.
Das ging mir auch so.
Also ich hatte so bei Facebook so trivial in der Benachrichtigung, so ihr Account wurde verifiziert oder so zwischen jemand hat auf Like geklickt.
So etwas bekam ich bei Twitter.
Ich dachte mir so, wie habt ihr das jetzt noch verifiziert?
Hab ich irgendwie nicht mitbekommen. Aber das ist so, also da merke ich meine Haupt-, also die eigene Reichweite halt Facebook. Und auf Twitter merkt man dann immer, wenn es auf einen wichtigen Multiplikator getroffen ist oder so, dann explodiert es halt auf einmal. Ja, ganz unterschiedlich irgendwie. Und auch ja, klar, schlichtweg tageszeit- und tagesformabhängig und so weiter. Wenn man zum falschen Zeitpunkt postet, passiert halt nichts. Und manchmal, wenn ich da noch mal schreibe, hier übrigens noch mal der Hinweis auf meinen Artikel für die Tagschicht, die Spätschicht, die Nachtschicht, wie auch immer. Und auf einmal liest es der Richtige und dann geht es halt ab. Also es ist ganz unterschiedlich. Ich hatte zum Beispiel mal zu einem ganz anderen Thema vor, Ewigkeiten, was geschrieben, warum sind E-Books nicht kostenlos, sondern warum muss man als Verlag Geld für nehmen und warum entstehen dann tatsächlich Kosten damit? So triviale Dinge wie Fotorechte kosten Geld, egal ob fürs E-Book oder nicht. Und der Designer möchte sein Geld, egal ob er das E-Book designt oder das gedruckte Buch und der Marketplace möchte auch Geld.
Also ein E-Book macht sich ja auch nicht selbst, schreibt sich ja nicht selbst.
Ja, eben. Und das war zum Beispiel ein Artikel, also damals war es so, da war ich noch Pressesprecher von einer Piratenpartei und die Piraten hatten noch Relevanz und ich war halt Verleger und in der Piratenpartei war es so, als eine ganz obskure Doppelrolle gesehen wurde, auch wenn es faktisch gar kein Problem war. Und das haben damals innerhalb von wenigen Tagen eine Viertelmillion Leute gelesen, einfach weil es auf ein paar Leute getroffen ist bei den Piraten, die das sozusagen gepusht haben, die damals eine Riesenreichweite hatten. Auf der anderen Seite der Börsenverein des Buchhandels, wo man so zwei ganz verschiedene Schienen hatte und wo sich jeder aber drin bestätigt sah im Text, dass er es doch quasi richtig erklärt oder so. Da ich gemerkt, das war irgendwie so im richtigen Moment das richtige Thema und mit mir im richtigen Bekanntheitsgrad sozusagen und wie das so zusammenkam. Dann habe ich später Sachen geschrieben, die ich viel interessanter und spannender fand. Und die hat keiner gelesen. Also so, weil es halt gerade nicht von allen Faktoren her gepasst hat. Aber gut, das denke ich, wirst du ja auch kennen.
Ja gut, ich mache mir, machen wir so Reichweiten ehrlich gesagt wenig Gedanken. Ich denke immer nur, was am Ende interessant ist, das wird auch schon seine Abnehmer finden. Das spricht sich halt einfach rum. Man kann sich ja da auch irgendwie so ein bisschen irre machen und diesen ganzen Zero-Wahnsinn und so. Da denke ich gar nicht erst drüber nach.
Da bekomme ich immer tolle Angebote. Ach ja, ich auch. Das Spannende ist, was ich da am lustigsten finde, dass die Leute sagen, na, aber du kannst halt mehr Umsatz machen. Da sage ich, okay, geht nicht anders, weil derzeit ist mein Umsatz null. Also so, wie viele Leute...
Das lässt sich doch leicht steigern.
Das finde ich halt immer spannend, wie viele Leute auch nicht verstehen, dass man Dinge in erster Linie macht, weil man sie machen will. Ich denke, wenn ich damit mal Geld verdiene, habe ich natürlich auch nichts gegen. Das war ja nicht der Antrieb, dass ich gesagt habe, ich will Geld verdienen und ich suche ein Businessmodell. Das sehe ich halt ganz viel auch, also gerade bei so Bloggern und Podcastern, wo es ja viel so ist, die fangen so an und manche verdienen mal Geld mit, manche nicht oder so. Oder zum Beispiel bei Sascha Lobo, wo ich denke, der ist halt bekannt gewesen und hat dann zum Beispiel Sachen bekommen, für einen Vortrag bezahlt oder irgendwas in der Art. Oder denk Leute wie du, du hast ja auch nicht irgendwie wahrscheinlich vor 20 Jahren dargesessen und gesagt, wie mache ich jetzt Geld mit meinem MacBook? Sondern das irgendwie ergibt sich ja, dass man bei manchen Leuten läuft so, bei manchen anders. Und diese Szene versteht das oft gut. Und wenn ich dann aber mit so klassischem Journalismus zu tun habe oder Zeitung oder sowas, für die ist oft unbegreiflich, wie ich das nicht aus kommerziellem Hauptinteresse mache. Das finde ich auch immer interessant, wie so diese Netzwelt und sozusagen die Papierwelt da so auseinander drifft.
Da wollte ich jetzt gerade noch mal drauf münden und vielleicht unser Thema auch noch mal kurz noch mal einzufangen, wie sich dieses Verhältnis so entwickelt. Ich meine, es mag ja auch spezielle Publikationen geben, die sich dem Kurdistan-Thema ohnehin mehr annehmen. Also jetzt gar nicht mal so kurden Organisationen oder so, sondern, weiß nicht, so Magazine für internationale Beziehungen. Es gibt ja auch so außenpolitische Zeitschriften, die jetzt so keiner groß kennt, aber die ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht gerade auch so diese Politik-Bereich beschicken. Hast du da auch irgendwie Kontakte aufmachen können?
Also ich habe, also was ich immer wieder mal habe, das kleinere Zeitungen oder so was oder so Magazine wie der Freitag oder so was. Also online, also sagen wir jetzt halt nicht Blog, sondern wirklich online Magazine, dass ich sowas auf der Skala mal melde und sage, können wir das Foto von dir benutzen? Wir haben aber keine bis nicht Kohle. Im Normalfall denke ich auch klar, können sie benutzen, weil wenn ich nein sage, benutzen sie es nur nicht. Da habe ich auch nichts von gewonnen. Also so und kommt halt immer darauf an. Also und wenn jemand nicht selber unendlich reich mit wird und mir nichts abgibt, denke ich, soll er doch machen. Also wenn es irgendwie einen Sinn hat. Ansonsten ist es selten. Was ich allerdings da interessant fand, gerade 2015, als ich in Schingal war, haben fast 30 Zeitungen, Zeitschriften, TV-Sender und so weiter Material von mir benutzt. Also Fotos und Videos und so weiter, wo auch mein Urheberrechtshinweis drin war, den haben die meisten dann gekonnt überblendet mit ihrem Logo. Allerdings hat mich niemand gefragt.
Also Videomaterial.
Genau, Videomaterial und auch Fotos zum Teil oder also Screenshots daraus. Allerdings hat niemand das lizenziert oder mich gefragt. Und wo ich dachte, so fand ich erst mal interessant und habe dann überlegt, wie geht man jetzt mit um? Also so mit Tod verklagen und so, das finde ich immer so, weiß ich nicht. Hat man ja im Prinzip nichts von, außer dass man sagt, habe ich gemacht. Und hatte dann erst mal die, also alle, die es gesendet haben, also Spiegel TV N24 oder so weiter angemailt und gesagt, hey, ich habe das bei euch gesehen, ich würde das gerne lizenzieren, das Material.
Was kostet das denn?
Und habe tatsächlich Angebote bekommen, also ich habe es auch mit meinem Namen geschickt. Ich habe da nicht irgendwie eine anonyme Identität also benutzt und ich habe dann für einen vierstelligen Betrag pro Minute mein Material angeboten gekriegt. Leider habe ich dann also einen Anwalt, mit dem ich später gesprochen habe, meinte, boah, hättest du das mal gemacht, also oder einfach gezeigt und gesagt, ich habe es bei euch gescreencasted, aber ich habe keinen Bock zu zahlen, gucken, ob sie dich verklagen.
Dann hätte man ja eine richtig lustige Nummer draus bauen können.
Okay, so kompliziert habe ich nicht gedacht. Ich hatte dann einfach einen langen Blogpost gemacht und halt geschrieben, wer alles mein Material benutzt hat, ohne es zu lizenzieren. Die Reaktionen waren spannend. Die beste Reaktion, muss ich sagen, kam von Spiegel. Die haben mich sofort angerufen und gesagt, sorry, keine Ahnung, was schief gelaufen ist, wir kümmern uns jetzt aber drum und klären das. Wo ich dachte, das ist ja erst mal ein guter Anfang. Also ich meine, klar, kann der Menge schiefgehen und dass die in der Verwertungskette am Ende nicht wissen, wo es am Anfang herkommt, passiert. Mit denen war das aber auch wirklich innerhalb von einer Stunde geklärt, wo ich dachte, okay, kann passieren, ich bin jetzt auch nicht persönlich sauer drum. Dann gab es andere, die haben gesagt, also zum Beispiel die Welt wollte erst mal, dass ich ihrer Rechtsabteilung nachweise, dass das Material von mir ist, weil da kann ja jeder kommen.
Das sicher nicht.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ihr euer Logo wegnimmt, ist da drunter mein Copyright Enno Lenze. Das wäre so ein Hinweis, aber wollen wir nicht in die Details gehen. Und dann gab es welche, die haben gesagt, also wenn ich nicht den Hinweis auf meiner Homepage lösche, dass sie das unlicensiert benutzt haben, dann arbeiten sie nie wieder mit mir.
Was sie ja bis dahin auch schon nicht getan haben.
Das haben wir bisher nicht. Und ich habe gar kein Interesse mit euch zu arbeiten. Die Drogen greift ins Leere. Oder es gab welche wie T-Online, also T-Online-News oder wie das heißt. Die haben sich auch gemeldet.
Die Telekom sind?
Genau. Und die haben sich halt gemeldet und einfach gesagt, sorry, also irgendwo am Anfang der Kette lief was schief. Keine Frage. Also erst mal sollen sie es löschen oder können sie es behalten, wenn sie den Hinweis ergänzen oder wie geht es jetzt weiter und was können wir tun, quasi damit wir Freunde bleiben. Aber direkt, sie haben keinen großen Etat, weil das halt nicht ist keine Geldmachmaschine, sondern so eine Art Service-Einrichtung an der Seite. Ich habe gesagt, hey, wenn man ehrlich miteinander redet, ist doch am einfachsten. Und die haben dann einfach im Artikel ergänzt, was ich da gemacht habe. Also einfach quasi geschrieben, wie sie an das Material gekommen sind und dass ich das da halt gemacht habe und so weiter. Damit werde ich quasi so gewürdigt. Genau.
Ja und auch verlinkt und das hat auch einen Wert. Klickzahlen haben die, glaube ich, ganz ordentliche.
Jaja, genau. Und da dachte ich auch zum einen, sie nehmen wahr, dass sie was falsch gemacht haben. Das finde ich, ist ja so der Kern der Sache. Also, dass man sich halt nicht verarscht vorkommt. Sie haben freundlich reagiert und habe gesagt, das ist doch alles okay. Also, ja, damit kann ich leben. Aber es geht ja eben drum, wie geht man mit um? Also, da fand ich, das fand ich wieder sehr spannend, wie unterschiedlich das halt war. Aber auch in den, also selbst innerhalb vom gleichen Konzern, zum Beispiel Bild benutzt ab und zu Material von mir. Aber die sind da sehr, sehr, sehr simpel. Die rufen halt an oder schicken eine Mail und sagen, das Foto, was du gerade gepostet hast, kannst du uns das in einer hohen Auflösung schicken und wir zahlen dir unseren üblichen Fotosatz. Der ist halt jetzt nicht im Bereich von beeindruckend, aber man wird behandelt, wie alle anderen Ausnahmen gemacht. Und wo ich dann denke, ja klar, nimm halt, fertig. Aber so, mit denen hatte ich lustigerweise noch nie Probleme und immer wieder mit ihnen zu tun gehabt, wo ich dachte, warum können die ein Telefon bedienen und die anderen nicht. Also finde ich auch ganz komisch.
Kann man daraus ablesen, dass es so, sagen wir mal, für Journalisten, ich weiß gar nicht, wie groß die Zahl ist. Also gibt es Journalisten, die so vergleichbar wie du in solchen Regionen arbeiten, eigenständig Material produzieren und das anbieten und lässt sich daraus ablesen, dass es für die jetzt auch nicht gerade einfach ist, so ein Lifestyle zu finanzieren?
Hartes Business. Sie machen das echt aus Überzeugung einfach. Ich habe mal mit einem gesprochen, der wirklich von Kriegsgebiet zu Kriegsgebiet jettet, die ganze Zeit, also immer da, wo es knallt. Also er hat jetzt nach Abzug der Kosten und allem im Jahr ungefähr 30.000 Netto. Ich dachte, das ist jetzt nicht so beeindruckend, dass man es für die Kohle macht. Also gerade mit einer sehr, sehr unsicheren Perspektive immer, was so passiert.
Einschließlich des eigenen Überlebens.
Genau. Und der sagte aber so, das ist halt wie so eine Sucht. Also er findet spannend, er kennt sich aus und er hängt da sozusagen drin fest. Und dann kenne ich eben die Leute von der BILD, also Klaas Weinmann und Paul Ronzheimer, die sozusagen die Kriegsberichterstatter da in Kurdistan, Irak sind. Darüber haben wir uns kennengelernt, die wirklich wochenlang da vor Ort waren. Und da hatte ich halt erst, also so dem Klischee nach Age Zweifel, warum die überhaupt hinfliegen und nicht einfach ihre Story schreiben, so wie man es von der BILD sich vorstellt. Und die haben halt gesagt, das ist recht trivial, find mal eine andere Zeitung, wo du sagst, ich flieg da mal vier Wochen hin und ich gucke mal, ob ich was schreiben kann als Festangestellter, für den die auch noch verantwortlich sind, wenn dir das passiert. Und danach hatte ich halt erst mal so andere Zeitungen gefragt und noch gesagt, habt ihr denn, also habt ihr eigene festangestellte Leute, die ihr da hinschickt? Und die Antwort war fast immer, nee, also von unseren Leuten schicken wir sicher keinen hin, ist ja viel zu gefährlich. Sagt gut, das heißt, man hat zumindest, scheint mir es bisher so, die Chance, du machst das auf eigene Rechnung mit größtem personellen und finanziellen Risiko. Oder du machst das für sowas wie BILD oder sicherlich auch noch eine Handvoll anderer, aber so die, die halt die Kohle haben, aber die so das klassische, dass du sozusagen für eine große, seriöse Zeitung als festangestellter, solide sowas machst, das scheint mir total auszusterben. Und das finde ich halt extrem schade und auch bedenklich, weil das heißt ja umgekehrt, dass die allermeisten Leute die hinfliegende Story bringen müssen, weil wenn du sagst, da war nichts los, dann kriegst du deine Reisekosten nicht rein. Also muss was passiert sein, was natürlich meist auch der Fall ist. Oder es kommt drauf an, wie man schreibt. Aber wenn garantiert gar nichts passiert, im Zweifel musst du dir irgendwas aus den Fingern saugen, damit du deine Kosten drin hast. Und das kann es halt nicht sein, weil dann ist man nicht mehr im Bereich von einer soliden Berichterstattung. Und das finde ich das Gefährliche dran. Was ich da noch spannend fand, von zwei Freelancern, die haben mir Mails geschickt, als ich diesen Blogpost geschrieben habe, dass also meine Sachen da unlinzenziert benutzt wurden. Und die haben gesagt, finden sie total geil, weil ihnen ist so was auch allen schon mal passiert, aber sie können halt schlecht nach außen gehen, weil sie dann Auftraggeber verlieren. Und da ich auch gesagt, das kann doch bei einem Land mit Pressefreiheit und Demokratie und einem Rechtsstaat eigentlich nicht sein, dass man sagt, ja Schwamm, darüber muss ja die Kohle haben.
Ja, Enno, durchs wilde Kurdistan eine Reise. Jetzt sind wir schon fast bei der Medienkritik angekommen. Was gibt es denn noch? Hast du denn noch irgendwas, was du noch zum Ausdruck bringen möchtest, so in dem Zusammenhang?
Ich glaube, wir hatten alles in der Zeit, einmal quer durch.
Wann steht der nächste Ausflug in die Region an?
Ich denke in einem halben Jahr ungefähr wieder. Also ich bin ungefähr zweimal im Jahr da, weil ich halt hier auch zu viel zu tun habe, schlichtweg. Also es ist ja quasi mein Urlaub immer, den ich da verbringe. Also ich denke im Frühjahr wieder, aber das kommt darauf an, wie es sich jetzt entwickelt.
Also das ist bei dir schon so eingepreist?
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Mallorca hat keine Chance mehr.
Ich habe auch meine Ausrüstung, also die medizinische Versorgung, schlussig, Westerhelm und alles dort liegen bei einem Freund. Also ich habe einen ganzen Koffermaterial dort, der da schon fest ist, weil ich ihn eh über die Jahre nicht...
Du hast noch einen Koffer in Erbil.
Genau, das lustige ist, nicht nur ich, bei dem Zuhause stehen ungefähr 20 Koffer. Also dem gehört der Deutsche Hof in Erbil, ein deutscher Biergarten, wo man Schweinssachs und so essen kann. Gunther, ein spannender, verrückter Typ. Und mir scheint jeder Journalist aus Deutschland, der in der Gegend unterwegs ist, hat bei Gunther ein Koffer mit seinem Equipment.
Berlin, Erbil, nur ein Buchstabe und man kriegt es schön durch die Gegend geschüttelt. Sogar auf Google verzeichnet. Da fühlt man sich doch ganz wie zu Hause. Na gut, Enno, dann sage ich mal vielen Dank.
Sehr gerne.
Für die Ausführungen hier zu Kurdistan und alles, was damit zu tun hat. Ich werde das auf jeden Fall weiter verfolgen. Insofern an alle, die hier zugehört haben. Ich hoffe, ihr fand es interessant. Ich sage Tschüss und bis bald.